LET ME DO THAT AS THE CHAIR OF
THE SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE
CONVENED THIS INFORMATION
HEARING IN CONCERT WITH THE
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. I AM VERY GRATEFUL
FOR EVERYONE'S ENGAGEMENT IN
TODAY'S TOPIC. THE STATE OF
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION,
COORDINATION AND COLLABORATION.
EACH SEGMENT OF CALIFORNIA'S
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM PLAYS A
VITAL ROLE IN CALIFORNIA'S
FUTURE. EACH HAS A UNIQUE
CONTRIBUTION. WE MUST AFFORD
EQUAL APPRECIATION AND
CONSIDERATION TO EACH THEIR
MISSION STATEMENT TO EXPRESS HOW
BEST TO MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
STATE AND PROVIDE THE FRAMEWORK
WITHIN WHICH THE STATE FUNDS AND
SUPPORTS HIGHER EDUCATION
PROGRAMS AND IN ISSUES. MORE
IMPORTANTLY, THEY SHARE A DEEPER
MISSION BEYOND THE DIVISION
BETWEEN THEM TO PROVIDE
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY AND
SUCCESS TO ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S
PEOPLE. WE HAVE FOUR SEGMENTS OF
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION.
CALIFORNIA REPUBLIC ONE PRIVATE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE THE
GATEWAY TO EQUITY, PROVIDING
ACCESS TO TOP QUALITY, LOWER
DIVISION TRANSFER AND VOCATIONAL
EDUCATION. THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITIES OFFER QUALITY
UNDERGRADUATE GRADUATE AND
PROFESSIONAL EDUCATION, REGARDED
AMONG THE WORLD'S LEADING
TEACHING UNIVERSITIES. THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IS THE
STATE PREMIER RESEARCH
UNIVERSITY AND ITS RESEARCH
SCHOLARS AND SCIENTISTS. PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE IN THE ECONOMIC
AND SOCIAL DEVELOPMENT OF THIS
GREAT STATE. THE PRIVATE
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES,
UNIVERSITIES OF THE STATE ARE
ESSENTIAL AND VALUABLE
COMPONENTS OF CALIFORNIA'S
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM.
NEEDLESS TO SAY, THAT OUR
UNIVERSITIES AND COLLEGES PLAY A
FUNDAMENTAL ROLE IN OUR STATE
THAT AGREE TO WHICH THESE
INSTITUTIONS COLLABORATE AND
COORDINATE THEIR EFFORTS
DIRECTLY INFLUENCES THEIR
ABILITY TO ADDRESS THE EVOLVING
NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS IN THE
WORKFORCE, ENSURING THAT EVERY
ASPECT OF THE SYSTEM IS
FUNCTIONING EFFECTIVELY FOR THE
BENEFIT OF ALL CALIFORNIA. THE
STATE HAS BEEN WITHOUT A HIGHER
EDUCATION COORDINATING BODY FOR
MORE THAN A DECADE, AND A
DISCUSSION OF THE CURRENT
CONDITIONS OF HOW DIFFERENT
ELEMENTS OF THE STATE'S HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM WORK TOGETHER
IS WORTH HAVING. I LOOK FORWARD
TO HAVING A ROBUST CONVERSATION
ON AREAS OF SUCCESS, CHALLENGES
AND STRATEGIES FOR ENHANCING
COORDINATION AND COLLABORATION.
TODAY WE WILL HAVE THREE PANELS.
FIRST WE'LL HAVE AN OVERVIEW
DISCUSSION WITH STAKEHOLDER
EXPERTS, INCLUDING REMARKS AND
BACK TO SUSAN JEZ, WITH
CALIFORNIA COMPETES. NON
PARTISAN, HIGHER EDUCATION
POLICY AND RESEARCH ORGANIZATION
IN IN AUDREY DOW WITH THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
, A HIGHER EDUCATION
ORGANIZATION FOCUSED ON STUDENT
SUCCESS ISSUES. NEXT WE WILL
HEAR FROM HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM REPRESENTATIVES ABOUT
THEORIES OF SUCCESS. GEOLOGISTS
STRATEGIES FOR ENHANCING
COORDINATION AND LAST WE WILL
HEAR FROM FACULTY FROM AN
IMPLEMENTATION STANDPOINT. THANK
YOU ALL AGAIN FOR BEING HERE. WE
HAVE A VERY FULL AGENDA, SO I'LL
TRY TO KEEP US ON TRACK. AND ON
TIME THAT BEING SAID, I'D LIKE
TO TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S PHªN FOR HIS
OPENING REMARKS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. SENATOR NEWMAN FOR THAT
WARM INTRODUCTION AND SO EXCITED
, JOIN EACH AND EVERYONE OF US
HERE TODAY TO HAVE A ROBUST
CONVERSATION. I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK MY FELLOW MEMBERS FROM
BOTH HOUSES, PANELISTS AND
PUBLIC FOR JOINING US AT TODAY'S
MEETING. ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
HIGHER EDUCATION HOLIDAY
FANTASTIC INFORMATION HEARING IN
OCTOBER AT EAST LOS ANGELES
COMMITTEE COLLEGE. TO TALK ABOUT
ENROLLMENT DECLINE, LEARNING
LOSS RETENTION AND RECRUITMENT
STRATEGIES. A MAJOR TAKEAWAY
FROM THAT HEARING WAS IMPORTANCE
OF COLLABORATION. CAMPUSES THAT
WERE BEING INNOVATIVE AND REALLY
ENGAGING THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITIES
WHO ARE OBSERVING ENCOURAGING
GROWTH AND STRONGER ENGAGEMENT
FROM THE COMMUNITY CAMPUSES AND
THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITIES WORK
TOGETHER TO FIND SOLUTIONS. WE
SEE CREATIVE SOLUTIONS TO
COMPLEX PROBLEMS, AND OUR
HEARING TODAY ALSO DEMONSTRATED
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS WERE
COLLABORATIVE TO FIND SOLUTIONS
IN THEIR REGIONS. AND HAS
CREATED ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
FOR STUDENTS. AS WE MENTIONED
EARLIER, SENATORS MENTIONED
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES, CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND ARE INDEPENDENT
INSTITUTIONS. EACH CONTRIBUTE
MEANINGFULLY TO OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION ECOSYSTEM. THESE
SCHOOLS EDUCATE THE NEXT
GENERATION OF LEADERS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES, HELPING TO CREATE
ENGAGED CITIZENS WHILE ALSO
ADDRESSING OUR FUTURE WORKFORCE
NEEDS. OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM FUNDAMENTALLY ADDRESSES
CALIFORNIA WHITE PROBLEMS AND
THERE NEEDS TO BE A SPACE FOR US
TO EXPLORE CALIFORNIA WHITE
SOLUTIONS AND IN FOSTERING THAT
STATEWIDE COLLABORATION AND
COORDINATION WE CAN HELP TO
PROVIDE FERTILE GROUND FOR
REGIONAL PARTNERSHIPS TO
CONTINUE TO GROW AND PROSPER AS
A STATE. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH
AGAIN TO ALL OUR PANELISTS FOR
COMING TO TESTIFY TODAY,
IRRESPECTIVE INSIGHTS WILL HELP
US IMMENSELY AND UNDERSTANDING
PERSPECTIVES. AND CHALLENGES
FACED BY INSTITUTIONS TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AGAINST
INTERNET THANK YOU. CHAIR PHªN.
WE WILL BE JOINED BY SOME OF OUR
OTHER COLLEAGUES AS WE MOVE
ALONG. LET ME FIRST BEFORE WE
START. LET ME WELCOME
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S SHERRY
QUICKSILVER. REMEMBER THE
COMMENTS JUST OAN. BUT SINCE
I'M THE OTHER ONLY OTHER ONE
HERE, OF COURSE. NO I'M REALLY
EXCITED TO BE HERE. I'M BACK ON
THE HIGHER ED COMMITTEE. I WAS
ON A HANDFUL OF YEARS AGO AND
I'M HAPPY TO RETURN. MY DISTRICT
HAS THE KELL STATE FULLERTON,
THE GREAT TITANS, BUT I ALSO
HAVE ONE OF THE OLDEST COMMUNITY
COLLEGES FULLERTON COLLEGE IN MY
DISTRICT AND IN THE NEW PART OF
MY DISTRICT. I HAVE THREE TOES
COLLEGE, WHICH BORDERS SYRIA,
TOES AND NORWALK. SO WE ARE
DEFINITELY INVESTED IN EDUCATION
, WITH THOUSANDS OF INDIVIDUALS
GRADUATING FROM MY DISTRICT A D
67 AND WE KNOW THAT THERE IS
PRESSING ISSUES FACING NOT ONLY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES, BUT
ADDITIONAL HIGHER AD AND I, AS
THE CHAIR NOTED, WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO COLLABORATE
AS WE MOVE FORWARD. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. AND THAT IS AN
EXCELLENT SEGUE TO OUR FIRST
PENALTY OVERVIEW PANEL. LET ME
WELCOME TO GINGER SAYS PHD WAS
THE CEO OF CALIFORNIA COMPETES.
WHICH LOOKS AT HIGHER EDUCATION
FOR A STRONG ECONOMY. AND AUDREY
DOW, SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY, PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING TO YOUR NEWMAN
CHAIR. FONG ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S
QUIRK-SILVA. MY NAME IS SUSAN
JAZZ. I'M THE CEO OF CALIFORNIA
COMPETES THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ABOUT
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY WITH HIGHER
EDUCATION, COORDINATION AND
WHERE WE ARE TODAY. A
COORDINATION AT ITS BEST IS
ABOUT THOUGHTFUL INTEGRATION OF
CALIFORNIA'S POLICIES, PROGRAMS,
SERVICES AND RESOURCES THAT
CENTERS THE INDIVIDUAL
CALIFORNIAN RATHER THAN THE
INTERESTS OF STATE AGENCIES OR
UNIVERSITIES AND EMPOWERS MORE
CALIFORNIANS TO DEVELOP THE
KNOWLEDGE AND SKILLS ESSENTIAL
FOR FOSTERING THRIVING
COMMUNITIES. THIS IS A NON
TRIVIAL TASK. CALIFORNIA IS HOME
TO 3.4 MILLION STUDENTS
ATTENDING OVER 500 COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES. NUMEROUS AGENCIES
HOLD HIGHER EDUCATION
RESPONSIBILITIES IN ADDITION
FROM ADMINISTERING FINANCIAL AID
TO OVERSEEING REGIONAL
INITIATIVES. DESPITE THIS VAST,
VAST SCALE AND DIVERSE NEEDS,
CALIFORNIA REMAINS THE ONLY
STATE IN THE NATION WITHOUT A
CENTRAL HIGHER EDUCATION ENTITY.
HOW DID WE GET HERE? CALIFORNIA
HASN'T ALWAYS BEEN WITHOUT A
COORDINATING ENTITY. IN FACT,
WE'VE HAD MANY COORDINATING
BODIES DATING BACK TO AT LEAST
1932 AND EXTENDING TO THE MOST
RECENT ENTITY THAT CALIFORNIA
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
COMMISSION OFTEN COMMONLY CALLED
CPAC, WHICH WAS DEFENDED IN 2011
, OUR FIRST FORMAL STANDING
COORDINATING BODY WAS CREATED IN
THE MASTER PLAN OF 1960. THE
AUTHORS OF THE MASTER PLAN
RECOGNIZED THE NEED FOR
OVERSIGHT AND ALIGNMENT WHEN
RESTRUCTURING CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM
INTO THE THREE SEGMENTS WE HAVE
TODAY AS SUCH, THE MASTER PLAN
ESTABLISHED THE COORDINATING
COUNCIL FOR HIGHER EDUCATION,
WHICH WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR
ENSURING COORDINATION,
DIFFERENTIATION AND EFFICIENT
RESOURCE ALLOCATION ACROSS THE
SEGMENTS. THIS APPROACH FOR
ALIGNMENT SHOWCASED A COMMITMENT
TO PROACTIVE AND STRATEGIC
GOVERNANCE, IF PERHAPS NOT
ALWAYS REALIZED IN PRACTICE IS
FOUNDATIONAL TO WELL INTEGRATED,
HIGH PERFORMING HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM. WHILE THIS ENTITY SERVED
ITS PURPOSE DURING A PERIOD OF
RAPID ENROLLMENT GROWTH, ITS
EFFECTIVENESS WANED OVER TIME
DUE TO STRUCTURAL AND
LIMITATIONS AND EVOLVING NEEDS.
THE ENTITIES, LIMITED AUTHORITY
AND SCOPE. MINT CALIFORNIA
REALLY HAD NO STATEWIDE PLANNING
AND INSTITUTIONAL INTERESTS WERE
PRIORITIZED. IN RESPONSE, THE
STATE CREATED CPAC IN 1973 WITH
MORE PLANNING RESPONSIBILITIES
UNLESS INSTITUTIONAL INFLUENCE
THAN ITS PREDECESSOR. BUT IT TO
FACE CHALLENGES HAD MANY
RESPONSIBILITIES BUT NO
JURISDICTION FOR DECISION MAKING
, MAKING IT DIFFICULT TO
NAVIGATE POWER DYNAMICS ACROSS
GOVERNING BODIES OR ADDRESS
CHALLENGES DIRECTLY WITHOUT
CONSENSUS. IT'S PLANNING AND
ANALYTICAL EFFORTS WERE
UNDERMINED BY A LACK OF CLEAR
STATE GOALS AND LIMITED ACCESS
TO DATA. CPAC AIMED TO SERVE AS
THE STATE'S NONPARTISAN
INDEPENDENT POLICY AND BUDGET
ANALYST FOR HIGHER EDUCATION,
BUT IT WAS ALSO AN ADVOCATE FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION. THESE
CONFLICTING RULES OFTEN MEANT IT
COULD DO NEITHER. WELL
ULTIMATELY SEE PECS.
EFFECTIVENESS ALSO WIND OVER
TIME LEADING TO ITS DEFUNDING IN
2011. CPAC'S RESPONSIBILITIES
WERE EITHER SHIFTED TO OTHER
STATE AGENCIES OR DISCONTINUED
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN TODAY? THE
ABSENCE OF COORDINATION BETWEEN
THE MYRIAD OF PARTNERS MEANS WE
FALL SHORT AND UNDERSTANDING
CALIFORNIA'S NEEDS FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION. ADDRESSING WIDENING
EQUITY GAPS, ASSESSING THE
IMPACT OF POLICY REFORMS AND
PROGRAMS IMPLEMENTED AND
MAXIMIZING RETURNS ON THE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
INVESTMENTS MORE SPECIFICALLY,
THE LACK OF EFFECTIVE
COORDINATION HAS LEFT OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM STRUGGLING TO
SUPPORT CALIFORNIANS ON THEIR
PATH 2 DEGREES COMPLETION AND A
GOOD LIFE. WE SEE IT IN THE
FRACTURED TRANSFER SYSTEM,
DELAYING OR MORE OFTEN BLOCKING
DEGREE ATTAINMENT AND ACCESS TO
BETTER PAYING JOBS. WE SEE IT IN
OUR STUDENTS WHO PUT THEIR
EDUCATIONAL GOALS ON HOLD OFTEN
FOR FOREVER BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
AFFORD COLLEGE. WE SEE IT IN
LABOR SHORTAGE AND CRITICAL
FIELDS LIKE HEALTH AND EDUCATION
THAT HOLD BACK OUR STATE AND ITS
RESIDENTS FROM REACHING THEIR
FULL POTENTIAL. THE RIGOR OF
COURSES AND THE HARD WORK OF
LEARNING SHOULD BE WHAT MAKES
THE JOURNEY TO AND THROUGH
COLLEGE CHALLENGING, NOT
BUREAUCRATIC HURDLES, LIKE
NAVIGATING TRANSFER OR BALANCING
WORK, FAMILY AND SCHOOL. YET
DESPITE THE SUBSTANTIAL
INVESTMENTS IN CALIFORNIA'S
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM, THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
COLLEGE STUDENTS FACE OUTSIDE
THEIR STUDIES. THIS MISALIGNMENT
REFLECTS A FAILURE AND
COORDINATION WITHOUT IT. OUR
STUDENTS, COMMUNITIES AND STATES
SUFFER. THE LEGISLATURE
CONTEMPLATES THE NEXT STEPS FOR
COORDINATION URGE MEMBERS TO
FIRST BE DELIBERATE AND
IDENTIFYING THE PROBLEMS WE AS A
STATE SEEK TO SOLVE AND THEN TO
DESIGN AN ENTITY TO COORDINATE
TOWARDS THAT. THANK YOU CHAIRS,
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES FOR
YOUR THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY, MISTER. WELCOME.
THANK YOU. AND GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN CHAIRS NEWMAN
AND FONG AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME HERE TODAY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING AND,
MORE IMPORTANTLY FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN HIGHER EDUCATION,
WHICH IS CRITICAL, CRITICAL
UNDERTAKING FOR STUDENTS AND FOR
THE FUTURE OF OUR STATE. MY NAME
IS AUDREY DOWN. I'M THE SENIOR
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE CAMPAIGN
FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY. THE
CAMPAIGN IS A NONPROFIT
COALITION OF EDUCATION, CIVIL
RIGHTS AND BUSINESS LEADERS,
REALLY SEEKING TO EXPAND COLLEGE
ACCESS AND STUDENT SUCCESS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA, I AM ALSO A AN
APPOINTED COMMISSIONER OF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION, WHERE I ASSIST IN
GUIDING CALIFORNIA STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID INVESTMENTS IN
PRIORITIES. WE'RE HERE TODAY TO
DISCUSS HIGHER EDUCATION
COORDINATION IN CALIFORNIA AND
SINCE THE DEFUNDING OF THE
CALIFORNIA POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION COMMISSION IN 2011,
THE STATE HAS NOT HAD A BODY
WITH PLANNING AND COORDINATION
AUTHORITY OVER OUR STATE SYSTEMS
OF HIGHER EDUCATION. THE
CHALLENGES THAT SPRING FROM A
LACK OF COORDINATION ARE MANY
AND THEIR URGENT WE HAVE A
BROKEN TRANSFER SYSTEM, THREE
SEPARATE FINANCIAL AID SYSTEMS
THAT STUDENTS WHO OFTEN STRADDLE
TWO OR THREE INSTITUTIONS AT A
TIME MUST NAVIGATE AND OFTEN
MUST NAVIGATE ALONE. WE HAVE AN
ATTAINMENT GOAL, BUT NO PLAN FOR
REACHING THAT GOAL. WE SEE
REGIONAL OR PIECEMEAL APPROACHES
TO SHARING RESOURCES WHEN
SOMETHING MUCH BIGGER AND MORE
POWERFUL IS NEEDED. WE LACK
STANDARDIZED DATA COLLECTION AND
NO ENTITY WITH THE AUTHORITY TO
ANALYZE THAT DATA PROPOSED
RECOMMENDATIONS SUPPORTED BY
THAT DATA, OR TO ENGAGE IN ANY
KIND OF LONG RANGE PLANNING,
USING THE DATA. TO ACHIEVE OUR
ATTAINMENT GOAL. UNFORTUNATELY
FOR OUR STATE, BUT ESPECIALLY
FOR OUR STUDENTS, WE LEAVE
COORDINATION ACROSS THE THREE
SEGMENTS AND SEE SACK TO THE
INDIVIDUAL RELATIONSHIPS OF THE
APPOINTED LEADERS. THE PRESIDENT
THE CSU AND CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
, COLLEGE CHANCELLORS AND THE C
SAC EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS ARE IMPORTANT, BUT
THERE'S NOTHING THAT COMPELS
THEM TO WORK TOGETHER. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY APPARENT IN OUR
BUDGET PROCESS WHEN INSTITUTIONS
COMPETE FOR LIMITED RESOURCES
AND OFTEN SEE EACH OTHER AS
COMPETITORS INSTEAD OF ALLIES.
COORDINATING BODY CAN BE A
NEUTRAL ENTITY WITH ONLY ONE
GOAL IN MIND SERVING STUDENTS.
CALIFORNIA HAS A SPECIAL
PROMINENCE IN NATIONAL POLICY
MAKING. WE'VE ALL HEARD THE
EXPRESSION AS CALIFORNIA GOES,
SO GOES THE NATION. BUT ON THIS
ONE ISSUE WE SEE THE REVERSE.
CALIFORNIA IS THE OUTLIER AND
THE ANOMALY TO OUR OWN DETRIMENT
. WE SEE ALL OTHER STATES HAVING
SOME VERSION OF A HIGHER
EDUCATION COORDINATING BODY.
THEY MAY HAVE DIFFERING DEGREES
OF AUTHORITY AND A TON A ME BUT
EVERY OTHER STATE IN THE NATION
HAS MADE A CONSCIOUS DECISION
THAT YES, IT MAKES SENSE TO
DEVOLVE SOME DEGREE OF DECISION
MAKING AND ANALYSIS AND PLANNING
AUTHORITY TO AN ENTITY THAT HAS
THE EXPERTISE, THE MISSION AND
THE STAFF TO DO SO. WE SEE
COORDINATING BODIES IN RED
STATES AND BLUE STATES. IN FACT,
THERE SEEMS TO BE NO
RELATIONSHIP TO THE POLITICS OF
THE STATE AND WHETHER THEY HAVE
A COMMISSION. RATHER IT IS
UNDERSTOOD TO BE A NECESSARY
TOOL OF GOVERNANCE AND
COORDINATION, CRITICAL TO
ENSURING THAT INSTITUTIONAL
INTERESTS DO NOT DRIVE THE
STATE'S INTERESTS THAT ARE
HIGHER EDUCATION. INVESTMENTS IN
POLICIES ARE GUIDED BY EVIDENCE
AND, MOST IMPORTANTLY, MADE WITH
STUDENTS NEEDS IN MIND. WE CAN
LOOK TO OTHER STATES. OREGON FOR
EXAMPLE, HAS A COORDINATING
ENTITY WITH FORMAL AUTHORITY TO
DECIDE ON AND ALLOCATE
INSTITUTIONAL BUDGET RESOURCES.
THAT WAY. FOR EXAMPLE, THERE WAS
APPROPRIATE VETTING AND ANALYSIS
TO EVALUATE THE CAPITAL NEEDS OF
INDIVIDUAL CAMPUSES AND
DETERMINED FINANCIAL AID NEEDS,
AND THEY DO THIS ANALYSIS
THROUGH AN EQUITY LENS, WHICH IS
THE CORNERSTONE OF OREGON'S
APPROACH TO HIGHER EDUCATION
POLICY AND, MOST IMPORTANTLY,
FUNDING COLORADO IS ANOTHER
EXAMPLE THAT HAS A DISTINCT
DIVISION COORDINATES AND
IMPLEMENTS A STATEWIDE TRANSFER
POLICY, ENSURING SEAMLESS
TRANSFER PATHWAYS AND COURSE
MOBILITY ARE PRIORITIZED. THAT
WE HAVE LINGERED AS A STATE SO
LONG WITHOUT A BODY IS EVEN MORE
EGREGIOUS WHEN YOU CONSIDER THE
COMPLEXITY THAT DISTINGUISHES
CALIFORNIA FROM ALMOST ANY OTHER
STATE. WE HAVE NEARLY 40 MILLION
PEOPLE. THE NEXT CLOSEST STATE
IS TEXAS WITH 30 MILLION. WE ARE
AN INCREDIBLY DIVERSE STATE WITH
OVER HALF THE STATE BEING LATIN
X ASIAN OR AFRICAN AMERICAN. NOT
ONLY THAT, BUT MORE THAN HALF OF
YOUNG CALIFORNIANS ARE COLLEGE
GOING POPULATION ARE LATIN. NEXT
WE HAVE PRONOUNCED INCOME
INEQUALITY WITH AN INCOME GAP
BETWEEN HIGH AND LOW INCOME
FAMILIES, EXCEEDING ALL BUT
THREE OTHER STATES. WE HAVE A
HOUSING CRISIS, WHICH BOTH
REFLECTS AND REINFORCES RACIAL
AND ETHNIC ETHNIC INEQUITIES,
WHICH ALSO REVEAL THEMSELVES IN
OUR SEGREGATED K 12 SCHOOLS AND
DISTRICTS. WE HAVE NOT ONE
SYSTEM OF PUBLIC FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTIONS LIKE OTHER STATES,
BUT TWO WE HAVE THE LARGEST
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM IN THE
WORLD WITH 2.1 MILLION STUDENTS
WITH 64% CLASSIFIED AS
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED. SO
THE QUESTION ISN'T WHY SHOULD WE
HAVE A COORDINATING BODY? THE
QUESTION IS WHY ON EARTH,
WOULDN'T WE? A GOOD EXAMPLE OF
BOTH THE LIMITS AND POTENTIAL OF
COORDINATION CAN BE FOUND IN THE
A B 928 COMMITTEE, WHICH THE
CAMPAIGN WAS APPOINTED TO
PARTICIPATED IN. SIGNED IN 2021
A B 9 TO 8 ARTICULATES A VISION
FOR COORDINATION THAT IS TIME
LIMITED. FOCUSED ON THE ISSUE OF
TRANSFER AND WITH CLEAR
PARAMETERS TO ITS AUTHORITY. A B
9 TO 8 COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN BRINGING
STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER TO WORK ON
UNIFIED GOALS TO IMPROVING
TRANSFER. AS A PUBLIC FACING
VENUE, MANY CONVERSATIONS THAT
WOULD TYPICALLY HAVE OCCURRED
PRIVATELY BEHIND CLOSED DOORS
AND IN SILOS NOW OCCUR PUBLICLY
AND IN COLLABORATION HOWEVER,
THE LIMITS OF THE A B 9 TO 8
COMMITTEE IS THAT ITS AUTHORITY
IS LIMITED TO TRANSFER. DESPITE
THERE BEING MANY AREAS INCLUDING
B, A AND M A GRANTING AUTHORITY
OR CHANGES TO UNDERGRADUATE
ADMISSIONS REQUIREMENTS THAT
REQUIRE COORDINATION. SO
ACTUALLY, THE LESSON IS
COORDINATION IS POSSIBLE, AND
PARTIES CAN BE INCENTIVIZED TO
PARTICIPATE CONSTRUCTIVELY.
IMAGINE FOR A MOMENT IF SOME OF
THE MORE CONTROVERSIAL DEBATES
IN CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER EDUCATION
ECOSYSTEM WEREN'T DECIDED BY ONE
SYSTEMS GOVERNING BOARD WHO HAVE
A VESTED INTEREST IN MAINTAINING
AND STRENGTHENING THE AUTONOMY
AND PRESTIGE OF THEIR SYSTEM,
BUT INSTEAD DELEGATED DECISION
MAKING TO A VENUE WHERE POLICIES
ARE EVALUATED BY WHETHER THEY
SERVE THE RESIDENTS OF THE STATE
, WHETHER THEY CREATE BARRIERS
TO ACCESS OR COMPLETION, IN
ESSENCE, WHETHER THEY ARE IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST. ANOTHER AREA IN
DESPERATE NEED OF COORDINATION
IS BOTH GOAL SETTING AND THE
HARDER PART GOAL ATTAINMENT. THE
NEWSOM ADMINISTRATION HAS
ARTICULATED AND AMBITIOUS
ATTAINMENT GOAL OF 70% MEANING
70% OF THE STATE HAS A
CREDENTIAL OF VALUE BY 2030. BUT
HOW DO YOU ACTUALIZE A GOAL THAT
, BY ITS VERY NATURE REQUIRES
COORDINATION NOT JUST BETWEEN
THE THREE SYSTEMS BUT WITH THE
KEY 12 SYSTEM AND THE WORKFORCE
AS WELL. AND WHAT PROGRAMS AND
POLICIES DO YOU INVEST TO MAKE
PROGRESS AGAINST THAT GOAL? HOW
DO YOU MEASURE PROGRESS? USING
WHAT METRICS WE ARE SO
ENCOURAGED BY THE CONVERSATION
TODAY AND BY THE RECENT MASTER
PLAN FOR CAREER EDUCATION, WHICH
ACKNOWLEDGES THE NEED FOR A
PLANNING, OVERSIGHT AND GOAL
SETTING VENUE TO MOVE OUR 70%
ATTAINMENT GOAL FORWARD. WE SEE
THIS AS A NECESSARY FIRST STEP,
BUT WE ALSO HOPE THAT ANY NEW
COORDINATING ENTITY IS EMBEDDED
WITH THE APPROPRIATE AUTHORITY
THAT WOULD BE REQUIRED FOR
INSTITUTIONAL ACCOUNTABILITY.
WHICH INCLUDES THE POWER TO
RECOMMEND INSTITUTIONAL BUDGETS,
INFORMED BUDGET AND POLICY
PRIORITIES AND PERHAPS MOST
VITAL OF ALL, MONITOR COMPLIANCE
WITH AND IMPLEMENTATION
IMPLEMENTATION OF STATUTE. THANK
YOU AGAIN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR TIME THIS
MORNING. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU BOTH. LET
ME ASK ONE QUESTION OPEN UP TO
MY COLLEGE, BOTH NOTED THE
ABSENCE OF A COORDINATING BODY.
IN ITS IMPLICATIONS. AND SO I
QUESTION YOU KNOW, LOOKING AT
REINSTITUTING SOMETHING LIKE
THAT, WOULD YOU? WHAT WOULD IT
LOOK LIKE? WOULD JUST BE CPAC.
TO RE INSTALLERS. WOULD YOU
DESCRIBE IT? SOME OTHER WAY. AND
IN THE INTERIM, HOW CAN WE
ACCOMPLISH THOSE GOALS IN THE
ABSENCE? OF A COORDINATING BODY.
OKAY GUS OFF, SO I THINK THAT
AND THEN FUNDING. CPAC IS NOT
THE ANSWER, I WOULD THINK ABOUT
WHAT ARE THE BIG NEEDS THAT WE
HAVE FOR CALIFORNIA TODAY. THE
CONTEXT WAS VERY DIFFERENT
TODAY. THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS ARE
DIFFERENT. WE HAVE A HANDOUT
THAT GOES THROUGH SOMETHING LIKE
10 OF THE TOP ISSUES THAT WE
SEE. COORDINATION COULD HELP
WITH THE STATE ADDRESS TODAY.
THE BIG ISSUES I SEE FOR
CALIFORNIA HIGHER RED OR AROUND
THE POLICY LEADERSHIP, THE
STATEWIDE POLICY LEADERSHIP.
AROUND GOAL SETTING AND THE
GOVERNOR SET A GOAL WOULD LOVE
TO UNDERSTAND LIKE WHERE DID THE
70 LIKE? WHY IS 70% OF GOOD
NUMBER FOR OUR STATE? AND THEN
HOW DO WE MEET THE GOAL? THAT IS
ONE KEY PIECE AND THEN THE OTHER
THING. THE OTHER BIG ISSUE I SEE
FOR CALIFORNIA IS WE HAVE MADE
SO MANY INVESTMENT AROUND INTER
SEGMENTAL. UM PROGRAMS AND
POLICIES, BUT WE DON'T HAVE A
GOOD PLACE FOR THOSE PROGRAMS TO
BE IMPLEMENTED. SO WE SEE THESE
PROGRAMS GOING TO DIFFERENCE.
THE AGENCY'S THE CASE, 16
REGIONAL GRANT PROGRAM IS BEING
ADMINISTERED BY THE OFFICE OF
SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION. WE SEE WORK
BASED LEARNING PROGRAM, SOME IN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN OPR,
SOME IN THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT
AID COMMISSION. UM THE BIG
HOUSING GRANT PROGRAM IS BEING
IMPLEMENTED BY THE STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE. ALL OF THESE
HAVE INTER SEGMENTAL COMPONENTS
AND SOMEONE WE'RE PUTTING THEM
INTO. PRINT PARTS OF OUR STATE
WHERE LOSING THAT CONNECTIVE
TISSUE THAT WOULD MAKE THESE
PROGRAMS A LOT STRONGER. AND
WE'RE NOT LEARNING ABOUT HOW WE
COULD. HOW THIS IS REACHING
STUDENTS. WELL, I THINK THOSE
ARE TWO MAJOR ISSUES THAT I SEE.
FIRST DATE THAT YOU KNOW CPAC
DIDN'T DO PROGRAM IMPLEMENTATION
. UM, I THINK IS ONE KEY PIECE
ALSO THINKING ABOUT, UM, I THINK
ANOTHER ISSUE THAT'S COME UP
MORE SO LATELY HAS BEEN AROUND
THE MISSION OF OUR THREE PUBLIC
HIGHER ED SEGMENTS. THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT A NEW ENTITY
COULD BE VERY USEFUL AROUND
THINKING ABOUT. I THINK WE
APPLIED BACCALAUREATE, FOR
EXAMPLE, UM, THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SHOULD THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HAVE THE APPLIED
BACCALAUREATE. WHAT'S THE IMPACT
ON THE CSU? THESE ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS FOR OUR TAKE
UPSTATE TO GRAPPLE WITH, UM SO I
COULD SEE THIS AS BEING ANOTHER
ISSUE THAT AN ENTITY TODAY WILL
GRAPPLE WITH THAT, YOU KNOW,
PERHAPS WASN'T IN CPAC'S PURVIEW
. SO IT'S STARTING WITH THE WHAT
ARE THE PROBLEMS TODAY? WHAT IS
OUR STATE LOOK LIKE? WHAT OUR
ISSUES WHAT OUR NEEDS AND
DRIVING FROM THEIR CONNECTION TO
WORKFORCE IS ALSO A BIG ONE.
THAT IN 2011 WAS SORT OF A AN
EMERGING ISSUE FOR OUR STATE.
THESE ARE REALLY URGENT NEEDS,
AND I WOULD THINK THAT AN ENTITY
TODAY WOULD ALSO BE VERY
THOUGHTFUL ABOUT CONNECTIONS TO
OUR STATE'S LABOR AGENCY TO
EMPLOYERS TO REGIONAL NEEDS.
ALSO WE NEED A SORT OF REGIONAL
ACCESS SKELETON TO SUPPORT THIS
REGIONAL. THE REGIONAL WORK THAT
OUR STATE HAS INVESTED DEEPLY IN
. THAT WOULD BE ANOTHER KEY
THING THAT I WOULD SEE
ACCREDITING ENTITY TODAY REALLY
FOCUSED ON APPRECIATE THAT, MR
BROWN. I THINK WHAT I'LL ADD IS
I WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHAT WAS GOOD ABOUT CPAC.
I ECHO DOCTOR JAZZES COMMENT
THAT I DON'T THINK SIPEK IS THE
RIGHT MODEL. BUT CPAC DID
PROVIDE A CRITICAL DATA RESEARCH
FUNCTION FOR THE STATE. IT DID,
UH, COLLECT DATA THAT WAS
SEAMLESS ACROSS THE THREE
SYSTEMS, AND IT ALSO DID REALLY
IMPORTANT PROJECTIONS FOR THE
STATE AROUND CAPACITY. THEY HAD
A SERIES CALLED READY OR NOT.
HERE THEY COME REALLY LOOKING AT
WHAT WAS COMING, YOU KNOW
STUDENTS COMING FROM THE K 12
SYSTEM AND PREDICTING FOR THE
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES HOW
THEY NEEDED TO PREPARE. TO BEST
SERVE THOSE STUDENTS THAT DATA
FUNCTION HAS NOT BEEN PICKED UP
AT ALL BY ANY OTHER ENTITY, AND
EACH SEGMENT COLLECTS DATA IN
ITS OWN WAY. WHEN WE WHEN WE
LOOK AT THAT DATA FROM THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
, EACH INSTITUTION DISAGGREGATE
THEIR DATA DIFFERENTLY. RACE AND
ETHNICITY CATEGORIES ARE
DIFFERENT, AND IT'S REALLY HARD
TO GET A SENSE OF WHAT IS GOING
ON. I THINK THE CRADLE TO CAREER
DATA. SYSTEM IS GOING TO BE A
HUGE STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
FROM THERE, BUT THAT IS AN
ESSENTIAL PART TO ANY
COORDINATING ENTITY IS HAVING
THE DATA CAPACITY FOR US TO
UNDERSTAND WHO IS IN OUR SYSTEM
WHO'S COMING INTO OUR SYSTEM?
WHO'S LEAVING? WHERE ARE THEY
GETTING? WHERE ARE THEY GETTING
STUCK? I WILL SAY THAT, YOU
KNOW, TO YOUR QUESTION. SENATOR
NEWMAN ABOUT WHAT DO WE DO IF WE
DON'T HAVE A COORDINATING
ENTITY? I DON'T KNOW IF I COULD
IN GOOD CONSCIENCE SAY THAT WE
SHOULD FOLLOW THAT APPROACH,
BECAUSE, AS SUSAN SHARED, WE
HAVE CONTINUED TO FIGURE OUT
PIECEMEAL WAYS TO DO THIS INNER
SEGMENTAL COORDINATION. THAT
JUST DOESN'T WORK. YOU KNOW,
WE'VE HAD THE LEADERS OF THE
SEGMENTS MEET INFORMALLY. WITH
THE GOVERNOR WITH NO PUBLIC
AGENDA. NO PUBLIC ACCOUNTABILITY
AND THAT REALLY DOESN'T ALLOW
FOR ALL THE ISSUES THAT NEED TO
BE VETTED. YOU KNOW, I MADE A
QUICK LIST OF THE ISSUES THAT A
COORDINATING ENTITY NEEDS TO
TALK ABOUT ITS GOALS. TRANSFER
FINANCIAL AID ADMISSIONS DATA
COLLECTION, THE SHARING OF BEST
PRACTICES. SHARED RESOURCES.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT HOUSING, UM
WE ACTUALLY HAVE SOME CAMPUSES
THAT HAVE HOUSING THAT COULD BE
SHARED WITH THE NEIGHBORING
CAMPUS. WE ARE LEAVING THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES TO CHANCE THAT
LEADERS ARE TALKING TO ONE
ANOTHER. BUT THERE'S NO FORMAL
WAY TO REALLY LOOK AT OUR
INVENTORY AND COORDINATE AROUND
THAT BUDGET. EVALUATION CAPACITY
AND WORKFORCE JUST IN THE LAST
TWO OR THREE YEARS ON THE ON THE
ISSUE OF ADMISSIONS. WE'VE SEEN
THE CSU TRY TO ADD AN ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENT TO 80 G, LOOKING AT
AN ADDITIONAL QUANTITATIVE
REASONING. QUANTITATIVE
REASONING COURSES AND RIGHT NOW,
THE U. C IS CONSIDERING ADDING
ANOTHER ANOTHER LAYER OR TAKING
AWAY A COURSE THAT WOULD, UM,
THAT WOULD BE COUNTED UNDER THE
MATH REQUIREMENT WITH NO
CONSULTATION WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. THAT IS
WHERE THE VALUE OF A
COORDINATING ENTITY WOULD COME
IN IF WE HAVE HIGHER EDUCATION,
SETTING ADMISSIONS REQUIREMENTS,
WHICH THEY DO, BUT WITHOUT
TALKING TO K 12 K 12 SYSTEM, WE
ARE ESSENTIALLY SAYING THAT THE
K 12 MAY NOT BE READY TO PRODUCE
STUDENTS AND MEET THOSE NEW
ADMISSIONS REQUIREMENTS. AND
WORK SIPHONING OFF ACCESS IF
THOSE CONVERSATIONS ARE NOT
HAPPENING IF THOSE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT HOW LONG WILL IT TAKE YOU
K 12 TO BE ABLE TO OFFER THESE
COURSES IN A WAY THAT EQUITABLE
WE'RE NOT HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS, SO I DON'T KNOW
THAT AT THIS POINT WITH THE
VOLUME, I THINK OF ISSUES THAT
REQUIRE, UM, INNER SEGMENTAL
QUARTER COORDINATION. I DON'T
THINK THAT I COULD RECOMMEND
ANOTHER WAY TO REALLY GET AROUND
IT BECAUSE I THINK WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO DO THAT, AND WE KEEP
COMING BACK TO THE SAME. PLACE
OF WHEN ARE WE GOING TO HAVE? I
THINK THE POLITICAL WILL TO
INSTITUTIONALIZE A COORDINATING
BODY. YOUR POINT IS WELL TAKEN.
COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS, COMMENTS.
I THINK IT'S SO MUCH THAT YOU'RE
NEWMAN AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE GREAT PRESENTATION HERE
TODAY AND MISSING COLORADO AND
OREGON AND SOME OF THE EXAMPLES
HERE. CAN YOU GIVE US ANOTHER
EXAMPLES OF WHAT OTHER STATES
HAVE DONE? CYBERLINK SUPPORT
COLLABORATION AND COLLABORATIVE
WORK BETWEEN THE DIFFERENT
SEGMENTS AND HOW WE CAN REALLY
CONTINUE TO ENCOURAGE THAT WORK
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. THERE ARE A
LOT OF OTHER STATES THAT ARE
DOING COORDINATION WORK, AND I
THINK WHERE WE SAW A
PROLIFERATION OF STATES HAS BEEN
AROUND ATTAINMENT GOALS, SO
WE'VE SEEN A NUMBER OF STATES
THROUGH THEIR COORDINATING BODY
HAVE AN ATTAINMENT GOAL THAT WAS
SET BY THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR AND THESE ENTITIES, THE
COORDINATING COMMISSIONS REALLY
SETTING OUT WHAT THE PLAN IS.
WHAT ARE THE METRICS BY WHICH
WE'RE GOING TO MEASURE OURSELVES
? AND WHAT ARE THE KEY DRIVERS
OF THAT. SO I WOULD REALLY SAY
THAT A LOT OF THE COMMISSION'S
OPERATORS SETTING A STRATEGIC
PLAN FOR HIGHER EDUCATION TO
MEET A GOAL AND THEN
IMPLEMENTING THAT A NUMBER OF
STATES AS I SHARED OREGON AND
COLORADO INCLUDED ARE TAKING THE
SYSTEMS WITHIN THEIR STATE AND
RECOMMENDING BUDGET. A LOT OF
THE SYSTEMS ARE DOING TRANSFER
WORK. A LOT OF THE SYSTEMS ARE
ALSO THINKING THROUGH OR A LOT
OF THE COORDINATING BODIES ARE
THINKING THROUGH FINANCIAL AID
FROM START TO FINISH, REGARDLESS
OF WHAT SEGMENT THE STUDENTS ARE
IN, SO THOSE ARE JUST A FEW OF
THE WAYS THAT WE'RE SEEING THE
COORDINATING HAPPENING. THANK
YOU. AND SECONDLY, TOUCHED UPON
THE HISTORY OF CPAC, BUT ARE
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL LESSONS
THAT WE SHOULD BE LEARNING FROM
CPAC AND AS WE GO FORWARD, THANK
YOU. I THINK SOME OF THE KEY
THINGS AND IT SORT OF TIES TO
WHAT AUDREY IS SAYING ABOUT THE
OTHER STATES WOULD BE THINKING
DEEPLY ABOUT WHAT IS WHAT IS
CALIFORNIA NEED TODAY AND
THINKING ABOUT OTHER STATES HAVE
, LIKE LITERALLY EVERY OTHER
STATE HAS SOME SORT OF
COORDINATING BODY. I THINK THEY
ARE INTERESTING, PERHAPS TO, UM
HELP US THEY HAVE BRING UP SOME
IDEAS OF WHAT WOULD BE POSSIBLE
IN CALIFORNIA. BUT THOSE OTHER
STATES ALSO HAVE, LIKE VERY
DIFFERENT POLITICAL CONTACTS.
DIFFERENT HIGHER ED STRUCTURES
THE WAY THAT THEY'RE GOVERNED.
SO SOME CAUTION ABOUT LOOKING AT
WHAT OTHER STATES ARE HELPING.
TENNESSEE HAS A VERY EFFECTIVE
COORDINATING ENTITY. IT'S A VERY
DIFFERENT STATE THAN CALIFORNIA,
BUT THEY DO SOME VERY COOL AND A
LITTLE COOL WORK THAT REALLY
GUIDES THE LEGISLATURE. ORGANS.
VERY INTERESTING AROUND THE
ALLOCATION. ONE COOL THING I
LOVE ABOUT COLORADO'S EVERY FIVE
YEARS. THEY COME UP WITH A NEW
STRATEGY FOR HIGHER ED, AND THEY
DO IT LEVERAGING DATA, BUT
THEY'RE REALIZING THAT THEY HAVE
TO BE AGILE AND SERVING THEIR
STUDENTS AND THOSE THINGS I
THINK FOR CPAC, THE LESSONS
LEARNED ARE RELEVANT FOR
THINKING ABOUT THE NEW ENTITY
TODAY. UM, ONE THING I TOUCHED
ON LIGHTLY FOR CPAC WAS AROUND,
UM, THE DATA PIECE AND SO I
THINK HAVING A STRONG DATA
SYSTEM AND THE CALIFORNIA'S WELL
, THAT'S WHY WOULD THE CROWDED
CAR DATA SYSTEM AND CONTINUING
THAT INVESTMENT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT HAS THE VALUE THAT WE
ALL SAW? ONE WHEN WE ADVOCATED
FOR THIS WHEN THE LEGISLATURE
FUNDS IT THAT WILL BE REALLY
CRITICAL FOR THE STATE
DEVELOPMENT? GOOD DECISIONS IS
HAVING THAT AND FRANKLY, THAT IS
GOING TO BE A MODEL FOR THE
NATION AROUND ITS STRONG
STATEWIDE LONGITUDINAL DATA
SYSTEM. SO I HAVE BIG HOPES THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN GO FROM BEING ONE
OF THE FEW STATES THAT THE ONLY
SHIP WITHOUT A COORDINATE ENTITY
TO A STATE THAT HAS THE BEST
COORDINATING ENTITY IN THE
COUNTRY. REMEMBER QUIRK-SILVA.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. I
AM. TAKING A LOT IN HERE, BUT
I'M DOING THE MATH ON CPAC WAS
AH, THIS THIS EVOLVED IN 2011.
SO ABOUT 13 YEARS AGO. AND OVER
THOSE YEARS. LIKE I SAID, I WAS
ON HIGHER ED. I MY FACT I'M AN
EDUCATOR BY PROFESSION 20 YEARS
IN THE CLASSROOM, ELEMENTARY
CLASSROOM AND SOME OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS I'VE HEARD IN
ROUND TABLES IN OUR DISTRICT ON
HIGHER ED. I'VE HEARD
INDIVIDUALLY FROM GOING TO
MEETINGS WITH HIGHER ED. WHETHER
IT'S COMMUNITY COLLEGE HIGHER,
ED AND YET I'M ASTOUNDED THAT
WE'RE NOT MAKING PROGRESS YOU
MENTIONED ON THE TRANSFERS. I
UNDERSTOOD THAT WE HAD ABOUT, UH
, CLOSE TO 30 TRANSFER PROGRAMS
WHERE, IF A STUDENT KNEW WHAT
THEY WANTED TO DO, JUST SAY IT
TO CSU, AND THEY STARTED
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IF THEY HAD
CHOSEN THAT TRANSFER PROGRAM.
IMMEDIATELY THEY COULD GET
THROUGH AND FOR YEARS AND YET
MANY STUDENTS DON'T KNOW THIS
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT GETTING TO
CAMPUSES TALKING FACE TO FACE
WITH THE COUNSELOR SO THEY MAY
SPEND A YEAR ON A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE BEFORE THEY EVEN KNOW
ABOUT THESE PROGRAMS. SO WHEN
YOU TALKED ABOUT BROKEN
FINANCIAL SYSTEMS AND SO FORTH,
AND I AGREE THAT COORDINATION IS
IMPERATIVE, BUT WITHOUT US,
BRINGING BACK A FORMAL BODY,
WHICH I DON'T THINK IS GOING TO
BE LIKELY AND THE CLIMATE WE ARE
NOW HOW DO WE INSIST THAT THERE
IS COORDINATION WITHOUT HAVING A
MANDATE TO DO THAT? UM, I SEE A
LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE AUDIENCE
AND BECAUSE I'VE SEEN SILOS
FOREVER. IN EDUCATION AND ABOUT
EVERY 10 YEARS. THERE'S ANOTHER
BIG MANDATE MATTER OF FACT,
RIGHT NOW AND ELEMENTARY. I KNOW
I SPOKE TO THE CHAIR. THAT'S NOW
A NEW WAY TO TEACH READING, AND
IT'S GOING TO BE YOU KNOW,
EVERYBODY'S GOING TO LEARN TO
READ BY DOING SCIENCE OF
READING. THE TRUTH IS, THAT'S
NOT THE TRUTH. THE TRUTH IS THAT
WE HAVE MULTIPLE WAYS TO GET
THERE, AND UNLESS WE FIGURE THIS
OUT, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE
SAME SITUATION FIVE OR 10 YEARS
FROM NOW WHERE PEOPLE KEEP
ASKING FOR MORE FUNDING, AND WE
HAVE TO EMBRACE WHO WE HAVE IN
FRONT OF US. THE STUDENTS THAT
ARE CHANGING BODY CHANGING
DEMOGRAPHIC AND I'M WANTING TO
HEAR MORE, BUT I AM, UH RAISING
MY EYEBROWS. I GUESS IF YOU
WOULD SAY ON SOME OF THE
INFORMATION I'M HEARING BECAUSE
I HEARD IT 10 YEARS AGO, 20
YEARS AGO. IF YOU WANT TO COME
AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO COMMENT
WE'VE COVERED. WE'VE PUT A LOT
OF THOUGHT INTO THINKING ABOUT
LIKE, HOW DOES OUR STATE
COORDINATE ITS EFFORTS AROUND
HIGHER EDUCATION IN CONNECTING
TO K 12 AND THE WORKFORCE AND
YOU? CAN WE APPROACH IT WITH CAN
WE HAVE COORDINATION WITHOUT A
COORDINATING ENTITY? BECAUSE
THERE AS I MENTIONED ALL THE 49
OTHER STATES HAVE COURT ANY
ENTITIES, BUT A LOT OF THEM ARE
LESS COORDINATED THAN CALIFORNIA
. SO CORDONING ENTITY DOES NOT
NECESSARILY GET YOU
COORDINATION. THAT SAID, I DON'T
SEE A WAY THAT CALIFORNIA
BECOMES MORE COORDINATED WITHOUT
A COORDINATING ENTITY. THE ONLY
THING I'LL ADD TO THAT
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S IS YOU KNOW THE
EXAMPLE I GAVE HIM MY TESTIMONY
ABOUT THE A B 9 TO 8 COMMITTEE,
WHICH REALLY A LEGISLATED THAT
THE PARTIES COME TOGETHER TO
FIGURE OUT AND STRENGTHEN
TRANSFER VIA THE ASSOCIATE
DEGREE FOR TRANSFER, WHICH I
THINK IS WHAT YOU WERE YOU WERE
DISCUSSING, UM I DON'T THINK
THAT'S THE WAY WE WANT TO
APPROACH COORDINATION THAT YOU
WANT TO LEGISLATE EVERY YOU KNOW
, ESSENTIALLY EVERY OPPORTUNITY
THAT REQUIRES INTER SEGMENTAL
COORDINATION, BUT THAT IS AN
EXAMPLE. I THINK AGAIN OF A WAY
THAT. CONVERSATION HAPPENED IN
THE PUBLIC WITH CLEAR GOALS WAS
FACILITATED, UM, TO HAVE REGULAR
CONVENING TO MEET A CHARGE AND
THAT IS WHAT WE'RE LACKING. WE
DON'T HAVE KIND OF A NEUTRAL
PLACE WHERE ALL OF THE PLAYERS
ARE COMING TOGETHER IN A
LEGISLATED WAY REQUIRED TO
REPORT OUT SO THERE IS
ACCOUNTABILITY. AND DO THE JOB
THAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO
AGAIN ACROSS ACROSS THE SEGMENTS
. WHEN IT DOES HAPPEN, IT IS
ORGANIC, AND THERE'S A LOT OF
STUFF THAT HAPPENS ORGANICALLY,
AND THAT'S WONDERFUL. BUT AS A
STATE, I THINK THAT THE STAKES
ARE TOO HIGH FOR US TO LEAVE
SOME OF THIS COORDINATION TO
CHANCE TO THE EXISTING
RELATIONSHIPS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION LEADERS BECAUSE THEY
KNOW EACH OTHER AND WANT TO WORK
TOGETHER. YOU KNOW IF THERE ARE
INSTITUTIONAL LEADERS THAT DON'T
LIKE EACH OTHER, THEY COULD
DECIDE I'M NOT GOING TO WORK.
WITH THAT PERSON. AND THAT WHERE
DOES THAT LEAVE US? THAT'S NOT A
GOOD PLACE TO BE. AND SO I DO
THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE A THE
FORMALITY OF A COMMISSION OF A
COORDINATING ENTITY TO
COORDINATE SO I DO APPRECIATE
THAT. WE'VE SEEN SOME OF THAT
FRICTION AROUND CONVERSATIONS
AROUND BACCALAUREATE PROGRAMS
BETWEEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
THE CSU, AND IT'S LARGELY BASED
ON GOODWILL USE. THERE'S NO REAL
LEVERAGE TO FORCE EITHER OF
THOSE ENTITIES TO WORK CLOSELY
TOGETHER TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S
CREEK. SILVA'S POINT, I MEAN,
IT'S NOT A SMALL THING. TO RE
IMPLEMENT COORDINATING BODY. SO
MY LAST QUESTION FOR YOU IS
GETTING FROM HERE TO THERE,
RIGHT SO THAT EXCEPT THAT BOTH
OF YOU THINK THAT THIS IS
NEEDED? YOU KNOW WHAT GUYS?
WOULD YOU GIVE US ON? WORKING
DELIBERATELY TOWARD CREATING AND
IMPLEMENTING A NEW COORDINATING
BODY. I THINK THERE ARE A COUPLE
OF THINGS I THINK FIRST. IT'S
REALLY ASSESSING, YOU KNOW. WHAT
ARE THE PRIORITIES IN TERMS OF
WHAT CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE
COORDINATING? WHETHER WHAT ARE
THE AREAS IN, YOU KNOW,
DETERMINING CAPACITY IN ACCESS
IN COMPLETION IN FINANCIAL AID,
RIGHT? WHAT ARE THOSE? THOSE BIG
BUCKETS? I THINK IT IS DOING
THAT LANDSCAPE ANALYSIS, A LOT
OF WHICH CALIFORNIA COMPETES HAS
DONE TO SAY WHAT ARE THE SOME OF
THE BEST PRACTICES THAT CAN WORK
FOR CALIFORNIA? OTHER STATES
HAVE TRIED. I KNOW THERE WERE
YOU KNOW, SEVERAL YEARS AGO, THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
ACTUALLY BROUGHT THE LEADERS
FROM OREGON TO CALIFORNIA TO
TALK TO OUR LEGISLATIVE BODIES
ABOUT HOW THEY APPROACHED,
ESTABLISHING AND STRENGTHENING
THEIR COORDINATING ENTITY. SO I
THINK IT IS TALKING WITH THOSE
STAKEHOLDERS TO FIGURE OUT HOW
MIGHT WE SET THIS UP? THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE HAS HAD
NO SHORTAGE OF TRIED POLICY
MAKING RIGHT TO ESTABLISH
ACCORDING ENTITY, I THINK
LOOKING AT THOSE CONVERSATIONS,
I THINK THE HEARING TODAY IS A
GREAT FIRST STEP, BUT THEN I
THINK IT IS PUTTING OUT A
PROPOSAL BASED ON THAT FEEDBACK.
I THINK THE LEGISLATURE HAS A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF POWER.
SOMETIMES THE QUESTION IS, WHAT
DO WE DO ABOUT èC RIGHT AS AN
AUTONOMOUS ENTITY, UM YOU DO
HAVE SIGNIFICANT POWER WITH YOUR
BUDGETARY AUTHORITY THAT CAN
ESSENTIALLY WRANGLE THE THREE
SYSTEMS TO WORK THERE YOU HAVE.
YOU HAVE SIGNIFICANT LEVERAGE. I
THINK TO REQUIRE THAT AND THEY
AND A CALL TO THE STATE TO MEET
THOSE NEEDS. DR ANY COMMENT? I
THINK IN SOME WAYS WE'RE CLOSER
THAN IT SEEMS. SO WHAT MICHIGAN
DID WOULD THEY CREATED THEIR
COORDINATING BODIES THEY PULLED
IN THE VARIOUS EFFORTS FROM
ACROSS THE STATE INTO A SINGLE,
A SINGLE AGENCY. SO THAT IS ONE
THING IS I FLAG WE HAVE A LOT OF
INTER SEGMENTAL AND CROSS SECTOR
WORK HAPPENING ALREADY IN OUR
STATE, SO IT'S NOT NECESSARILY,
HMM. CREATING NEW A NEW A NEW
NEW TASKS FOR THE STATE TO
HANDLE, BUT IT'S BRINGING
TOGETHER ALL OF THE WORK THAT'S
HAPPENING ACROSS OUR GOVERNMENT
INTO A SINGLE PLACE WHERE THEY
CAN WORK TOGETHER AND THEN WITH
REGARD TO THE POLICY LEADERSHIP,
WE HAVE MODELS AROUND THAT, AND
SOME THAT EXISTS ALREADY,
PERHAPS LIKE C. C AS AN EXAMPLE
THE GOVERNOR'S COUNCIL SO IT'S
NOT NECESSARILY HAVING TO CREATE
A BRAND NEW THING. BUT TAKING
WHAT OUR STATE HAS ALREADY
INVESTED IN AND THEN PULLING IT
TOGETHER IN A WAY THAT IT'S MORE
COHERENT, SO IT'S ALMOST
REORGANIZING RATHER THAN
CREATING SOMETHING NEW. THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES. ANY FINAL
THOUGHTS QUESTIONS. COLLUSIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR
UM, CERTAINLY WE KNOW THAT IT
WOULD BE HELPFUL TO HAVE SOME
LEVEL OF COORDINATING IN TERMS
OF MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
WORKFORCE THAT WE NEED. I CAN'T
THINK OF AN INDUSTRY OR SEGMENT
RIGHT NOW THAT IS IN DIRE NEED.
IN TERMS OF WORKFORCE, BUT I
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT YOU KNOW,
UM I ACTUALLY WAS A MEMBER OF
THE CSU BOARD OF TRUSTEES IS ONE
POINT AND I REMEMBER A TIME WHEN
WE WERE. ASKING TO HAVE THE
RIGHT TO BE ABLE TO OFFER A
DOCTORATE IN EDUCATION BECAUSE
WE WERE THE EDUCATORS OF THEM.
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
TEACHERS AND MANY TIMES WE
THOUGHT THAT PEOPLE THOUGHT THE
WORLD WAS COMING TO AN END. UM
AND I THINK THAT UM. WE
CERTAINLY NEED TO FIND WAYS TO,
UM ENSURE THAT THERE'S PROPER
COORDINATION BECAUSE UM, IF WE
DON'T UM, I MEAN, WE HAVE SO
MANY GAPS RIGHT NOW, BUT I DON'T
THINK THAT JUST HAVING DATA IS
PART OF IT. WE REALLY IF WE'RE
GOING TO DO IT, WE HAVE TO DO IT
RIGHT, RIGHT. HOW DO WE ENSURE
THAT WE DON'T HAVE WE PREVENT? A
BODY FROM FALLING INTO A UM A
LACK OF RELEVANCE. FOR PEOPLE TO
THINK THAT THIS IS A BODY.
THAT'S AUTONOMOUS. THEY'RE
TALKING. THEY'RE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS. THEY'RE PRODUCING
REPORTS THAT NOBODY'S READING
RIGHT ALL THOSE TYPE OF THINGS.
HOW DO WE PREVENT A BODY FROM
HAVING FALLING INTO A LACK OF
RELEVANCE? SO I THINK THERE'S A
THERE'S A COUPLE WAYS AND CPAC
IS PROBABLY INFORMATIVE AROUND
THIS AND A NUMBER OF OTHER
STATES ACCORD ENTITIES THAT HAVE
, YOU KNOW, THEY DESCRIBED LIKE
A LAMBORGHINI IN THE GARAGE THAT
THEY NEVER DRIVE. UM I THINK ONE
KEY THING IS THE MASTERY MAKES
YOU USEFUL. SO IF YOU'RE
DELIVERING TOWARDS A NEED AND
YOU HAVE EXPERTISE, THERE WILL
BE A DEMAND FOR THAT WORK IF
IT'S NOT USEFUL IF IT'S NOT
REGRESS THAN THAT FALLS TO THE
WAYSIDE, AND THEY'RE NO LONGER
USEFUL ADVISOR BEING TRUSTED
ADVISOR THAT YOU HAVE TO EXECUTE
THAT RAW WELL AND THIS ENTITY.
UM ALSO, I THINK AROUND. UM
AUDREY HAS TALKED ABOUT THE
BUDGET LIKE INCENTIVES MATTER.
SO WHAT INCENTIVES WITH THIS
ENTITY BE ABLE TO OFFER TO
COORDINATE THE HIGHER ED
SEGMENTS BUDGET IS ONE AND
FORMAL AUTHORITY. THE POWER TO
MANDATE IS ANOTHER THING TO
CONSIDER. SO FOR WHAT? WHAT
AREAS WOULD IT BE USEFUL FOR
THIS ENTITY TO HAVE AUTHORITY TO
MAKE DECISIONS? UM I THINK
PARING SOME OF THIS POLICY
LEADERSHIP AROUND PLANNING AND
RESEARCH WITH IMPLEMENTATION AND
CAPACITY BUILDING FOR THE
SEGMENTS, ALONG WITH THE BALANCE
OF INCENTIVES AUTHORITY WILL BE
REALLY CRITICAL. FOR ITS
EFFECTIVENESS, AND I COMPLETELY
CONCUR. I WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
THIS IS THE EDUCATION DOCTORATE.
I WAS SACK STATES, ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEAD AND JACK
SCOTT IS ON MY BOARD. SO I THINK
THIS IS LIKE A TRAFFIC COP ROLE
OF THE ENTITY WILL BE REALLY
USEFUL, NOT JUST IN SORT OF IN A
YOU KNOW, DICTATING WHO CAN DO
WHAT HE CANNOT DO IT BUT ALSO
PROVIDING A SPACE FOR SEGMENT
LEADERSHIP TO GET TOGETHER AND
DELIBERATE. AND IDEALLY COME TO
CONSENSUS ON THEIR OWN AROUND
WHAT MAKES SENSE AND WHAT
DOESN'T BUT THEY HAVE THAT SPACE
TO PULL TOGETHER WITH EXPERTS TO
FIGURE OUT. IS THERE A SPACE FOR
THE CSU TO OFFER THE EDUCATION
DOCTORATE INDEPENDENTLY? AND IF
SO, WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE?
ARE THEY SERVING A STATE NEED
THAT'S NOT BEING ADDRESSED BY
THE èC OR BY PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS, WHICH ALSO HAVE A
REALLY CRITICAL ROLE IN OUR
STATE AROUND SERVING WORKFORCE
NEEDS. ANY OTHER THOUGHTS. YOUR
QUESTIONS? CERTAINLY REMEMBER.
THANK YOU. UM I JUST DR CHARLES,
I'M JUST LOOKING AT YOUR YOUR
HAND OUT AND YOU KNOW, UM, ON
PAGE SEVEN. IT TALKS ABOUT HOW C
PECK. UM SUFFERED FROM ONGOING
TENSION THAT ULTIMATELY
UNDERMINED ITS EFFECTIVENESS
OVER TIME. CPAC'S CREDIBILITY
WITH LAWMAKERS ERODED WITH SOME
CLAIMING THAT BASICALLY THAT THE
SEGMENTS WERE WHO WERE
DOMINATING CPAC'S AGENDA AND
UNDERMINING THE OVERALL
CREDIBILITY OF THE BODY. AND YET
YOUR PROPOSAL YOU KNOW, IT'S
TALKING ABOUT ABOUT HOW DID
DETAILED EXPERT ANALYSIS IS
ESSENTIAL FOR INFORMING
DECISIONS BY THE GOVERNMENT, THE
LEGISLATURE, SO I MEAN, I
APOLOGIZE. I CAME IN LATE TO BUT
HOW DO WE AVOID MAKING THAT SAME
MISTAKE WAS C PECK, TOO, TOO? IT
SEEMS LIKE COMMON SENSE THAT WE
SHOULD BE COORDINATING OUR
EFFORTS TO MAXIMIZE OUR YOU KNOW
THE OUTCOMES. UM OTHER THAN OUR
BUDGET CHALLENGES OF TRYING TO
CREATE A NEW BODY, YOU KNOW, AND
AT THIS TIME, BUT, UM, IN TERMS
OF THIS BASIC PROBLEM OF C PECS,
CREDIBILITY BEING DOMINATED BY
UNDERMINED BEING BEING DOMINATED
BY THE SEGMENTS. REPRESENTATIVES
ON THE ON THE BODY. HOW DO WE
AVOID THAT FROM HAPPENING AGAIN?
GREAT QUESTION. UM SERVICES,
COORDINATING HIGHER AND HIGHER
IN CALIFORNIA AS GOOD AS
COMPLICATED AND THE SOLUTION IS
GOING TO BE COMPLICATED AND NOT
VERY CLEAR. I THINK I DON'T
THINK THERE'S GOING TO BE A THIS
IS THE OBVIOUS SOLUTION TO
COORDINATING HIGHER IN
CALIFORNIA. I THINK SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT YOU'VE FLAGGED HERE
THAT CALIFORNIA CAN MEET US FLAG
RAISING THE LEADERSHIP OF THE OF
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE CORN. ANY
ENTITY WILL BE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT. THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR, WHOEVER IS THAT THAT
FRONT PERSON THAT DRIVES THE
WORK THAT INDIVIDUAL, UM. HAS TO
HAVE THINK EXTREME EXPERTISE,
BOTH IN THE STRUCTURE OF HIGHER
RED AND THE NEEDS OF THE STATE
BUT ALSO WHAT HAPPENS IN
GOVERNING AND POLITICS IN OUR
STATE AND BE ABLE TO NAVIGATE
THAT. WELL UM, WITH REGARDS TO
THE INSTITUTIONAL INFLUENCE
AROUND CPAC. THE CHALLENGES WITH
PUBLIC MEMBERS OF THE GOVERNING
BOARD OFTEN COME TO THE
GOVERNING BOARDS WITHOUT AND
AREN'T AS STAFFED AS
INSTITUTIONAL LEADERS ARE SO
WHEN YOU HAVE SOMEONE FROM THE
UC CSU AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES,
THEY HAVE THE POWER OF THEIR
INSTITUTIONS BEHIND THEM, AND
KNOWLEDGE IS POWER IN THESE
BOARDS WHEN YOU COME IN AND
FORMED. WILL YOU COUNT THE
SOLUTION? VERSUS AN APPOINTEE
WHO MAY NOT HAVE THAT SORT OF
SAME BALANCE AND SO IT'S NOT,
YOU KNOW, A FORMAL LIKE
GOVERNANCE ISSUE, BUT IT REALLY
IS A POWER ISSUE AROUND WHO
COMES TO THIS SO THINKING
THROUGH HOW DOES THIS ENTITY AND
ITS STAFF BALANCE THAT POWER
DYNAMIC SO THAT PUBLIC MEMBERS
WHO ARE REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
AS A WHOLE? THE LEGISLATURE
STUDENTS COME WITH EQUAL FOOTING
AS THE HIGHER RED SEGMENTS.
THOSE I THINK ARE THE KEY PIECES
REQUIRE. I THINK THE LEGISLATURE
TO KEEP AN EYE ON THINGS LIKE TO
SEE. HOW IS THIS ENTITY DOING IN
FIVE YEARS? DO WE NEED TO MAKE
CHANGES AND I WILL TELL YOU
EVERY OTHER STATE IS MAKING
CHANGES CONSTANTLY, AND
CALIFORNIA'S HAD REFORM LIKE
CALLS FOR REFORMS OF
COORDINATION. THERE WERE MANY,
MANY, MANY MANY CALLS TO REFORM
CPAC BEFORE IT WAS DEFENDED.
WHAT OUR STATE REALLY DID WAS
CUT ITS FUNDING. AND IT BECAME
LESS AND LESS USEFUL RATHER THAN
ACTUALLY MAKING THE CHANGES THAT
WERE NEEDED TO ALLOW CPAC TO BE
MORE EFFECTIVE. YOU KNOW, I HEAR
IT'S THE SAME, BUT I AM JUST A
LITTLE YOU KNOW, WITHOUT DUE
RESPECT, SKEPTICAL ABOUT JUST
RELYING ON GETTING THE RIGHT
PEOPLE INVOLVED WHEN THERE SEEMS
TO BE A STRUCTURAL ISSUE THAT
WE'VE SEEN HERE IN CALIFORNIA,
GIVEN, YOU KNOW, THE
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTONOMOUS
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND YOU
KNOW, AND THE SEGMENTS, YOU KNOW
, I MEAN, I AM NOT AWARE OF
ANYTHING IN TERMS OF THAT
FUNDAMENTAL DYNAMIC, CHANGING
BETWEEN ONE, CPAC WAS DISBANDED
AND 2012 OR 2011, AND NOW AND SO
, I MEAN, I WOULD JUST HOPE THAT
THIS DISCUSSION AND ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS WOULD TRY TO ADDRESS
STRUCTURAL SOLUTIONS RATHER THAN
JUST RELYING ON, YOU KNOW,
GETTING THE RIGHT LEADERSHIP.
ABSOLUTELY I THINK THAT THE
INCENTIVES AND THE AUTHORITY
PIECE THAT I PAINTED ON EARLIER
ALSO KEY PARTS OF THIS, TOO.
YEAH I WOULD ECHO THE AUTHORITY.
I THINK CPAC WHILE IT DID, AS I
SHARED EARLIER HAVE A GREAT DATA
FUNCTION WHAT IT COMPLETELY
LACKED IN WHAT I THINK MADE IT
INEFFECTIVE WAS ITS LACK OF
AUTHORITY AUTHORITY FOR YOU
KNOW, I THINK AS YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT A NEW ENTITY, WE SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT BUDGETARY
AUTHORITY SUCH THAT THE ENTITY
CAN MAKE A RECOMMENDATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR BUDGET FOR THE
THREE SEGMENTS, NOT JUST ONE
SEGMENT. IT SHOULD BE THINKING
ABOUT APPROVAL AROUND ADMISSIONS
SUCH THAT IF AN INSTITUTION
WANTS TO MAKE ADMISSIONS CHANGES
. HOW DOES THAT ENTITY? UM QUOTE
UNQUOTE APPROVE THOSE THINGS? I
THINK WE ALSO DEGREE OFFERINGS.
WE TALKED ABOUT THAT A LITTLE
BIT RIGHT NOW. RIGHT HOW? WHO
OFFERS DEGREES? WHAT DEGREES?
HOW ARE WE MEETING DEMAND AND
HAVING THAT ENTITY WITHOUT THOSE
THOSE LEVELS OF AUTHORITY? THERE
IS NO INCENTIVE FOR THE
INSTITUTIONS TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE COORDINATING ENTITY AT ALL.
THERE JUST REALLY ISN'T AND THEN
IT CAN BECOME A PLATFORM FOR
JUST RHETORIC AND FUND, MAYBE
CONVERSATION, BUT NO REAL WORK.
CAN I BUILD A LITTLE BIT OFF OF
THAT? THE ORGAN EXAMPLE THAT
AUDREY MENTIONED MORE CONCRETE
CONCRETELY THE LEGISLATURE AND
ORGAN ALLOCATES ITS HIGHER ED
BUDGET AND THE COORDINATING
ENTITY MAKES DECISIONS ON WHO
LIKE WHERE DOES THIS MONEY GO?
SO IT HAS THAT SORT OF LIKE THAT
SUPREME POWER THERE, WHICH
CANNOT BE CANNOT BE UNDERSTATED.
MM. I APPRECIATE ALL OF YOUR
COMMENTS ANYTHING ELSE AS WE
CLOSE IT, SO I DO THINK THAT
FIRST. THANK YOU, DOCTOR. DOUBT
DR JAZZ MISS DOWN. YOU HAVE
FRAMED WELL, THE REST OF OUR
DISCUSSION PROBABLY WENT ON
LONGER THAN WE HAD ASSUMED THAT
THAT'S A GOOD THING. SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
, AND IT IS VERY RELEVANT TO THE
REST OF THE HEARING. LET ME TURN
IT OVER NOW. TO MY COLLEAGUE.
REMEMBER FUN? THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SENATOR NEWMAN AND THANK YOU FOR
ROBUST PANEL HERE. THE NEXT ITEM
IS ITEM NUMBER THREE CALIFORNIA
HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS, AREAS
OF SUCCESS, CHALLENGES AND
STRATEGIES FOR ENHANCING
COORDINATION AND LIKE TO INVITE
OUR PANELISTS UP, DR AISHA LOW
EXECUTIVE VICE CHANCELLOR OF
ECUADOR'S STUDENT LEARNING
EXPERIENCE, AN IMPACT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE OF DR NATHAN
EVANS, DEPUTY VICE CHANCELLOR,
ACADEMIC AND STUDENT AFFAIRS,
CHIEF ACADEMIC OFFICER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY. WE
HAVE DR KATHERINE NEWMAN.
PROVOST UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AND WE HAVE KRISTEN SAURUS
PRESIDENT ASSOCIATION OF
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES WELCOME. DOCTOR
LIU WOULD YOU LIKE TO START,
PLEASE? THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU. CHAIR NEWMAN AND
CHAIR FONG FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO DISCUSS THIS VERY IMPORTANT
TOPIC OF PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
, COORDINATION. COLLABORATION
AND DR I SHALLOW, EXECUTIVE VICE
CHANCELLOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TRANSFERS
OFFICE, GIVEN THE HIGHER
EDUCATION ECOSYSTEM ESTABLISHED
BY CALIFORNIA'S MASTER PLAN FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION. INTER
SEGMENTAL COORDINATION AND
COLLABORATION IS ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL TO COORDINATE PROGRAMS
AND PATHWAYS ACROSS FOUR
SEGMENTS AND OVER 200
INSTITUTIONS INCLUSIVE OF A I
CCU COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES.
THOSE FOUR SEGMENTS AND OVER 200
INSTITUTIONS ARE DECENTRALIZED
AND AUTONOMOUS WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CSU UC IN ICU
SEGMENTS OPERATING UNDER
DIFFERENT GOVERNANCE AND FUNDING
STRUCTURES. INTEREST. SEGMENTAL
COLLABORATION IS A MATTER OF
CURRICULUM COORDINATION, AND THE
PROCESS IS NEEDED TO COORDINATE
CURRICULUM ACROSS HUNDREDS OF
INDEPENDENT INSTITUTIONS IS
DETAILED, COMPLEX ITERATIVE AND
INSTITUTIONALLY DISTINCT. IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE CALIFORNIANS
WITH A DIVERSE PLETHORA OF
HIGHER EDUCATION PATHWAYS THAT
ARE ALIGNED TO WORKFORCE NEEDS
AND OPPORTUNITIES. WE MUST
ENSURE THAT TRANSFER PATHWAYS
ARE CLEAR AND STREAMLINED THAT
THE ACCEPTANCE OF TRANSFER
PATHWAYS IS STANDARDIZED ACROSS
CAMPUSES THAT STUDENTS CREDITS
ARE OBJECTIVELY ACCEPTED AND
APPLY TO THEIR DEGREE
REQUIREMENTS. AND THAT STUDENTS
HAVE THE FINANCIAL AND SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT. THEY NEED TO
PERSIST AND COMPLETE. NOW THERE
IS MUCH SUCCESS TO CELEBRATE,
AND IN FACT AS THE SEGMENTS OF
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION AS WELL
AS OUR EU PARTNERS, WE HAVE BEEN
COORDINATING TO SOLVE THESE
PROBLEMS TODAY. 31% OF UC
GRADUATES START AT A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND 54% OF CSU GRADUATE
OR COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRANSFERS.
THE NUMBER OF EARNERS ASSOCIATED
DEGREE FOR TRANSFER EARNERS HAS
SUBSTANTIALLY INCREASED AS WELL
AS STUDENTS THAT WE DEFINE AS
TRANSFER READY ONE OF THE
HALLMARKS OF CALIFORNIA INTER
SEGMENTAL COORDINATION ISN'T
SINCERE WILLINGNESS TO
COLLABORATE ON THE PART OF THE
SEGMENTS. DESPITE THE SIZE AND
DIVERSITY OF OUR SEGMENTS AND
CAMPUSES, WE ARE COLLECTIVELY
INVESTED IN NAVIGATING THOSE
COMPLEXITIES. TO ENSURE PATHWAYS
AND PROCESSES THAT ARE STUDENT
CENTERED IN EASY TO FOLLOW, FOR
EXAMPLE, WHILE CSU UC AND C YOU
WERE NOT MANDATED TO PARTICIPATE
IN A B 1111 COMMON COURSE
NUMBERING THEY HAVE WILLINGLY
AND ENTHUSIASTICALLY
PARTICIPATED AS THOUGHT PARTNERS
AND STRATEGISTS IN HELPING
DESIGN A COMMON COURSE NUMBERING
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STAKEHOLDERS.
SIMILARLY UC AND CSU WORKED
CLOSELY WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STAKEHOLDERS
IN THEIR DESIGN OF THEIR DUAL
ADMISSION PROGRAMS. ADDITIONALLY
PRIOR TO THE 8928 ENTER
SEGMENTAL TRANSFER COMMUNITY
COMMITTEE, THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IN THE èC
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT FORMED A
TRANSFER TASK FORCE AND WORK
TOGETHER. TO IDENTIFY NEEDS AND
PRIORITIZE STRATEGIES BETWEEN
SEGMENTS. WE ALSO HAVE A VERY
STRONG PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AND I SEE SEE YOU, OR WE
HAVE DEVELOPED DOZENS OF
TRANSFER IMO US WITH PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS. LASTLY THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE, THE CSU CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AND THE èC OFFERS OF THE
PRESIDENT EQUALLY SUPPORT AND
MAINTAIN THE ASSIST PLATFORM. WE
COULD ADD TO THAT AN UNTOLD
NUMBER OF LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS
THAT TAKE PLACE ACROSS OUR
INSTITUTIONS PARTNERING ON
CURRICULUM ON PROGRAM PATHWAYS
ON HOUSING, AS WELL AS
SUPPORTING STUDENTS, SOCIAL AND
EMOTIONAL NEEDS. ANOTHER CARE OF
SUCCESS THAT IS WORTH NOTING IS
THE FACULTY LEADERSHIP AND
COORDINATION ACROSS OUR SEGMENTS
, EVIDENCED BY THE WORK OF I
KISS TO ESTABLISH THE COW GETS
THE UNIFIED GENERAL EDUCATION
PATTERN FOR TRANSFER AND
COLLABORATION BETWEEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND CSU FACULTY TO CO
CREATE WHAT ARE CALLED TRANSFER
MODEL CURRICULA. THE FOUNDATION
OF THE ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR
TRANSFER PATHWAYS. WORK THAT IS
LED BY THE ACADEMIC SENATE FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WHILE WE CELEBRATE THESE AREAS
OF SUCCESS, THERE ARE CHALLENGES
TO ACHIEVING THE UNIFIED AND
STREAMLINE TRANSFER PROCESS. THE
STATE ENVISIONS CHIEF AMONG THEM
IS THE CURRENT COMPLEXITY OF
TRANSFER PATHWAYS WHERE THERE
ARE MANY DIFFERING TRANSFER
REQUIREMENTS ACROSS THE SEGMENTS
, CAMPUSES AND MAJORS WHILE
COURSE ARTICULATION PROCESSES
AND AGREEMENTS EXIST. AND THERE
ARE CENTRALIST PROCESSES TO
ARTICULATE COURSES FOR
BACCALAUREATE AND GENERAL
EDUCATION. CREDIT COURSE THE
COURSE ARTICULATION FOR MAJOR
PREPARATORY COURSES REMAIN
DECENTRALIZED AND AUTONOMOUS
ACROSS CAMPUSES. THE POLICIES,
PRACTICES, TIMELINES AND
REQUIREMENTS FOR THESE COURTS.
ARTICULATION PROCESSES ALSO VARY
ACROSS SEGMENTS IN CAMPUSES.
ADDITIONALLY WHILE THE ACADEMIC
SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HAS WORKED TIRELESSLY
TO ESTABLISH COURSE
IDENTIFICATION SYSTEM KNOWN AS C
I D TO COORDINATE CURRICULUM
ACROSS THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND A TRANSFORM MODEL CURRICULUM
DESIGN PROCESS TO CO CREATE
TRANSFER PATHWAYS. PATHWAYS
WOULD CSU FACULTY FOR THE A. D T
S. THAT IS A VOLUNTARY PROCESS.
FACULTY MUST BE RECRUITED TO
PARTICIPATE IN AND FOR WHICH
FACULTY OR GRAVELY UNDER
COMPENSATED. LASTLY AS HAS BEEN
SPOKEN TO, IT IS DIFFICULT TO
FULLY UNDERSTAND. THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSFER LANDSCAPE BECAUSE WE
LACK THE NEEDED INTER SEGMENTAL
DATA TO TRACK PROGRESS AND
IDENTIFY GAPS. THE LACK OF AN
INTER SEGMENTAL DATA SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA SERIOUSLY CONSTRAINS
ANY TYPE OF INTER SEGMENTAL
ANALYSIS AND LIMITED ACCESS TO
PROGRAM AND COURSE DATA HINDERS
BACCALAUREATE DEGREE DEVELOPMENT
AND COLLABORATION. SO HOW DO WE
MOVE FORWARD IN ORDER TO
SIMPLIFY THE COMPLEXITIES AND
ACHIEVE THE TRANSFER AND
BACCALAUREATE DEGREE ATTAINMENT
SUCCESS? WE ALL DESIRE. WE
BELIEVE ACUTE. FEW KEY
STRATEGIES ARE NEEDED AS CALLED
FOR IN THE RECENT 2023
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE 928
COMMITTEE. WE NEED A RESOURCED
INTER SEGMENT. OF COURSE,
ARTICULATION AND PATHWAYS
DEVELOPMENT INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
BUILDS UPON EXISTING STRUCTURES
TO OVERSEE AND FACILITATE THE
PROCESS. OF COURSE REVIEW.
PATHWAY, DEVELOPMENT AND
DETERMINATIONS OF SIMILARITY. WE
NEED TO INVEST IN THE
ACCELERATED COMPLETION OF THE
CRADLE TO CAREER DATA SYSTEM
WITH ACTIVE PARTICIPATION FROM
THE FOUR SEGMENTS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION TO INFORM THE DATA AND
INFORMATION NEEDS. THIS DATA
SYSTEM IS NEEDED TO INFORM THE
DEVELOPMENT OF METRICS,
MONITORING MECHANISMS AND
DASHBOARDS RELATED TO TRANSFER
AND CREDIT MOBILITY. WE MUST
RECRUIT TRAINED SUPPORT,
COMPENSATE AND PROVIDE
INCENTIVES FOR FACULTY
PARTICIPATION IN CURRICULUM
COORDINATION TO DESIGN TRANSFER
MODEL CURRICULA AND COLLABORATE
ON PROGRAM PATHWAYS, AND WE NEED
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT ACROSS ALL
FOUR SEGMENTS OF PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. DOCTOR LIU. NEXT STEP
WE HAVE DR EVANS. WELCOME GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS NATHAN EVANS
AND I SERVE AS DEPUTY VICE
CHANCELLOR AND CHIEF ACADEMIC
OFFICER FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY. NEWMAN, CHAIR FONG
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY, ALONG WITH MY
SEGMENT, COLLEAGUES. ECHOING
MANY OF DR LO'S REMARKS, THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
PRIORITIZES AND TAKES GREAT
PRIDE IN BUILDING AND
STRENGTHENING EFFECTIVE INTER
SEGMENTAL PARTNERSHIPS WITH OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION PEERS. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS ARE ALL OF OUR
RESPONSIBILITY, AND ALL OF US
HAVE INVESTED INTEREST IN THEIR
SUCCESS, THEIR MOBILITY BETWEEN
AND AMONG OUR SEGMENTS AND
ULTIMATELY, THEIR GRADUATION AND
SERVICE TO OUR COMMUNITIES AND
TO OUR STATE. TODAY WE CONTINUE
TO WORK TOGETHER TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS FROM EVERY BACKGROUND
INCOME AND REGION OF OUR STATES
ARE WELL SERVED AND SUPPORTED IN
PURSUING THEIR GOALS THROUGHOUT
THEIR LIFETIMES AND REACHING
THEIR FULL POTENTIAL. THE CSU
REMAINS COMMITTED TO THIS
COLLABORATION AND ENGAGEMENT
ACROSS SEGMENTS AND SECTORS.
THERE'S MUCH TO CELEBRATE AS
WE'VE HEARD SOME OF TODAY AND
OUR COLLECTIVE WORK TO ENSURE
SUCCESS AND SOCIAL MOBILITY FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AND
RESIDENTS. THE STATES CONTINUED
SUPPORT, FOR EXAMPLE, FOR THE
ISSUES GRADUATION INITIATIVE HAS
RESULTED IN ALL TIME GRADUATION
RATES FOR STUDENTS FROM ALL
BACKGROUNDS. THOSE ARRIVING
IMMEDIATELY FROM HIGH SCHOOL AND
THOSE FROM OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PARTNERS, AS WELL AS NEW DATA
INFORMED STRATEGIES THAT ARE
SHOWING GREAT PROMISE IN CLOSING
EQUITY GAPS AS ANOTHER TIMELY
EXAMPLE. THE CSU COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CæA AND èC. HAVE BEEN
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY ALONG
WITH SISAK IN LIGHT OF THE
DELAYS IN THE FEDERAL FINANCIAL
AID APPLICATION. AND DUE IN
LARGE PART TO RECENT LEGISLATION
AND IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN THE U. C
WE'VE MADE IMPRESSIVE STRIDES IN
SIMPLIFYING TRANSFER AND CARVING
CLEAR PATHWAYS TO FOUR YEAR
DEGREES, GRADUATE SCHOOL AND
FULFILLING CAREERS IN
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE. TO THAT
END, THE CSU IS DEEPLY GRATEFUL
FOR THE LEGISLATURE'S CONTINUED
COMMITMENT AND TO HIGHER
EDUCATION, ACCESS AND ITS
INVESTMENT IN OUR INSTITUTIONS
CORE MISSIONS, INCLUDING
PREPARING CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE
WORKFORCE IN THE FUTURE. DESPITE
THIS PROGRESS, THE ABSENCE OF A
HIGHER EDUCATION COORDINATING
BODY FOR THE LAST 12 YEARS HAS
ILLUMINATED OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EVEN MORE EFFECTIVE
COLLABORATION AND SYNERGY. A
COORDINATING ROLE WITH THE RIGHT
SCOPE COULD LOOK BROADLY ACROSS
THE HIGHER EDUCATION LANDSCAPE
TO BETTER FACILITATE EYES
FACILITATE AND EVEN INCENTIVIZE
CROSS SEGMENT PARTNERSHIPS. SUCH
AN ENTITY COULD HELP REDUCE
REDUNDANCY AND ENSURE FISCAL
EFFICIENCY AND THE IN USE OF
LIMITED STATE DOLLARS. IT COULD
ALSO IMPARTIALLY INFORMED AND
MAINTAINED VALUABLE
INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE AND THE
CONTINUED ADVANCEMENT OF
COLLECTIVE PRIORITIES THROUGH
TRANSITIONS IN BOTH
INSTITUTIONAL AND GOVERNMENT
LEADERSHIP WHILE INCLUDING
REPRESENTATION FROM EDUCATION
SEGMENTS. SUCH AN ENTITY COULD
ALSO INCORPORATE IMPARTIAL
VOICES TO ENSURE EFFECTIVE
COLLABORATION AND ADDRESS
DISPUTES, WHICH MAY DISTRACT
FROM COOPERATIVE EFFORTS. IT
COULD ALSO PROVIDE A SOURCE OF
FEEDBACK ON PROPOSED REFORMS AND
ENSURE THEY ARE GIVEN TIME TO
WORK, AND IT WOULD PROVIDE MORE
MORE ROBUST INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
WOULD ALLOW OUR INSTITUTIONS TO
ACT NIMBLY AND EFFICIENTLY IN
THE FACE OF SHARED CHALLENGES
AND COMMON GOALS. IN SHORT, SUCH
A ROLE COULD AID ALL OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS IN MAXIMIZING
RESOURCES, BETTER SERVING
STUDENTS AND ENSURING CALIFORNIA
REMAINS STRONGLY COMPETITIVE IN
THE INCREASING HIERARCHY
INCREASINGLY COMPETITIVE, HIGHER
EDUCATION LANDSCAPE. THE ABSENCE
OR CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH
NOT HAVING SUCH AN ENTITY TODAY
HAS REALLY NECESSITATED
SOLUTIONS TO BE QUICKLY SPUN UP
WITHOUT CONTINUITY OR THE
BENEFIT OF LONG TERM CONTEXT TO
NAME JUST A FEW SPECIFIC
EXAMPLES. SUCH AN ENTITY HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO ADDRESS ISSUES. AS
WE HAVE HEARD TODAY OF ACADEMIC
PROGRAM DUPLICATION, SUCH AS
APPLIED BACCALAUREATE DEGREE
PROGRAMS PROPOSED BY COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. OR DOCTORAL PROGRAMS,
AS PROPOSED BY THE CSU. IT COULD
ALSO CONDUCT REGULAR ASSESSMENTS
OF CSU AND UC ADMISSIONS
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA ONCE AGAIN
OVERDUE TASK LAST REQUIRED BY
THE 2015 BUDGET TRAILER BILL. IT
COULD ALSO ASSESS HIGHER
EDUCATION CAPACITY AND DEMAND
PROVIDING RECOMMENDATIONS TO
ADDRESS BARRIERS THAT LIMIT
ACCESS TO ALL SEGMENTS SUCH AS
CLINICAL PLACEMENT, AVAILABILITY
AND NURSING. AND IT COULD
FACILITATE THE EXPANSION OF
ONLINE EDUCATION TO MAKE IT MORE
PORTABLE TO CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
WHO MAY BE TRANSITORY, AS WELL
AS CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS WITH
NATIONWIDE PRESENCE. IN CLOSING,
THE CSU IS OPEN AND RECEPTIVE TO
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH OUR
PARTNERS AND WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON THIS IMPORTANT
TOPIC AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS HIGHER EDUCATION ISSUES
THAT SPAN ACROSS ALL OF OUR
SEGMENTS. SUCH DISCUSSIONS
SHOULD CONSIDER AN APPROPRIATE
SCOPE THAT COMPLEMENTS THE WORK
OF HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS
THAT LEVERAGES REPRESENTATION
FROM THE SEGMENTS THEMSELVES AND
OTHER CRITICAL VOICES AND
FOCUSES ON WORK THAT WOULD BUILD
UPON OUR EXISTING PARTNERSHIPS
AND LEVERAGE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE AS DOCTOR JUST
DESCRIBED. AND FINALLY,
OPTIMIZER COLLECTIVE EFFORTS IN
SERVICE TO OUR STUDENTS AND THE
STATE. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO WITH
YOU. AND I WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS
AT THE CLOSE OF OUR DISCUSSION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. DOCTOR
ROBBINS EXCEPT LIKE TO WELCOME
DR KATHERINE NEWMAN. GOOD
MORNING. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME. I'M REALLY HONORED TO
JOIN MY COUNTERPARTS ACROSS THE
TABLE HERE IN TALKING ABOUT THE
EXTRAORDINARY WORK WE DO TO
COLLABORATE TOGETHER TO PRODUCE
THE FINEST EDUCATION SYSTEM IN
THE NATION. I PERSONALLY AM A
PROUD PRODUCT OF THIS
LEGISLATURES INVESTMENT IN
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION. HAVING
COMPLETED MY DEGREES AT UC SAN
DIEGO AND èC, BERKELEY 10
MEMBERS OF MY FAMILY HAVE BEEN
SIMILARLY BLESSED. WE OWE IT
PRETTY MUCH EVERYTHING WE'VE
ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH TO YOUR
INVESTMENT IN PUBLIC, HIGHER
EDUCATION. I AM VERY PROUD THAT
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER EDUCATION
SEGMENTS ARE COMING TOGETHER
ACROSS ALL OF OUR BOUNDARIES ON
MANY MAJOR ISSUES, INCLUDING
ESPECIALLY OUR RECENT
PARTNERSHIP ON THE CRADLE TO
GRAVE CAREER DATA SYSTEM. EXCUSE
ME ALL THE WAY TO THE GRAVE AS
WELL AS YOU SEE, SYSTEM WIDE
PROVOST AND A SPECIALIST IN THE
STUDY OF LABOR MARKETS AND
ECONOMIC MOBILITY. I'M VERY KEEN
TO WORK WITH MY COUNTERPARTS IN
THE OTHER SEGMENTS ON SERVING
STATE WORKFORCE NEEDS, BOTH IN
TERMS OF CREATING NEW INDUSTRIES
THAT CREATE THE HIGH WAGE JOBS
AND IN TRAINING THE EMPLOYEES
THAT CAN FILL THOSE ROLES. THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA HAS A
SPECIAL ROLE TO PLAY IN
SUPPORTING THAT GROWTH BECAUSE
WE ARE AS YOU KNOW, A POWERHOUSE
OF INNOVATION THAT LEADS
DIRECTLY TO THOSE NEW INDUSTRIES
JUST TO SHOW YOU HOW HIGH TECH
WE ARE. I BROUGHT WITH ME MY
HOMEGROWN VISUAL AIDS. THANKS
CARDBOARD BACKED VISUAL AIDS,
THANKS TO THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
JUST TO ILLUSTRATE THIS POINT.
WE HAVE THE MOST PATENTS IN THE
NATION. UH MORE THAN 50,000
PATENTS NEARLY FOUR TIMES AS
MANY AS TEXAS AND 10 TIMES AS
MANY AS FLORIDA AND COMPARED TO
THE REST OF THE WORLD,
CALIFORNIA WOULD RANK SECOND
GLOBALLY. WE ARE NUMBER ONE IN
HIGHER EDUCATION FOR US PATENTS.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WAS
GRANTED MORE U. S UTILITY
PATENTS LAST YEAR THAN ANY OTHER
UNIVERSITY IN THE WORLD THAT
DOES NOT HAPPEN BY ACCIDENT. IT
HAPPENS BECAUSE THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR AND THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
INVESTED IN THIS KIND OF
EXTRAORDINARY HIGH QUALITY. TO
BENEFIT FROM THOSE INNOVATIONS
WE NEED. WE ALL NEED A STEADY
STREAM OF TALENT. THAT'S WHY YOU
SEE IS COMMITTED TO OPENING THE
DOORS OF OPPORTUNITY TO STUDENTS
FROM ALL BACKGROUNDS, ESPECIALLY
TRANSFER STUDENTS. WE WANT TO
MAKE THAT PATH TO TRANSFER. A
SEAMLESS AND ACCESSIBLE AS
POSSIBLE, AND YOU CAN SEE THAT
DEEP COMMITMENT IN OUR STUDENT
BODY. THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA ENROLLS MORK AS
USUAL. OH MENTIONED MORE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS THAN
ANY OTHER UNIVERSITY OF ITS
CALIBER IN THE NATION, ONE IN
EVERY THREE èC GRADUATES STARTS
THEIR CAREER AT A CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. 75% OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS WHO APPLY TO èC ARE
ADMITTED ALTOGETHER ALMOST
45,000 CURRENT UNDERGRADUATES
ARE COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRANSFER
STUDENTS. SO MY COLLEAGUES WHEN
YOU HEAR THAT THE SYSTEM IS
BROKEN. I WOULD LIKE YOU TO
THINK AGAIN. IT'S ACTUALLY
WORKING EXTREMELY EFFECTIVELY.
THERE IS NO OTHER PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM OF THE CALIBER
OF YOU SEE, THAT CAN BOAST THESE
KINDS OF TRANSFER STATISTICS.
AND THAT IS NOT AN ACCIDENT. WE
HAVE INVESTED. IN EXACTLY THAT
OUTCOME, STARTING AS EARLY AS
MIDDLE SCHOOL. èC HAS PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE STATE TO HELP
STUDENTS PREPARE FOR TRANSFER AS
A PATH TO FOUR YEAR COLLEGE
DEGREES. IN ADDITION, WE
COLLABORATE WITH OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PARTNERS TO PROVIDE
ACADEMIC PREPARATION THROUGH THE
PUENTE PROJECT AND IN
MATHEMATICS, ENGINEERING AND
SCIENCE ACHIEVEMENT OR THE MESA
PROGRAM. THIS REFLECTS THE GOALS
NOT ONLY OF THE LEGISLATURE BUT
OF THE GOVERNOR THROUGH THE
COMPACT THAT WE HAVE TO IMPROVE
ON ALL OF THESE DIMENSIONS
COLLECTIVELY, ALONG WITH UCS
TRANSFER PREP PROGRAMS, WE
PROVIDE DIRECT ACADEMIC
PREPARATION, ACADEMIC ADVISING
ADMISSION AND FINANCIAL AID AND
COLLEGE KNOWLEDGE SUPPORT TO
MORE THAN 40,000 COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS. TRANSFER
STUDENTS NOT ONLY ENROLL AT UC,
THEY ALSO THRIVE WITH US. THEY
GRADUATE AND GO ON TO CAREERS IN
SOME OF THE NATION'S MOST
IMPORTANT INDUSTRIES THROUGH OUR
U. C L, A PILOT AND OTHER
EFFORTS, INCLUDING THE JOURNEY
TO èC TRANSFER PROGRAMS WERE
ALSO CREATING MORE SEAMLESS
TRANSFER EXPERIENCES AND HELPING
TO MAKE A WORLD CLASS èC
EDUCATION ACCESSIBLE TO EVEN
MORE CALIFORNIANS, AND THAT
COMMITMENT WILL GROW IN TIME.
WHEN WE LOOK BEYOND TRANSFER. I
ALSO LIKE MY COLLEAGUES. VIEW
ONLINE EDUCATION IS ANOTHER AREA
WHERE THE SEGMENTS ARE WELL
POSITIONED TO COME TOGETHER TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO NEW POPULATIONS
IN THE STATE WITH NEW MODALITIES
, WE NEED TO CREATE HIGH QUALITY
ONLINE PROGRAMS THAT ARE A MODEL
FOR THE NATION AND FOR THE WORLD
. FINALLY AS WE PLAN FOR THE
FUTURE, IT'S CLEAR THAT WE NEED
A VISION IN THE STATE REGARDING
THE FUNDING NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM. I WAS NOT HERE WHEN CPAC
WAS DISBANDED. I UNDERSTAND
THERE WERE PROS AND CONS
INVOLVED. BUT I'VE BEEN TOLD
THAT IT DID A VERY GOOD JOB,
ESPECIALLY OF ASSESSING CAPITAL
FACILITY NEEDS AND ADVOCATING
FOR GENERAL OBLIGATION BOND ACTS
FOR POST SECONDARY EDUCATION,
SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD WE WOULD
WELCOME AGAIN, AND THAT IS A
ROLE WHERE THE SEGMENTS CAN COME
TOGETHER WITH A SINGLE VOICE
THAT MATTERS TO ALL OF US. OUR
SISTER STATES LOOK WITH ENVY ON
THE ACHIEVEMENTS OF THE
CALIFORNIA MASTER PLAN, IN WHICH
EACH SEGMENT FOCUSES ON
EXCELLENCE IN ITS OWN SPHERE.
THE DIFFERENTIATION OF FUNCTIONS
HAS WORKED. NO OTHER STATE HAS
AS MANY EXCELLENT ARE ONE
RESEARCH INSTITUTIONS, NOR HAVE
THEY BEEN ABLE TO GROW NEW ONES.
BUT U C. RIVERSIDE JUST LAST
YEAR BECAME THE EIGHTH èC
CAMPUS INVITED TO JOIN THE
PRESTIGIOUS AMERICAN ASSOCIATION
OF UNIVERSITIES. THAT'S THE TOP
65 UNIVERSITIES IN THE COUNTRY.
EIGHT OF THEM ARE YOU SEE
CAMPUSES. IT IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT. WE THINK IN TIMES
WHEN RESOURCES ARE CONSTRAINED
TO EMPHASIZE MISSIONS, SPECIFIC
EXCELLENCE AND MAXIMIZE THE
BENEFITS THROUGH COLLABORATION
OF THE KIND YOU'VE BEEN HEARING
ABOUT, RATHER THAN DUPLICATION.
WE HAVE CHALLENGES, BUT WE
SHOULD NOT LOSE SIGHT OF WHAT
CALIFORNIA HAS ACCOMPLISHED. AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
MY COLLEAGUES TODAY AND
ANSWERING YOUR QUESTIONS. TO SEE
HOW WE CAN BUILD ON THIS
REMARKABLE TRACK RECORD OF
SUCCESS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. DOCTOR NEWMAN. NEXT WOULD
LIKE TO WELCOME KRISTIN SAURUS.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU
FOR THE INVITATION TODAY CHAIR
NEWMAN AND SHARE FONG AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CHRISTIAN STORY AS THE PRESIDENT
OF THE INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA
COLLEGES, THE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING OUR DIVERSE SECTOR,
THE INDEPENDENT SECTOR I JUST
WILL UNDERSCORE IS INDEPENDENT.
SO THESE ARE 90 INSTITUTIONS.
ALL WITH THEIR OWN GOVERNING
BODIES, AND I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSCORE WHERE WE
HEARD FROM DR LO THAT CALIFORNIA
IS AN INCREDIBLY DIVERSE STATE
WITH AN INCREDIBLY DIVERSE
INSTITUTIONS. BUT WHEN WE COME
TOGETHER AND COLLABORATE, WE
MAKE THE DIFFERENCE FOR STUDENTS
, SO INDEPENDENT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH OUR PARTNERS WORKING WITH
ALL OF YOU SINCE THE INCEPTION
OF THE MASTER PLAN, I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO UNDERSCORE
THE INDEPENDENT COLLEGES WERE AN
INTEGRAL PART OF DRAFTING THE
ORIGINAL MASTER PLAN FROM
OVERSEEING AND SHARING THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE TO BEING ON
EVERY COMMITTEE THAT DEVELOPED
THE PLAN. OUR PLAN CAME TOGETHER
WITH ONE PURPOSE AND THAT WAS TO
SERVE STUDENTS IN THE STATE K
THROUGH 12 STUDENTS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
ADULTS, STUDENTS OR WHAT WE CALL
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS. THAT
WORK CONTINUES TODAY, AND WE
CONTINUE TO COLLABORATE AROUND
THAT. SO I THINK IS THIS BODY IF
WE KEEP STUDENTS CENTER IF WE
KEEP THE REGIONAL ASPECTS OF OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM CENTER AND
REALLY THINK ABOUT INSTITUTIONAL
DIVERSITY. IF WE COME THROUGH
THAT LENS WE CAN THINK ABOUT HOW
CAN WE IMPROVE COLLABORATION? AS
YOU'VE HEARD? WE COLLABORATE.
WELL WE WORK ON THE SYSTEMS CæA
AS PLEASED AND PROUD TO HAVE
ADOPTED THE ASSOCIATE DEGREE OF
TRANSFER THAT IS A PATHWAY THAT
WAS DEVELOPED BETWEEN THE
FACULTY OF CSU IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. THAT WE TOOK THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO USE THAT PATHWAY
BECAUSE IT'S WELL KNOWN STUDENTS
ARE USING IT TO SAY, HOW CAN WE
ADOPT THAT WITHIN OUR SECTOR SO
THAT WE CAN SERVE STUDENTS? 39
INSTITUTIONS OF THE I C. C YOU
HAVE ADOPTED THAT PATHWAY. IT'S
BEEN SUCCESSFUL TO DATE OVER
FIVE YEARS, 10,000 STUDENTS HAVE
BEEN ACCEPTED TO AN AI CCU
INSTITUTION. BUT WITH IT COMES
FROM CHALLENGES AND THAT IT IS A
PROGRAM BETWEEN CSU AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO THAT WHEN
OUR FACULTY WANT TO DEVELOP A
PROGRAM, FOR EXAMPLE, ONE
INSTITUTION WHO HAD AN EARLY
PROGRAM IN CYBER SECURITY OF THE
HIGH NEED WORK FORCE FIELD. WE
WEREN'T ABLE TO MAP THAT SINCE
WE DON'T HAVE THAT FACULTY
PROCESS, SO I THINK THAT'S AN
AREA OF IMPROVEMENT. THE OTHER
AREAS THAT DR SUSAN JAZZ ALSO
BROUGHT UP WAS MISSION CREEP.
AND WHILE WE NOW HAVE THE
APPLIED BACCALAUREATE, AND YOU
ALSO HEARD THIS FROM DR EVANS,
THEY APPLY DOCTORAL DEGREE. WHAT
DOES THAT LOOK LIKE? AND WHAT IS
THE IMPACT ON A I CCU
INSTITUTIONS WHO HAVE MANY
PROGRAMS IN THESE FIELDS. WE ARE
THE REPAIR OF THE ADVANCED
WORKFORCE IN THIS STATE. WE
COLLECTIVELY ENROLL OVER 150,000
GRADUATE STUDENTS THAT IS LARGER
THAN YOU. C AND C ISSUES
ENROLLMENT COMBINED. SO TODAY WE
ARE ROLE ENROLLING, GRADUATING
40% PREPARING 40% OF THE
TEACHERS. OVER 90% OF THE
CLINICAL PROFESSIONALS HIGH NEED
95% OF PHYSICIAN ASSISTANCE OVER
50% OF NURSES, SO THIS TIME TO
COME TOGETHER AND COLLABORATE TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS OF
OUR STUDENTS TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS OF OUR
WORKFORCE IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT. WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH OUR SEGMENT. PARTNERS
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU.
WE ARE EXCITED ABOUT THE NEW
PLAN THAT'S BEING DEVELOPED ON
THEIR MASTER PLAN FOR CAREER
EDUCATION. WE'RE ALL IN
PARTICIPATING THAT AS WELL. SO
WE WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH YOU ON WHAT IMPROVED
COORDINATION CAN LOOK LIKE I
WILL UNDERSCORE THAT IT MUST
HAVE SEGMENT REPRESENTATION TO
UNDERSTAND THE COMPLEXITIES OF
OUR INSTITUTIONS TO UNDERSTAND
THE REGULATORY INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WE MUST COMPLY WITH. AND
THE CREDIT ACCREDITATION
REQUIREMENTS THAT WE MUST ALSO
COMPLY WITH. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH TEACHING SEGMENTS
FOR SHARING YOUR INSIGHTS AND
HERE TODAY AND TO REALLY TALK
ABOUT THE CHALLENGES AND
STRATEGIES GOING FORWARD AS WELL
. JUST A QUICK QUESTION AND OPEN
UP TO MY COLLEAGUES. WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S BEEN VERY MANY
SIGNIFICANT REFORM EFFORTS OVER
THE LAST 15 YEARS. IT WAS JUST
HIGHLIGHTED WITH THE ASSOCIATE
DEGREES WHERE TRANSFER PROGRAM
ALSO CAN'T GET C AND MANY OTHER
REFORM EFFORTS HAS THE PACE OF
REFORM PLACE A BURDEN ON
IMPLEMENTATION. AND WHAT A
STANDING COORDINATED BODY HELP
RELIEVE SOME OF THE PRESSURE AND
GETTING THEIR FOLKS TOGETHER TO
REALLY IMPLEMENT A LOT OF THESE
NEW POLICIES. ANY OF THE
SEGMENTS LIKE TO TREATMENT? YES
TAKE A QUICK CRACK AT THAT ONE.
I DO WANT I DO THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT AS WE PROCEED WITH
THESE REFORMS TO BE CAREFUL TO
EVALUATE THEM. AND TO BE SURE
THEY'RE WORKING WELL BEFORE WE
SPREAD THEM TOO FAR. THIS IS THE
GENIUS BEHIND THE PILOT AT UCL
LÀ, WHICH IS OUR LARGEST
TRANSFER RECEIVING INSTITUTION,
AND THAT'S THE REASON WHY WE
FELT IT WAS IMPORTANT TO BEGIN
WITH THEM. BUT WE'RE GOING TO DO
SO IN A WAY THAT SYSTEMATIC WITH
THE DATA COLLECTED SO THAT WE
CAN SEE WHETHER OR NOT IT'S
EFFECTIVE AND THEN WE HAVE
COMMITTED TO EXPANDING BOTH.
EXPANDING THE NUMBER OF MAJORS
AT UCLA AND THEN EXPANDING TO
OUR OTHER INSTITUTIONS, BUT WE
WANT TO DO THAT. ONLY
UNDERSTANDING HOW EFFECTIVE IT
IS AND MEASURING QUESTIONS LIKE
TIME 2 DEGREES ARE WE SURE THAT
STUDENTS ARE PROPERLY PREPARED?
ARE WE ABLE TO MEASURE THEIR
PROGRESS SO THAT WE KNOW THEY'RE
NOT HAVING TO SPEND ADDITIONAL
FUNDS TO STAY LONGER WITH US IF
THEY'RE NOT IF THEY HAVE GAPS IN
THEIR PREPARATION? I THINK THIS
HAS BEEN VERY WELL PLANNED. FOR
EXACTLY THE KIND OF
EXPERIMENTATION THAT IS NEEDED
IN ORDER TO BE SURE, SOMETHING
WORKS BEFORE WE IMPLEMENTED IN
WAYS THAT ARE VERY EXPENSIVE. I
IF I MAY. I'M SORRY IF I MAY ADD
TO WHAT PROVINCE NEWMAN SHARED I
SO I THINK THOSE ARE ALL
ABSOLUTELY VALID POINTS. I THINK
ONE OF THE OTHER REALITIES IS IN
ABSENCE OF SOME TYPE OF ENTITY
THAT'S LOOKING BROADLY FOR EACH
OF THESE. AND YOU HEARD THIS
FROM DR JAZZ AS WELL AS SENIOR
VICE PRESIDENT DOWD. THERE HAS
BEEN THE NEED TO CREATE OR SPIN
UP AN INFRASTRUCTURE TO ADDRESS
EACH OF THESE AND THAT WHAT THAT
MEANS IS THERE'S NOT CONTINUITY
OFTEN ACROSS THEM. AND SO THAT
INSTITUTIONAL THAT HISTORIC
KNOWLEDGE AND CONTEXT HAS TO BE
SORT OF SCAFFOLDING FOR EVERY
ONE OF THOSE PROJECTS. AND SO I
DO THINK, YES, PACE, MAYBE ONE
ELEMENT BUT THE ABSENCE OF A WAY
TO BRING THOSE CONVERSATIONS
TOGETHER. SOMETIMES ALSO MAKES
MAKES THE STARTING POINT FOR
FURTHER THAN IT NEED BE EACH
TIME WE ADDRESS THESE TOPICS.
THANK YOU, DR EVANS, DOCTOR LIU
YES. SO THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION. CHAIR, FONG, I THINK
THE SIMPLE ANSWER IS GUESTS. AH
AS DR EVANS JUST SPOKE TO AS WE
RECEIVE A NEW POLICY INITIATIVES
, WHICH WE SUPPORT HER AND ARE
HAPPY TO RECEIVE. WE THEN HAVE
TO CREATE AN INFRASTRUCTURE AND
A PROCESS FOR IMPLEMENTATION.
WE'RE DOING THAT IN SILOS WITHIN
OUR RESPECTIVE SEGMENTS
COORDINATING THEN ACROSS OUR
SEGMENTS, BUT ALL OF THAT
REQUIRES TIME AND BANDWIDTH AND
RESOURCE. THAT MAKES IT A
CHALLENGE. RIGHT WHEN YOU THEN
HAVE FOUR OR FIVE DIFFERENT
MAJOR STATEWIDE INITIATIVES THAT
YOU'RE IMPLEMENTING AT THE SAME
TIME AND CERTAINLY CAN SPEAK FOR
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY.
COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IS A
SMALL STATE AGENCY WITH 160
EMPLOYEES TO SERVE 116 COLLEGES
AND ALMOST 2 MILLION STUDENTS.
WE DO THE WORK. WE MAKE THE
SACRIFICES TO DO THE WORK, BUT I
THINK WE DO THE WORK OF THIS
SERVICE BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
INDIVIDUALLY STAND UP A PLAN A
PROCESS FIND SUPPORT HIRE
CONSULTANTS OFTEN TO HELP CLOSE
THOSE GAPS AND TO DR EVANS,
POINTING IN PARTICULAR BECAUSE
OF THE PACE AT WHICH REFORM IS
MOVING. WE HAVEN'T TAKEN THE
TIME TO PAUSE AND RELEASE
STRATEGICALLY TIED ALL OF THESE
POLICY INITIATIVES TOGETHER AND
BE THOUGHTFUL ABOUT HOW WE'RE
GOING TO IMPLEMENT THEM IN
COHESION WITH ONE ANOTHER IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR SEGMENT
PARTNERS AND AS DR NEWMAN TALKED
ABOUT WITH EVALUATION AS A PART
OF THE PLAN FROM THE BEGINNING
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
DISORDERS UNDERSCORE WHAT MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE SHARED AND
AGAIN, IF WITH THAT STUDENT
FOCUS AND LENS THE 80 T, FOR
EXAMPLE, I MEAN, IT'S A
WONDERFUL PROGRAM, AND IT'S BEEN
WORKING, BUT EVALUATION IS
REALLY IMPORTANT. THE CRADLE TO
CAREER THAT IS A SUCCESS, AND
THAT WORK IS GOING TO BE ABLE TO
HELP US DRIVE AND IMPROVE THIS
AS WELL. BUT YES, THERE CAN BE,
I THINK. GREATER SYNERGY ABOUT
YOU KNOW AGAIN, HOW WOULD THESE
PROGRAMS OPERATE TO SERVE
STUDENTS IN THE CONTEXT OF
EVERYTHING ELSE? THANK YOU SO
MUCH. COLLEAGUES CHAIRMAN. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR FUNK. I AM ACTUALLY
I AM IMPRESSED THAT THERE IS A
APPARENT APPARENTLY A GOOD
CONSENSUS ACROSS ALL THE
SEGMENTS ABOUT THE NEED FOR A
COORDINATING BODY. LET ME ASK
YOU THE SAME QUESTION. I ASKED
OF THE FIRST ENGLISH WHAT WOULD
YOUR ADVICE BE TO US ABOUT HOW
TO GET FROM HERE TO THERE AND
SOME WAY THAT MAKES SENSE AND
WHAT WHAT'S THE FIRST ORDER OF
BUSINESS FOR THE LEGISLATURE IN
ASSISTING IN THAT PROCESS? THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT THAT
QUESTION I WOULD ECHO. SOME OF
THE COMMENTS ARE THE FIRST PANEL
SHARED. I DO THINK IT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT TO ALMOST START CLEAN
SHEET IN TERMS OF ENVISIONING
WHAT CALIFORNIA'S NEEDS AND WHAT
OUR STUDENTS AND COMMUNITIES
NEEDS ARE TODAY. THERE'S A
FREQUENCY AND I KNOW IT'S TO
SORT OF SHORTHAND A CPAC 2.0.
BUT AS IT WAS DISCUSSED EARLIER,
CPAC ORIGINATED MORE THAN FOUR
DECADES AGO. WE WERE A DIFFERENT
STATE, DIFFERENT POPULATION,
DIFFERENT NEEDS, AND SO I THINK,
REALLY STARTING FRESH AND
THINKING ABOUT THAT AND BUILDING
ON THE SUCCESSES THAT YOU HEARD
TODAY, THINKING ABOUT HOW THOSE
CAN COME TOGETHER RATHER THAN
COMPLETELY STARTING SOMETHING
THAT THAT STILL HAS THE REALITY
AS YOU HEARD FROM DR JAZZ, WHERE
PIECES ARE SPREAD THROUGHOUT THE
SORT OF GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AND
SO I THINK, REALLY STARTING
CLEAN SHEET AND NOT TYING IT
BACK TO CPAC. BUT REALLY THEN
BUILDING AND BRINGING TOGETHER
THE EFFORTS THAT ARE ALSO
UNDERWAY IN A COHESIVE A
COHESIVE MANNER. NO SECOND WITH
DR EVANS JUST SAID, AND I WOULD
ADD TO THAT THAT IN ADDITION TO
THIS NOTION THAT WE NEED A
COORDINATING ENTITY TO PROVIDE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE SEGMENT,
I WOULD HOPE THAT IF SUCH A
THING IS CREATED AND AGREE THAT
WE SHOULD START SORT OF TABULA
RASA THERE THAT THERE WOULD BE
SORT OF AN ETHOS OF SUPPORT. THE
SYNERGY YOU'RE FILLING HERE IS
VERY REAL. RIGHT. I HAVE THESE
INDIVIDUAL CELL PHONE NUMBERS.
WE ARE IN VERY CLOSE CONTACT
WITH ONE ANOTHER. WE ARE
CERTAINLY DOING ALL THAT WE CAN
TO COORDINATE OUR EFFORTS AND
KEEP STUDENTS AT THE CENTER. BUT
WE NEED SUPPORT. AND SO WHEN I
THINK ABOUT THE ROLE OF A
COORDINATING ENTITY, THE SUPPORT
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE FROM SUCH AN
ENTITY. AS WAS SPOKEN TO BY OUR
PREVIOUS PRESENTERS IS AROUND
DATA AND RESEARCH. I HAVE THE
PLEASURE OF CHAIRING THE 928
COMMITTEE FOR ITS FIRST TWO
YEARS AND AS WE GRAPPLED WITH
MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS FOR SOME
OF THE GOALS THAT WERE PUT
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE GOALS LIKE
CREATING A PLAN OF ACTION FOR
HOW WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE
REGIONAL GAPS. WE WERE REALLY
STUCK WITH A LACK OF DATA AND
INFORMATION. WE DON'T HAVE A
REGIONAL LANDSCAPE ANALYSIS TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE NEEDS AND
OPPORTUNITIES ARE WITHIN EACH
REGION. WE NEED THAT THE BABY
928 COMMITTEE WAS ASKED TO
PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS ON GOALS
AROUND WORKFORCE AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. WE DON'T HAVE A
LANDSCAPE ANALYSIS RIGHT OF THE
WORKFORCE NEEDS WITHIN OUR
REGION WITHIN REGIONS ACROSS THE
STATE, SO THAT ROLL AROUND DATA
CANNOT BE UNDERSTATED IS VERY
IMPORTANT SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
WELL INFORMED, DATA DRIVEN
DECISIONS. I THINK THAT WOULD
ALSO BE IMPORTANT FOR SUCH AN
ENTITY IS TO PROVIDE A PLATFORM
FOR THE SEGMENTS TO COME
TOGETHER ON POLICY
IMPLEMENTATION. WE DO THAT, BUT
WE DO IT AT HOC DR. EVANS
TALKING ABOUT WE THEN HAVE TO
ACTIVATE OUR SMALL STAFFS TO
TAKE ON YET ANOTHER THING, IT
WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL TO HAVE
THE SUPPORT OF IN ENTITY THAT
WHEN A NEW PIECE OF LEGISLATION
IS PASSED, THAT THERE'S A PLACE
TO BRING THAT AND THAT WE HAVE
RESOURCES. SUPPORT TO HELP US IN
THAT COORDINATION IN THAT
PLANNING. AND THEN, AS I TALKED
ABOUT IN PARTICULAR IN MY
COMMENTS COMING OUT OF THE A B
928 COMMITTEE WERE ACTUALLY
ASKING FOR SUPPORT FOR SOMETHING
VERY SPECIFIC, WHICH IS THE
PROCESS OF FACULTY ACROSS THE
SEGMENTS COMING TOGETHER TO
COORDINATE ON CURRICULUM. THAT'S
HOW YOU BUILD TRANSFER PATHWAYS,
IN ADDITION TO THE LARGER POLICY
NEEDS AND DATA NEEDS, WE NEED TO
RESOURCE AN OPPORTUNITY TO BRING
OUR FACULTY TOGETHER SO THAT
THEY CAN COLLABORATE ON
DESIGNING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STUDENTS. PROVIDES NEWMAN WHO IS
NOT RELATED TO ME, I HAVE NOT AT
ALL I WISH, BUT NOT AT ALL. UM I
WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT THE
COMMENTS THAT HAVE JUST BEEN
MADE. I THINK THE UC SYSTEM
WOULD PROBABLY ADVOCATE FOR A
SOMEWHAT MORE CAUTIOUS APPROACH
TO COLLABORATION. THE MOST
IMPORTANT ELEMENT WE NEED, AS DR
LO SAID, HIS RESOURCES THAT
SUPPORT COORDINATION WHETHER
THEY FLOW THROUGH A BODY OR THEY
DON'T FLOW THROUGH. YOUR BODY IS
CRITICAL IF WE'RE GOING TO
ACTUALLY ACHIEVE THESE
COORDINATIVE GOALS THAT WE HAVE
THE RESOURCES NECESSARY TO MAKE
THEM STICK. I DO THINK THE DATA
ISSUES ARE CRITICAL. I WOULD
ARGUE THAT WE NEED A GROUP THAT
CAN HELP US WITH OCCUPATIONAL
FORECASTING WITH UNDERSTANDING
WHAT, FOR EXAMPLE, THE IMPACT OF
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE IS GOING
TO BE ON LABOR MARKET DEMAND AND
THE WAYS IN WHICH OCCUPATIONS
WILL GROW AND SHRINK THAT
MATCHING TOGETHER THE DATA NEEDS
OF THE STATE'S ECONOMIC SYSTEM
AND THE UNIVERSITY'S ROLE IN
PROVIDING THE LABOR FORCE SEEMS
TO ME TO BE A PARTICULARLY
HELPFUL WAY IN WHICH THAT
COORDINATION COULD MATTER. BUT I
DO WANT TO UNDERLINE AGAIN.
THERE'S A GREAT DEAL OF SUCCESS
ALREADY IN PLACE, AND I WOULD BE
CAREFUL NOT TO BURDEN IT TOO
MUCH WITH ELEMENTS OF
COORDINATION THAT CAN MAKE IT
HARDER FOR US TO CONTINUE TO
ACHIEVE THESE EXTRAORDINARY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS. I MEAN, THERE
IS NO OTHER STATE IN THE NATION
THAT HAS A RECORD EQUIVALENT TO
OURS. SO LET'S BE CAREFUL. ABOUT
WHAT WE DO TO AFFECT THE WAY IN
WHICH THAT WORKS. THE STORIES
DONE TO ECHO IN SUPPORT WHAT MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE A SHARED. I
THINK THERE'S SOME OPPORTUNITIES
HERE TO SEE TO SEE THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN DEVELOPED AND TO
ALIGN WITH THAT. SO TO REALLY
LOOK ACROSS THE INFRASTRUCTURE
OF WHAT'S IN PLACE AND WHAT CAN
BE BUILT UPON. I THINK A CLEAN
SHEET, AS DR EVANS SAYS, IS
EXACTLY RIGHT. WHAT I WOULD
UNDERSCORE FOR I DO IS THAT
THERE BE REPRESENTATION TO BE
SURE THAT WERE INCLUDED. OF THE
ASSETS IN OUR SECTOR AND AS IT
WAS IN THE CPAC, BUT SEE TO SEE
WHEN OUR SYSTEM SECTORS ACTUALLY
A REPRESENTATIVE ON ACTUAL
GOVERNING BOARD. I THINK WE'RE
BETTER UNDERSTOOD AND VALUED. SO
I WOULD ARGUE FOR THAT, UM AGAIN
. I THINK PROVOST NEWMAN SAID IT
WELL, THERE IS A LOT WORKING
WELL, AND IT'S JUST ABOUT HOW DO
WE KNOW SCAFFOLD APPROPRIATELY
AND SUPPORT IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL. SURE I I'M STILL
CURIOUS ABOUT HOW WE TRANSLATE
ALL OF THIS INTO LEGISLATIVE
ACTION. BUT IS IT SOMETHING LIKE
YOU KNOW THE 89 TO 8 PROCESS,
YOU KNOW, AS A FIRST STEP IN
YOUR VIEW, DR LOWER, OR IS IT
SOMETHING ELSE? RIGHT YOU KNOW,
DON'T HOPEFUL THAT WE'LL LEAVE
HERE TODAY WITH SOMETHING THAT
THAT SORT OF GIVES US SOME
DIRECTION, THE LEGISLATURE AND
HOW WE CAN ASSIST YOU AND
CREATING A USEFUL AND ADAPTABLE
COORDINATING STRUCTURE THAT
WORKS FOR ALL THE SEGMENTS. I
THINK WE CAN BUILD OFF OF WHAT
IT WAS ESTABLISHED FOR A B 928.
IF YOU LOOK AT THAT THE
MEMBERSHIP OF THAT BODY YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT A SMALL
REPRESENTATION OF SORT OF
INDIVIDUALS REPRESENTING WHAT IS
REALLY THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE. SO I
THINK WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT
A FUTURE COORDINATING BODY MIGHT
BE I WOULD RECOMMEND RIGHT, BUT
IT NEEDS TO HAVE PARTS IN PIECES
IN TERMS OF, FOR EXAMPLE, WHEN I
SIT IN THAT ROOM, UM I AM THE
LEADERSHIP VOICE FOR THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM. I
WOULD ARGUE. WE NEED MORE VOICES
THAN MINE AT THE TABLE THAT I
APPRECIATE MY OWN TO BE A PART
OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS. SO HOW
MIGHT YOU HAVE A STRUCTURE WHERE
THERE IS A COORDINATING BODY?
BUT THERE ARE SUB COMMITTEES AND
OTHER BODIES THAT REALLY TAP
INTO THE EXPERTISE ON THE
GROUND. THAT IS DOING THE ACTUAL
WORK RIGHT OF BUILDING THESE
PROGRAMS OF SUPPORTING STUDENTS,
SO I WOULD SAY A GENERAL
STRUCTURE SIMILAR TO WHAT HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED WITH 928, BUT
WITH MORE LAYERS SO THAT THERE
ARE MORE VOICES CONTRIBUTING TO
THAT THE DESIGN OF
RECOMMENDATIONS AND IN
PARTICULAR THOSE WHO ARE IN THE
FIELD DOING THE WORK. I COULD
JUST ADD TO THAT AND IT'S
ECHOING ONE OF YOUR POINTS.
SORRY IT GOES ON AND OFF ON ITS
OWN. UM 8928, I THINK WAS REALLY
QUITE A MODEL PROCESS. BUT IF
YOU LOOK AT THE IMPLEMENTATION
RESOURCES TO MAKE IT WORK, IT'S
NOT AS ROBUST AS WOULD BE
HELPFUL. WE NEED TO INVOLVE
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE. FACULTY
MEMBERS ACROSS THE SYSTEMS WHO
CAN COORDINATE SO THAT STUDENTS
NOT ONLY ARE ADMITTED TO THE èC
BUT ARE PREPARED PROPERLY AND
SUCCEED TO BRING THOSE PEOPLE
TOGETHER. WE'RE BASICALLY
CREATING EXTRA JOBS FOR THEM.
WHEREVER WE CAN PROVIDE RELEASED
TIME FOR THEM TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR THEM TO PARTICIPATE. WE HAVE
MORE VOICES AT THE TABLE. SO
PERSONALLY, I WOULD SAY THAT THE
928 PROCESS PROPERLY RESOURCED
IS AN EXCELLENT WAY TO GO. I
APPRECIATE THAT. SIT DOWN.
SENATOR KOBOLD. SORRY I'M ALL
THE WAY HERE. UM SO I REALLY,
REALLY APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK
THAT ALL OF YOU WITHIN YOUR OWN
SPACES HAVE ACTUALLY CONTRIBUTED
THIS MORNING BECAUSE I HAVE
ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN THINKING
ABOUT THIS FOR THE PAST COUPLE
OF YEARS, ESPECIALLY RECENTLY IN
THIS IN THIS LAST YEAR ABOUT THE
UM IMPACT THAT WE'RE HAVING IS
ALLEGED LEGISLATURE COMING IN
WITH BILL PROPOSALS ON CHANGING
AND CORRELATING THINGS AND I AM
GOING YES, BUT THERE WAS
DIFFERENT SYSTEMS FOR DIFFERENT
PURPOSES. UM DR NEWMAN. I REALLY
APPRECIATED YOUR COMMENTS TODAY.
VERY, VERY ALL OF YOU. UM I
THINK AS FAR AS LEGISLATIVELY
WHAT I'M HEARING IS THAT, UM ITS
BUDGET, ALLOCATING MONEY SO THAT
WE CAN IT LITERALLY CREATE THE
UM THE. JOBS. UM FOR THESE
PROFESSORS TO COME IN AND BE
ABLE TO COORDINATE IS THAT'S
THAT'S THE NUMBER ONE THING WE
WERE TO EXPAND LEGISLATIVELY. IT
WOULD BE ADDING NUMBERS TO THE
COMMITTEE TO THE COMMISSION AND
ADDING THE APPROPRIATE FUNDING
SO THAT PEOPLE CAN ACTUALLY DO
THE JOB OF THE COORDINATING SO
ADDING NUMBERS TO THE
COMMISSION. AND THE FUNDING TO
BE ABLE TO PAY THEM TO BE ABLE
TO DO THAT JOB. AT LEAST FOR US.
I WASN'T THINKING SO MUCH OF
ADDING NEW PEOPLE. IT'S THE
PEOPLE WE HAVE WHO NEED A BIT
MORE TIME TO MOBILIZE THEIR
EXPERTISE TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE
DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW WE
COORDINATE ACROSS OUR SEGMENTS,
SO IT'S LESS ABOUT FUNDING
COMMISSION MEMBERS AND MORE
ABOUT ENABLING US TO TAP THE
EXPERTISE IN OUR SYSTEMS.
BECAUSE THEY ALREADY HAVE FULL
TIME JOBS. SO WE NEED TO REPLACE
THEIR TEACHING. FOR EXAMPLE, IF
THEY'RE GOING TO BE SECONDED TO
THE TASK OF DECIDING HOW TO
BUILD A PROGRAM IN ENGINEERING
THAT'S GOING TO, YOU KNOW,
CRISSCROSS ALL OF OUR SYSTEMS.
BUT YOU KNOW, IT CERTAINLY HELPS
TO HAVE THOSE RESOURCES. IT
MAKES THE PROCESS MOVE FASTER.
IT MAKES IT EASIER TO CALL ON
PEOPLE AND WE THINK, IN THE END,
IT PROVIDES FOR A MUCH MORE
EFFECTIVE, EFFICIENT SYSTEM FOR
THE STATE AS A WHOLE. DO YOU
HAVE? SO DO YOU NEED A SPECIFIC
HAVE ENOUGH STAFF FOR EVERY
FIELD THAT YOU'RE WORKING WITH?
IS THAT IS THAT HOW IT WOULD
WORK OR WOULD IT ARE YOU ASKING
US IF WE HAVE ENOUGH STAFF
BECAUSE WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO
GIVE YOU AN ANSWER, COORDINATING
THE CORRELATION BETWEEN ONE
MAJOR TO ANOTHER MAJOR FROM ONE
SCHOOL TO ANOTHER SCHOOL DO YOU
NEED TO HAVE SPECIFIC PEOPLE
WITHIN THOSE MAJORS TO BE ABLE
TO COORDINATE. YES WE ASKED THEM
TO DO THAT. SO WE IT'S VERY
HELPFUL TO US IF WE CAN PROVIDE
SOME SUPPORTED RELEASE TIME
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T HAVE TO PUT
SOMEONE ELSE BACK IN THE
CLASSROOM WHILE THEY'RE WORKING
ON THE COORDINATION PROCESS, SO
IT'S REALLY IT'S NOT A MATTER SO
MUCH OF HIRING NEW PEOPLE AS IT
IS BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE FOR
SOME OF THE COMMITMENTS THAT
EXISTING PEOPLE NEED TO MAKE TO
MAKE THIS HAPPEN. AS MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID, THIS IS
VERY MUCH A FACULTY TO FACULTY
PROCESS BECAUSE THE ELECTRICAL
ENGINEERS THAT ARE IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES NEED TO TALK
EXTENSIVELY WITH THE ELECTRICAL
ENGINEERS IN THE UC SYSTEM. TO
BE SURE THE COURSES THEY'RE
DEVELOPING IN THE FRONT END.
SEAMLESSLY FLOW TOWARD THE
ADVANCED COURSES THEY WILL DO
WHEN THEY COME WITH US. SO WHEN
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE NUMBERS OF
HOW MANY PEOPLE YOU WILL BE?
NEEDING TO ENGAGE. WE'RE LOOKING
AT EVERY SINGLE AREA OF UM MAJOR
THAT YOU HAVE. WELL, I THINK WE
CAN PROBABLY DO THINGS IN SORT
OF SYRIA SERIAL FASHION, SO
WE'RE NOT DUPLICATING THE ENTIRE
SIZE OF OUR FACULTY. BUT I WOULD
JUST SAY THIS IS IN KEEPING WITH
DR LO'S POINTS WHEN A MANDATE
COMES FROM THE LEGISLATURE, EVEN
ONE THAT WE EMBRACE IT'S NOT
COST FREE TO IMPLEMENT IT. AND
SO IT REALLY HELPS A LOT TO
SPEED THE PROCESS IF THERE'S DUE
ATTENTION TO THE RESOURCES
NEEDED, AS WOULD BE TRUE OF ANY
LEGISLATIVE MANDATE, I THINK I
HAVE TO AGREE. THANK YOU. SO
MUCH FOR YOUR FEEDBACK TODAY WAS
VERY, VERY HELPFUL AND
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU SO MUCH
ENERGY OR BOTH. NEXT UP. WE HAVE
SENATOR CUEVAS FOLLOWED BY
SUMMER. MERCY G. THANK YOU.
APOLOGIES FOR MY MASK. I'M
GETTING OVER A LITTLE COLD. I
REALLY APPRECIATED THE COMMENTS
ABOUT WORKFORCE, BUT I WANTED IF
WE COULD DRILL DOWN A LITTLE BIT
MORE ON THAT. IN TERMS OF HOW
YOUR SYSTEMS ARE COLLABORATING
AROUND WORKFORCE. THE STATE IS
ON THE CUSP OF RECEIVING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE. FUNDS TO SORT OF
LOOK AT CLIMATE RESILIENCY
TECHNOLOGIES, UM, SCIENCES, UM,
ALL THE WAY TO THE ACTUAL
MANUFACTURING PIECE THAT I THINK
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
CERTAINLY PREPARED TO ADDRESS,
BUT I'M CURIOUS HOW YOU
PRIORITIZE. WHERE YOU FOCUS ON
WORKFORCE. I THINK DR NEWMAN YOU
TALKED ABOUT THE ALIGNMENT OF
THE ELECTRICAL ENGINEERS, WHICH
WAS REALLY FASCINATING TO ME.
BUT HOW DO YOU ACTUALLY
COLLABORATE? ON WORKFORCE AND.
WHERE DO YOU DETERMINE? UM,
BECAUSE THERE ARE MILLIONS OF
CLASSIFICATIONS. RIGHT UM, WHERE
DO YOU DETERMINE WHERE YOUR
FOCUS WILL BE? UM WE KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF APPRENTICESHIPS.
WE KNOW THE IMPORTANCE OF
LEARNING EARNING OPPORTUNITIES.
AND SO I JUST WONDER HOW YOU
FACTOR ALL OF THOSE THINGS IN TO
YOUR WORKFORCE. COLLABORATION.
IT SOUNDS LIKE ON TRANSFER.
WE'RE GETTING THERE. RIGHT. LIKE
TRANSFER IS DON'T KNOW IF THERE
IS THE MODEL OF THAT THAT CAN BE
APPLIED IN OTHER PLACES. BUT I'M
CURIOUS ABOUT THE WORKFORCE
BECAUSE IT'S ONE AREA THAT. I
FEEL WE ARE FAR BEHIND AS WE'RE
TRYING TO REACH THESE CLIMATE,
RESILIENT GOALS. UM WE STILL
HAVE A TOUGH TIME GETTING OUR
WORKFORCE. ORGANIZED RECRUITED.
IN CLASSROOMS AND IN SOME SORT
OF PATHWAY THAT WOULD INCLUDE
ALL OF OUR SYSTEMS, SO I'M JUST
CURIOUS IF YOU COULD SAY MORE
ABOUT THE COLLABORATION AROUND
WORKFORCE AND WHAT YOU
PRIORITIZE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT QUESTION. I'M HAPPY TO
BEGIN. I KNOW ALL ALL OF US
COULD SPEAK TWO DIFFERENT
EXAMPLES, SO I WOULD SAY THERE
ARE BOTH THOSE THAT ARE WE'RE
ADDRESSING SORT OF IN THE
IMMEDIATE YOU SPOKE ABOUT SOME
OF THOSE THERE ARE OTHERS IN,
FOR EXAMPLE, THE EDUCATOR
WORKFORCE. WE KNOW THE CRITICAL
NEED AND NOW WITH CHANGING
CERTIFICATION EXPECTATIONS IN
PRE K THROUGH, YOU KNOW, THREE
HAVE BROUGHT TOGETHER BECAUSE AS
YOU HEARD FROM DR LO, MORE THAN
HALF OF OUR CSU BACCALAUREATE
DEGREE EARNERS STARTED THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE, SO AS WE ARE
THINKING ABOUT EXPANDING AND
MEETING BOTH THE IMMEDIATE AND
FUTURE NEEDS, IT IS MOST
FREQUENTLY IN TANDEM WITH OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PARTNERS
BECAUSE THE MAJORITY OF OUR
STUDENTS START THEIR JOURNEY
THERE. SO FOR EXAMPLE, BRINGING
TOGETHER FACULTY AND LEADER IN
THE EDUCATION SPACES TO SORT OF
CO CREATE THAT CURRICULUM MUCH
THE WAY THAT THAT PROVIDES
NEWMAN DESCRIBED WITH
ENGINEERING THAT ALSO PLAYS OUT
SO BRINGING THOSE FIELDS OF
STUDY TOGETHER. INCLUSIVE OF THE
EMPLOYERS TO THOSE CONVERSATIONS
, AND SO THAT IS ONE SPACE
NURSING WOULD BE ANOTHER. YOU
KNOW, I SPOKE ABOUT ONE OF THE
LIMITATIONS THAT HINDERS ALL OF
US IN GROWING NURSING PROGRAMS
ARE THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS IN THE
AVAILABILITY AND STRUCTURE THAT
HAS TO BE IN PLACE, NO MATTER
WHERE A STUDENT STARTS. THAT'S
GOING TO BE A BARRIER, SO
BRINGING TOGETHER OUR SYSTEM.
DEMS AND SEGMENTS TO TALK WITH
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
WITH THE LARGER HEALTHCARE
EMPLOYERS AND NAVIGATING AND
DESIGNING PROGRAMS THAT CAN
ADDRESS NOT ONLY THE IMMEDIATE
WORKFORCE NEED, BUT HOW DO WE
THINK ABOUT THAT DIFFERENTLY
ACROSS THE SEGMENTS BECAUSE
WE'RE ALL WORKING TOWARDS
SIMILAR GOALS? I WOULD SAY THE
ONE AND OPPORTUNITY THAT YOU'VE
HEARD TODAY IS IN THE DATA TO BE
AHEAD OF THAT RIGHT NOW. I'M
SPEAKING ABOUT ADDRESSING THE
NEEDS OF TODAY, UM, IN ABSENCE
AND WE'RE ALL A VERY OPTIMISTIC
OF THE CRADLE TO CAREER SYSTEM
AS WELL AS FEEDING OTHER DATA,
BUT REALLY GETTING AHEAD AND
PLANNING IS AN OPPORTUNITY. AND
I THANK YOU HEARD FROM ALL OF US
IN DIFFERENT WAYS. AND I WOULD
JUST ADD TO THAT CERTAINLY
SECONDING WHAT DR EVANS HAS
SHARED WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
WORKFORCE AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT, YOU KNOW, MEMBER
SMALL EQUIVALENT. I THINK YOU
ARE CORRECT. RIGHT IN YOUR
EXAMINATION THAT THIS IS AN AREA
OF NEEDED IMPROVEMENT. MUCH IS
TAKING PLACE HAS TAKEN PLACE IN
PARTICULAR FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT,
PREPARING STUDENTS TO GO
DIRECTLY INTO THE WORKFORCE IS
HISTORICALLY SOMETHING THAT OUR
COLLEGES HAVE DONE WILL CONTINUE
TO DO. YOU WILL CERTAINLY SEE
UNDER THE DIRECTION OF OUR NEW
CHANCELLOR, DR SONJA CHRISTIAN
AND OUR NEW VISION 2030, A
ROADMAP FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES,
THAT WORKFORCES CENTER AND WE
ARE PUSHING ON THAT VERY HEAVILY
WITH OUR COLLEGES THAT ALL OF
ACADEMICS AS WORKFORCE AT ALL OF
OUR STUDENTS ARE INVESTING IN
HIGHER EDUCATION BECAUSE THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR WORK FORCE AND AN
ECONOMIC OUTCOME AND THAT WE
HAVE TO DESIGN ALL PROGRAMS WITH
THAT WORKFORCE OUTCOME IN MIND,
AND SO WE'RE DOUBLING DOWN ON
THAT. BUT WHEN WE THINK ABOUT,
FOR EXAMPLE, YOU KNOW WORKING
TOWARDS KEY AREAS THAT WE KNOW
THERE ARE GAPS, EDUCATION,
NURSING AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE. BUT SECOND WHAT DR EVANS
SAID. HOW DO WE GET AHEAD OF
THAT? HOW DO WE ACTUALLY KNOW
WHAT THE JOBS OF THE FUTURE ARE?
SO THAT WE CAN DESIGN THOSE
PROGRAMS AND THEN THIS IS WHERE
HONESTLY, I WOULD SAY THIS IS
WHERE A COORDINATING BODY WOULD
BE HELPFUL. HOW DO WE HAVE THAT
DATA AND INFORMATION? AND THEN
HOW DO WE THEN COORDINATE
RESPECTIVELY ACROSS SYSTEMS
AROUND THE ROLE THAT EACH ONE OF
US IS GOING TO PLAY AND BUILDING
THAT WORKFORCE PIPELINE BECAUSE,
DEPENDING ON THE PIPELINE,
STUDENTS MAY NEED TO GO ALL THE
WAY RIGHT TO THE DOCTORAL
DEGREE, SENDING THEM OFF INTO
ENGINEERING AND OTHER SCIENCES
AT UC AND ICU INSTITUTIONS
COORDINATING THAT EFFORT WOULD
DEFINITELY BE HELPFUL. IF I CAN
JUST ADD TO THAT I DO THINK WE
HAVE A VERY STRONG MODEL FOR
SEGMENTAL DIVISION OF LABOR,
WHERE THEY'RE DIFFERENT SLICES
OF THE LABOR MARKET THAT OUR
STUDENTS ARE AIMING FOR, AND
THAT WE PREPARE THEM FOR AND I
THINK WE'VE GOT A VERY GOOD WAY
OF THINKING ABOUT THAT. BUT IF I
WAS GOING TO ADD TWO ELEMENTS TO
THIS MIX THAT I THINK WOULD BE
IMPORTANT WHEN I MENTIONED
BEFORE FORECASTING CONNECTING
THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR TO THE
UNIVERSITY IN WAYS THAT HELP US
FORECAST WHERE THE LABOR MARKET
IS MOVING, WHAT OCCUPATIONS ARE
GOING TO BE GROWING WHAT'S GOING
TO BE SHRINKING SO THAT WE CAN
THINK AHEAD BECAUSE IT TAKES
YEARS TO PREPARE THESE PROGRAMS
AND YEARS FOR STUDENTS TO MOVE
THROUGH THEM. BUT THE SECOND
THING I WOULD SAY, AND NOW HERE
I AM SPEAKING MAINLY FOR MY OWN
SEGMENT. I WOULD LOVE TO SEE A
MUCH MORE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
IN WHAT WE CALL EXPERIENTIAL
LEARNING. IT IS NOT ENOUGH FOR
OUR STUDENTS TO BE IN OUR
CLASSROOMS. THEY NEED TO BE IN
LABORATORIES WHEREVER POSSIBLE
THEY NEED TO HAVE CO OP
OPPORTUNITIES WITH INDUSTRIES IN
THE REGION. SO THEY GET SHOP
FLOOR EXPERIENCE, SO THEY HAVE
REFERENCES. THIS IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT FOR OUR FIRST
GENERATION LOW INCOME STUDENTS
WHOSE PARENTS ARE NOT GOING TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THEM PROBABLY
WITH THOSE SORTS OF REFERENCES
AND CONNECTIONS. BUT I THINK
WE'RE BEHIND THE CURVE ON
EXPERIENTIAL LEARNING, NOT
RELATIVE TO OUR PEERS BECAUSE
ALL PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION AT
OUR LEVEL IS BEHIND THE CURVE.
BUT I DO THINK WE NEED TO DO
MORE. I THINK EMPLOYERS ARE
WILLING TO ENGAGE WITH US.
BECAUSE THEY'RE LOOKING FOR US
TO PREPARE THAT WORKFORCE AND
THEY WOULD REALLY LIKE THOSE
PEOPLE TO HAVE MORE EXPERIENCE
AS OPPOSED TO JUST THE CLASSROOM
LEARNING, BUT THAT IS EXPENSIVE
TO DEVELOP EXPENSIVE TO PROVIDE
PREPARATION FOR, AND THOSE
STUDENTS CAN'T REALLY AFFORD TO
DO THIS WITHOUT BEING ABLE TO
EARN, YOU KNOW, SUMMER MONEY,
THEY CAN'T WORK FOR FREE. SO
THAT'S SOMETHING I THINK THE UC
SYSTEM IS, IS REALLY INTERESTED
IN FIGURING OUT HOW TO INVEST IN
SOME OF OUR FIELDS DO THAT,
NATURALLY. ENGINEERING BEING ONE
OF THEM OTHERS NOT SO MUCH. AND
PRETTY MUCH EVERYBODY COULD
BENEFIT FROM FROM SUCH AN
INVESTMENT. I REALLY APPRECIATE
THIS QUESTION BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
PREPARE THE STUDENTS FOR THE
JOBS TODAY. AND THE JOBS OF
TOMORROW. AND WE ARE IN A VERY
RAPIDLY CHANGING WORKFORCE WITH
A I. WE ARE JUST AT THE VERY TIP
OF WHERE THE WORKFORCE IN
CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO GO. I DO
THINK COORDINATING BODY COULD BE
HELPFUL HERE AS WE THINK ABOUT
THIS WITHIN OUR SEGMENTS AND
THAT WE CAN ALSO LEARN FROM ONE
ANOTHER. AND THERE ARE SOME
INSTITUTIONS WHO DO THAT WORK OF
PUTTING STUDENTS INTO THOSE
LEARNING JOB TRAINING
EXPERIENCES. ENORMOUSLY HELPFUL
WHEN THEY GRADUATE. THEY ARE
READY TO GO IN THE ALREADY TO
ENTER INTO THE WORKFORCE. SO
AFFORDABILITY IS REALLY
IMPORTANT HERE. WE HAVEN'T
TALKED A LOT ABOUT FINANCIAL AID
. SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT DAD
MENTIONED COORDINATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION THAT WILL BE
IMPORTANT TO EVEN WITH THE STATE
HAS AND WE'VE SEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL AND TEACHING. IS THIS
FUNDING SUPPORT FOR RESIDENCIES?
SO THAT'S TEACHERS OF THE FUTURE
. HAVE THAT FIRST EXPERIENCE
WHERE THEY'RE FULLY FUNDED, AND
THEY CAN AFFORD THE PROGRAM. SO
AFFORDABILITY SUPPORT OF SUPPORT
. I WOULD ALSO UNDERSCORE AT THE
TABLE OF COORDINATION, THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR AND OTHER
GROUPS WHO ARE FORECASTING SO
THAT WERE IN LINE WITH THEM AT
ONE TABLE. AT THE INSTITUTIONAL
LEVEL REGIONAL LEVEL. WE HAVE TO
BE VERY, VERY MINDFUL OF THIS TO
THE INLAND EMPIRE MAY NEED IS
GOING TO BE DIFFERENT THAN THE
BAY AREA NOW. SO HOW WE
INTENTIONAL ABOUT THAT, BUT THE
FRESNO AREA IS GOING TO NEED IS
VERY DIFFERENT, SO WE HAVE
THRIVING INDUSTRIES IN THE STATE
, AND WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
THINK ABOUT HOW TO FASTER THOSE
WHO ARE HERE AND AGAIN. I THINK
WE'RE ALL TRYING TO PLAN FOR THE
FUTURE AS RAPIDLY AS IT'S
COMING. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
SENATOR. SOME REMEMBER MERCER
JIN. THANK YOU. I WANTED TO. I
AM HEARING SOME POINTS WHERE
THERE SEEMS TO BE AGREEMENT OF
THE BENEFICIAL ABOUT THE
BENEFITS OF HAVING SOME KIND OF
A COORDINATING BODY. ALTHOUGH I
HEAR DR NEWMAN SEEM TO BE THE
ONLY ONE EMPHASIZING CAUTION,
AND I WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT.
BUT MY FIRST QUESTION IS, UM,
SEVERAL OF YOU MENTIONED UM, HOW
A COORDINATED BODY COULD BE
BENEFICIAL TO IDENTIFY CAPITAL
NEEDS CAPITAL FACILITY NEEDS.
HOW WOULD A COORDINATED BODY BE
BENEFICIAL AS OPPOSED TO EACH
ONE OF THE PUBLIC SEGMENTS? YOU
KNOW, I AM THINKING ABOUT YOU
KNOW OUR DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
EDUCATION BOND FOR THE NEVER
PREVENT VALID. HOW WOULD A
COORDINATED BODY BE BETTER THAN
HEARING FROM EACH SEGMENT IN
TERMS OF WHAT YOUR CAPITAL
FACILITY NEEDS HER? WELL I THINK
YOU WILL HEAR PLENTY FROM EACH
SEGMENT, BUT IN SPEAKING WITH A
UNIFIED VOICE ABOUT THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA'S NEEDS FOR INVESTING
IN PHYSICAL FACILITIES IN
LABORATORIES IN YOU KNOW,
CLINICAL FACILITIES AND SO ON.
INSTEAD OF HITTING YOU AND THE
REST OF THE CITIZENS WITH 1000
VOICES SPEAKING WITH ONE VOICE,
I THINK WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL.
THERE ARE ALSO OBVIOUSLY
PRIORITY SETTING QUESTIONS.
THAT'S VERY MUCH YOUR BUSINESS,
BUT IT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING
WHERE WE COULD THRASH OUT SOME
OF THOSE ISSUES. WE HAVE SEEN,
FOR EXAMPLE, ON OUR MERCED
CAMPUS, THE ABILITY TO
COLLABORATE ON HOUSING THEIR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN THE AREA
AND WE HAVE HOUSING THAT CAN
HELP TAKE CARE OF SOME OF THOSE
STUDENTS. WHEREVER YOU'VE GOT. A
SCARCE RESOURCE IS EXPENSIVE TO
PRODUCE. THAT LEVEL OF
COORDINATION CAN BE VERY HELPFUL
AND WHEN IT'S A PHYSICAL
FACILITY IS REALLY QUITE COSTLY.
UM MY SENSE OF CAUTION IS MERELY
TO ADVOCATE FOR STARTING WITH
THE THINGS WE ALL CAN AGREE OR
CRITICAL. THE DATA NEEDS ARE
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL. THESE
CAPITAL NEEDS ARE CRITICAL AND
THEN PROCEED WITH CAUTION SO
THAT WE DON'T INVENT A BIG,
POWERFUL BUREAUCRACY. THAT IN A
SENSE, SUBLIMATE WHAT I THINK
HAS ALREADY BEEN A VERY
EFFECTIVE SENSE OF COORDINATION
AMONGST US. IF I MAY ADD TO THAT
. I ECHO UM PROVINCE. NEWMAN'S
FEEDBACK AND I THINK THE REALITY
IS THERE ARE GREAT EXAMPLES OF
INDIVIDUAL INSTITUTIONS WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY ON SOME
FACILITIES. I THINK THE STUDENT
HOUSING AND EVEN FACULTY AND
STAFF HOUSING GIVEN ARE GIVEN
THE SORT OF REALITY AND
AFFORDABILITY IN THE STATE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT RIGHT NOW
HAVE TO BE NEGOTIATED AND
NAVIGATED BY WONDER ONE ENTITIES
, AND THEY'RE OFTEN CHALLENGING
THOR. ANY TOPICS TO GET THROUGH,
BASED ON HOW A BOND MIGHT HAVE
ORIGINALLY BEEN WRITTEN. IF IT'S
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT,
AND SO WE HAVE POCKETS OF
SUCCESS, COMPTON COLLEGE AND HE
ISSUED DOMINGUEZ HILLS. CSU
NORTHRIDGE WAS SOME OF THE
VALLEY COMMUNITY COLLEGES. YOU
MENTIONED èC MERCED AND SOME OF
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES, BUT THEY
ARE HAVING TO INDIVIDUALLY
NAVIGATE THAT, WHEREAS AGAIN, A
BROADER, UH, CONTEXT OR ENTITY
TO HELP NAVIGATE THAT AND
SIMPLIFY, I THINK WOULD BE
WELCOME BECAUSE I WAS AT A
MEETING OF OUR FIVE L, A BASIN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND THE L. A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT ALL
COLLEGES. THIS WAS ONE OF THE
TOP ISSUES THAT AROSE THE
ABILITY TO SHARE FACILITIES, BUT
RIGHT NOW NOW IT IS LITERALLY
INDIVIDUAL INSTITUTION WORKING
WITH INDIVIDUAL INSTITUTION AND
NAVIGATING ALL THE COMPLEXITIES
OF BEING UP. YOU KNOW, BE IT A
BOND TO BE AT THE ORIGINAL
FUNDING MECHANISM, WHATEVER AND
HAVING TO NAVIGATE THAT
INDIVIDUALLY. A MORE COORDINATED
EFFORT, I THINK WOULD OPEN THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES UP ACROSS THE
STATE. I JUST WANTED TO ADD A
SECOND WHAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
SHARED. WE ALSO HAVE A NUMBER OF
PARTNERSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND I CCU INSTITUTIONS
IN TERMS OF HOUSING AND
FACILITIES AS WELL. JUST WANTED
TO ADD A PROVINCE. NEWMAN IS NOT
ALONE IN HER CAUTION, RIGHT? I
THINK WE SUPPORT THE IDEA. WE
CAN SEE THE POTENTIAL BENEFITS,
BUT WE WOULD SHARE THE CAUTION
THAT IT'S CAREFULLY DESIGNED.
THAT IT IS NOT DESIGNED WITHOUT
THE VOICE AND INFLUENCE OF THE
SEGMENT. IT'S GOING TO ACTUALLY
IMPACT BECAUSE SOMETHING OF THIS
TYPE COULD BE IMMENSELY HELPFUL.
AND IF NOT DESIGN WILL, IT COULD
BE IMMENSELY DETRIMENTAL, SO I
THINK WE SHARE THE CAUTION AS
WELL. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ANY FURTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS? THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ROBUST PANEL REALLY APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR ALL THE
DIFFERENT INSIGHTS TO MY
COLLEAGUES AS WELL AND REALLY
THE NEED FOR DATA FOR RESEARCH
FOR POLICY EVALUATIONS, AND I
THINK THE COMMENTS HAVE BEEN A
REALLY VALUABLE HERE TODAY. SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT TIME, I
WOULD LIKE TO PASS IT BACK TO
CHAIR NEWMAN TO INTRODUCE OUR
FINAL PANEL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU TO THE PANELISTS
TO APPRECIATE LET ME NOW WELCOME
OUR FINAL PANEL IN THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE ACADEMIC
SENATES OF EACH OF THE THREE
HIGHER EDUCATIONAL TEARS IN
CALIFORNIA. UM COME ON UP. WE
WILL HAVE VIRGINIA MAY BETH
STEPHAN JAMES STAIN TRIGGER. AND
. AGAIN WELCOME AND MISS. MAY
YOU MAY PROCEED. AUTOMATICALLY
TURNS ON NO IT FOR A WHILE, SO
THANK YOU. CHAIR NEWMAN, CHAIR
FONG SENATORS AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S I, TOO AM A
PRODUCT OF THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION SYSTEM. I WENT HERE K
THROUGH 12 COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
CSUN èC. SO NOW I'M IN THE
SYSTEM SO SUCCESSES FOLLOWING
THE PASSAGE OF SENATE BILL 14
52,004, WHICH SOUGHT TO IMPROVE
STUDENT OUTCOMES THROUGH THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A COMMON COURSE
NUMBERING SYSTEM. THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ACADEMIC SENATE LED THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE SID COURSE
IDENTIFICATION NUMBERING SYSTEM
TO IDENTIFY LIKE COURSES.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND CSU
FACULTY HAVE WORKED TOGETHER
ESTABLISHING DESCRIPTORS AND
PROCESSES. NEXT CAME SENATE BILL
1444 40, WHICH ESTABLISHED THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE TRANSFER
MODEL CURRICULA OR ASSOCIATE
DEGREES FOR TRANSFER. AGAIN THE
ACADEMIC SENATE LEAD THIS WORK,
CREATING TRANSFER MODEL
CURRICULA FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TO DEVELOP THE ASSOCIATE DEGREES
FOR TRANSFER AND FOR CSU
CAMPUSES TO DETERMINE WHICH
BACCALAUREATE DEGREES ARE
SIMILAR FOR A TRANSFER
GUARANTEE. TODAY THERE ARE 40
ESTABLISHED TRANSFER MODEL
CURRICULA ANOTHER SIX OR COMING
THROUGH THE VETTING PROCESS WITH
TWO. IN THE CONCEPT PHASE, THERE
IS MUCH MORE TRANSFER MODEL
CURRICULA AND SUCH MUCH MORE
THAN TRANSFER MODEL CURRICULA,
SUCH AS MODEL CURRICULA
DEVELOPED FOR TWO YEAR WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS, BUT WE CAN SAVE THAT
FOR ANOTHER TIME. RECOGNIZING
THE NEED TO PROVIDE CLEAR
PATHWAYS AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EQUITABLE STUDENT OUTCOMES. THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ACADEMIC
SENATE STARTED THE FIRST PHASE
OF ADDRESSING ONE OF THEIR 2017
RESOLUTIONS, ALIGNING TRANSFER
PATHWAYS FOR CSU AND UC SYSTEMS
IN 2020, THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ACADEMIC SENATE INITIATED THE
TRANSFER ALIGNMENT PROJECT.
TRANSFER MODEL CURRICULA AND èC
TRANSFER PATHWAYS AND POLITICAL
SCIENCE AND SOCIOLOGY WERE
EASILY ALIGNED. HOWEVER THERE
WAS STILL MUCH WORK TO DO. THE
CSU AND UC ACADEMIC SENATES HAVE
JOINED EFFORTS WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ACADEMIC
SENATE IN THIS PROJECT TO ALIGN
TRANSFER MODEL CURRICULA AND èC
TRANSFER PATHWAYS WHERE FEASIBLE
AND VALUABLE TO STUDENTS. WE'RE
ALIGNMENT IS NOT FEASIBLE, CLEAR
JUSTIFICATION REGARDING THE
VALUE AND BENEFIT TO STUDENTS OF
THOSE DIFFERENT PATHWAYS WILL BE
DOCUMENTED AND COMMUNICATED FOR
STUDENTS, STAFF AND THE COLLEGE
COMMUNITY. CURRENTLY 10 TRANSFER
MODEL CURRICULA OR UNDER REVIEW
FOR ALIGNMENT, INCLUDING SEVEN
STEM DISCIPLINES. THROUGH
DECEMBER 2023, THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ACADEMIC SENATE,
FACILITATED THIS WORK THROUGH
OUR SID STRUCTURE WITH NO
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. I HAVE
SOME GOOD NEWS. JUST THIS
SPRING, THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE CAME UP WITH
SOME FUNDING TO HELP FACILITATE
THIS WORK. WE DID ASK FOR, UM,
SUPPORT FROM THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND REQUEST PROCESS IN
2324 THROUGH THAT PROCESS, BUT
IT DIDN'T MAKE IT THROUGH THE
STATE BUDGET PROCESS. SO HERE
ARE SOME CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE
FACING, AND YOU'VE HEARD IT FROM
THE OTHER PRESENTERS AS WELL.
THERE ARE 23 CSU CAMPUSES, NINE
U. C CAMPUSES AND NUMEROUS
INDEPENDENT TRANSFER
INSTITUTIONS WITH 115 ASSOCIATE
DEGREE GRANTING COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. TO ESTABLISH TRANSFER
AND COURSE ARTICULATION
AGREEMENTS FOR GENERAL EDUCATION
AND MAJORS PREPARATION. NOT ALL
INSTITUTIONS CAN OFFER ALL
DEGREES AND COURSES. TWO MAJOR
CHALLENGES THE FIRST THERE ARE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. NEW
BARRIERS TO TRANSFER ASSOCIATE
DEGREE ATTAINMENT. FOR EXAMPLE,
THE ECONOMICS TRANSFER MODEL
CURRICULUM, THE FRAMEWORK FOR
THE ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR
TRANSFER HAS A MINIMUM CALCULUS
REQUIREMENT OF ONE SEMESTER OF
BUSINESS CALCULUS, WHEREAS THE
EXPECTED COURSE COMPLETION FOR
THE MAJOR REQUIREMENT IN THE èC
TRANSFER PATHWAY IS A FULL YEAR
OF ENGINEERING CALCULUS
TRANSFERRED TO CSU, WITH A FULL
YEAR OF ENGINEERING CALCULUS
WILL CERTAINLY PREPARE STUDENTS
TO DO WELL AND CSU WILL TAKE
THOSE STUDENTS. IT IS MORE THAN
WHAT IS REQUIRED. THUS ALIGNING
THE TWO PATHWAYS WOULD RAISE THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR STUDENTS
TRANSFERRING TO CSU
UNINTENTIONALLY CREATING A
BARRIER TO TRANSFER AN ASSOCIATE
DEGREE ATTAINMENT. SECOND
COORDINATION. WE'VE BEEN TALKING
A LOT ABOUT THAT TODAY.
COORDINATION OF A LARGE NUMBER
OF INSTITUTIONS FOR TRANSFER AND
ARTICULATION, DISCUSSIONS AND
AGREEMENTS REQUIRES ADDITIONAL
STAFFING, WHICH REQUIRES
RESOURCES. WE HAVE A WHOLE
PROCESS RIGHT NOW SET UP WITH
JUST THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
THE CSU. WHEN WE BRING IN OUR
èC PARTNERS ARE INDEPENDENT
INSTITUTION PARTNERS IS
EXPONENTIAL WITH THE
COORDINATION NEEDED TO GET THIS
WORK DONE WELL. SO HERE ARE SOME
STRATEGIES FOR ENHANCING
COORDINATION. FULLY RESOURCE
EXISTING STRUCTURES SO FULLY
RESOURCED THAT INTER SEGMENTAL
COURSE ARTICULATION AND PATHWAYS
DEVELOPMENT MINT INFRASTRUCTURE,
AS RECOMMENDED BY THE 928
COMMITTEE. CLARIFY THE ROLES AND
PROCESSES AND MISSIONS OF EACH
SEGMENT, IDENTIFY OPPORTUNITIES
AND CHALLENGES BASED BY EACH
SEGMENT WHILE ENSURING EQUITABLE
STUDENT OUTCOMES RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANT ROLE FACULTY PLAY. IN
THE EDUCATION PROCESS. THEY
WORKED CLOSEST WITH STUDENTS.
THEY UNDERSTAND THE DETAILS OF
THE PROGRAMS AND COURSEWORK THEY
CARE ABOUT STUDENT SUCCESS AND
THEN FINALLY KEEP THE
EDUCATIONAL PRACTITIONERS FRONT
AND CENTER IN ALL THE
COORDINATION, EFFORTS AND
DECISIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT BETH STEPFORD, CHAIR OF THE
ACADEMIC CENTER, THE KELP.
EXCUSE ME, CAVALRY SPEAKING
BRAZILIAN AND SHARE OF THE INTER
SEGMENTAL COMMITTEE ON THE
ACADEMIC SENTENCE. WELCOME.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME TO SPEAK. TODAY CSU
FACULTY CARED DEEPLY ABOUT
STUDENT SUCCESS, IN FACT,
UNQUESTIONABLY A PRIMARY
MOTIVATOR FOR FACULTY WORKING IN
THE CSU IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CREATIVELY AND EFFECTIVELY TEACH
STUDENTS AND ENSURE THEIR
SUCCESS. POST GRADUATION. CSU
FACULTY KNOW THEIR STUDENTS WELL
AND ARE EXPERTS ON STUDENT
SUCCESS IN THE CLASSROOM. TO
ENSURE THAT THE COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES OF CALIFORNIA MEET
CURRENT AND FUTURE STUDENT NEEDS
AND DEMANDS. IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THE THREE SEGMENTS TO
COLLABORATE, ESPECIALLY ON
TRANSFER PROCESSES, WHILE ALSO
WORKING TO SHOWCASE THE UNIQUE
STRENGTHS TO EFFECTIVELY ATTRACT
STUDENTS AND SERVE. THEIR
DISTINCT STUDENT POPULATIONS AS
A PROCESS FOR DEVELOPING CAL GET
SEE A SINGULAR PATHWAY AND
STANDARDS FOR TRANSFER FROM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO BOTH THE
UC AND CSU HAVE SHOWN THROUGH
THE INTER SEGMENTAL COMMITTEE OF
ACADEMIC SENTENCE, WHICH I
CURRENTLY CHAIR AND MY COLLEAGUE
CHAIRED LAST YEAR. FACULTY IN
THE THREE SEGMENTS, SEGMENTS OF
PRO PROVEN THAT THEY CAN WORK
TOGETHER PRODUCTIVELY IN A
TIMELY WAY ON COMMON GOALS TO
ENHANCE STUDENT TRANSFER IN
PROGRESS TOWARDS A BACCALAUREATE
DEGREE. HOWEVER ONE THING THAT
WOULD AID IN THIS TRANSFER IS
FOR THE STATE TO HAVE A UNIFIED
WAY TO HANDLE AND COMMUNICATE.
TRANSCRIPTS BETWEEN SYSTEMS.
CURRENTLY TRANSFERRED COURSES
OFTEN HAVE TO BE MANUALLY
ENTERED FROM. PDF SO STUDENT
TRANSCRIPTS SOMETIMES MULTIPLE
TIMES, INTRODUCING BOTH DELAYS
IN PROCESSING AND THE
POSSIBILITY FOR ERRORS, HAVING
AN INTEGRATED SYSTEM TO PROCESS
TRANSCRIPTS WOULD EASE AND
DEMYSTIFY TRANSFER CSU FACULTY
OFTEN OBSERVE THE CHALLENGES AND
STUDENT TRANSFER AND THEIR
ROLES, ACADEMIC ADVISORS AND
MENTORS WHO WORK CLOSELY WITH
STUDENTS TO HELP PLAN THEIR
PROGRESS 2 DEGREES AND BEYOND.
IT'S NOT UNUSUAL FOR A FACULTY
MEMBER REVIEWING THE TRANSCRIPTS
OF A STUDENT WHO TRANSFERRED
INTO THE CSU TO SEE MULTIPLE
ISSUES THAT WILL PREVENT A
STUDENT FROM GRADUATING WITHIN
FOUR YEARS. FOR EXAMPLE,
STUDENTS MIGHT SPEND MORE THAN
TWO YEARS AT A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE, OFTEN ATTENDING
MULTIPLE DIFFERENT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES EARNING UNITS THAT A
CSU REGISTRAR'S OFFICE CAN'T
TRANSFER. TO A BACCALAUREATE
DEGREE BECAUSE ONLY A MAXIMUM OF
70 UNITS CAN BE TRANSFERRED FROM
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO CSU,
EXPANDING DUAL ENROLLMENT OF
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS A PROMISING
WAY TO ENGAGE STUDENTS IN POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION, BUT THESE
STUDENTS MUST BE PROVIDED WITH
MEANINGFUL ADVISING SO THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND HOW THESE COURSES
WILL IMPACT SUCCESSFUL
COMPLETION OF BACCALAUREATE
DEGREES. FOR EXAMPLE, WE FIND
THAT MANY TIMES THESE STUDENTS
DON'T KNOW THEIR GRADES AND
THEIR DUAL ENROLLMENT COURSES
WILL BE INCLUDED. DID. IN THEIR
COLLEGE TRANSCRIPTS AND AFFECT
THEIR COLLEGE GPA, WHICH THEN
AFFECTS THEIR ADMISSIONS
OPPORTUNITIES. STRONG ONE ON ONE
ADVISING, WHICH IS EXPENSIVE,
AND WE'VE TALKED A LOT ABOUT
RESOURCES, BUT STRONG ONE ON ONE
ADVISING AND RESOURCES SUCH AS A
SISTER OR THE OFFICIAL COURSE,
TRANSFER AND ARTICULATION SYSTEM
FOR CALIFORNIA PUBLIC COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES HELP STUDENTS
TO MINIMIZE UNITS. THEY CANNOT
BE USED TOWARDS THEIR FOUR YEAR
DEGREE. SEVERAL CSU'S ARE
BUILDING TWO PLUS TWO DEGREES IN
FIELDS SUCH AS NURSING IN HIGH
DEMAND AREAS IN THE STATE
STUDENTS IN THESE PROGRAMS TAKE
TWO YEARS OF COURSES AT A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND THEN UPON
COMPLETION OF THIS COURSE, IS
TRANSFERRED TO THE LOCAL CSU TO
FINISH THEIR DEGREE IN A PATHWAY
THAT IS PRE PLANNED TO MAXIMIZE
THEIR ABILITY TO GRADUATE WITHIN
FOUR YEARS AND ENTER THEIR
CHOSEN FIELD. SERIOUSLY FACULTY
ALSO OBSERVED THAT A MAJOR
BARRIER FOR STUDENTS ATTAINING
THEIR FOUR YEAR DEGREES COST OF
ATTENDANCE STUDENTS BASING THEIR
CHOICE OF INSTITUTION AND THEIR
STATUS IS FULL TIME OR PART TIME
ON LIVING COSTS. FOR EXAMPLE,
STUDENTS MIGHT CHOOSE A LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OVER A FARTHER
AWAY CSU BECAUSE THEY CAN LIVE
AT HOME AND SAVE ON RENT, FOOD
AND TRANSPORTATION COSTS.
WHETHER OR NOT THEY LIVE AT HOME
, THEY STILL MIGHT ENGAGE IN 30
TO 40 HOURS A WEEK OF PAID WORK
TO COVER COSTS WHILE ATTEMPTING
TO FINISH THEIR DEGREE. WHICH
OFTEN HAS AN IMPACT ON THEIR
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE, SUCH AS
HAVING TO REPEAT COURSES, THEY
COULD NOT SUCCESSFULLY TEND TO
THE FIRST TIME. SO TO ALLOW
STUDENTS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
FOCUS ON THEIR STUDIES AND
PROGRESS TO THEIR DEGREES. WE
SUPPORT THE STATE FUNDING CAL
GRANTS TO COVER THE COST OF
ATTENDANCE BEYOND JUST TUITION
AND IN CLOSING. THESE ARE
HIGHLIGHTS OF THE COMPLICATED
PROBLEMS WE HAVE TO SOLVE, BUT
FACULTY ARE WILLING PARTNERS AND
LEADERS WITH A DEMONSTRATED
HISTORY OF SUCCESS. RECENT
SUCCESS. AS WELL AS SUSTAINED
SUCCESS, ENGAGING EVERY DAY AND
HELPING STUDENTS LEARN EARN
THEIR DEGREES AND ACHIEVE THEIR
DREAMS AND LONG TERM SUCCESS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT. WELCOME TO MR JAMES STEIN
TRIGGER CHAIR OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA ACADEMIC SENATE.
EXCUSE ME. THANK YOU. CHEERS
NEWMAN AND FONG AND THOSE WHO
REMAIN HAVE A SCRIPT.
APPARENTLY, I'M LOSING MY VOICE
TO HAVE A SCRIPT. BUT I JUST
WANT TO MENTION SOMETHING OFF
SCRIPT BEFORE I BEFORE I GET TO
THIS EARLIER IT WAS MENTIONED OR
SUGGESTED THAT THE MAIN POINTS
OF CONTACT BETWEEN THE THREE
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS
IS REALLY AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS.
PRESIDENT WHATEVER. UM UH, I
HOPE AND I THINK THAT THAT KIND
OF CONTACT TAKES PLACE BUT
CONTACT BETWEEN THE THREE
ACADEMIC SENATE ABSOLUTELY TAKES
PLACE AND A LOT OF COORDINATION
TAKES PLACE THROUGH THE ACADEMIC
SENTENCE, TOO. AND I'M LOOKING
AT MY COUNTERPARTS HERE BECAUSE
WE KNOW EACH OTHER THROUGH THE
INTER SEGMENTAL WORK THAT WE DO.
WE WERE ON ZOOM CALLS. YESTERDAY
THE WEEK BEFORE, AND AN
INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF
COORDINATION ALREADY TAKES PLACE
TO THE ACADEMIC SENATE WORTH
FACULTY CAN PROVIDE THEIR INPUT
ON MATTERS OF CURRICULA AND
TRANSFER AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE. WITH THAT I WILL GO TO
MY SCRIPT AND I'LL TRY TO CUT
OUT SOME TRUNKS BECAUSE I THINK
WE'RE OVER TIME. UM POLICY
MAKING IN THE CURRENT TRANSFER
CONTEXT IS BOTH A CHALLENGE AND
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE A
COHERENT LONG TERM PLAN THAT
WILL STRENGTHEN THE STUDENT
TRANSFER PIPELINE IN CALIFORNIA.
IN WHAT FOLLOWS I WILL HIGHLIGHT
BOTH èC AND INTER SEGMENTAL
POLICY INITIATIVES AND THEY'RE
EVOLVING NATURE AS WE WORK
TOGETHER TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
PERSPECTIVE TRANSFERS. ACADEMIC
PREPARATION IS THE FOUNDATION OF
FUTURE ACADEMIC CESS SUCCESS IN
COLLEGE. THIS IS WHY IT IS
CENTRAL TO THE TRANSFER POLICY
MAKING EFFORTS IN EACH OF THE
STATES. HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEMS. WE MUST ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS NOT ONLY CAN TRANSFER
BUT ALSO THAT THEY WILL THRIVE
AFTER TRANSFER. ARTICULATION IS
THE PRACTICE OF ALIGNING
CURRICULUM ACROSS EDUCATION
SEGMENTS TO SUPPORT STUDENTS IN
THEIR TRANSITION FROM ONE
SEGMENT TO ANOTHER. THROUGH THE
TRANSFER ARTICULATION PROCESS.
èC WORKS WITH CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO DETERMINE
THE TRANSFERABILITY OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE COURSEWORK TO OUR
CAMPUSES. AFTER COURSE,
TRANSFERABILITY IS ESTABLISHED
BASED ON UCS ACADEMIC
PREPARATION POLICY, WHICH IS SET
BY THE FACULTY SPECIFIC
ARTICULATION AGREEMENTS ARE
IMPLEMENTED TO CONFIRM WHAT
COURSES COUNT FOR MAJOR BREADTH
AND OTHER GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS. THIS IS HOW WE
OUTLINED A CLEAR PATH FOR
TRANSFER STUDENTS TO ATTAIN A
BACCALAUREATE DEGREE. GIVEN THE
ROLE FACULTY PLAY AND SHARED
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURES THAT
UPHOLD THE ACADEMIC MISSION OF
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS.
POLICIES FOR ACADEMIC
REQUIREMENTS RELY ON FACULTY
EXPERTISE TO DETERMINE
APPROPRIATE POLICY CRITERIA. IN
THE CASE OF èC TRANSFERABLE
TRANSFERABLE COURSE AGREEMENTS
IDENTIFY èC TRANSFERABLE
COURSES FOR EACH COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. THESE AGREEMENTS ARE
UPDATED ANNUALLY SO THEY CAN
ACCURATELY ACCURATELY REFLECT
THE MOST CURRENT CURRICULUM. AND
IT'S CRUCIAL TO MAINTAIN CLEAR
POLICY TO MANAGE THESE DYNAMIC
COMPONENTS OF TRANSFER
ARTICULATION. NOT LONG AFTER THE
ASSOCIATE DEGREES FOR TRANSFER,
A TTS WERE DEVELOPED FOR
TRANSFER TO CSU èC LAUNCHED AN
INITIATIVE TO IDENTIFY A COMMON
SET OF LOWER DIVISION COURSES AS
APPROPRIATE PREPARATION FOR 20
OF THE MOST SOUGHT AFTER MAJORS
AMONG TRANSFER APPLICANTS TO èC
BèC TRANSFER PATH YOU SEE
TRANSFER PATHWAYS WERE CREATED
IN 20 1500 JOINT LEADERSHIP OF
THE ACADEMIC SENATE. AND THE UC
SYSTEM LIKE PROVOST AND IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE èC
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT AND THE
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. EACH TRANSFER PATHWAY
IDENTIFIED A SINGLE SET OF
COURSES FOR A GIVEN MAJOR, THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS CAN
TAKE TO TRANSFER ANY èC CAMPUS.
THIS UNPRECEDENTED ACHIEVEMENT
CAME FROM A SHARED COMMITMENT TO
ENSURE STUDENTS ARE WELL
PREPARED AND SUPPORTED IN THEIR
TRANSFER CHEN JOURNEY AS
INTEREST IN 80 èC TRANSFER
PATHWAYS HAS GROWN OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS, SIGNIFICANT WORK
ON TRANSFER POLICY HAS BEEN
UNDERTAKEN BY THE FACULTY SENATE
OF THE THREE PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEMS, AS WELL AS BY
KISS THE INTER SEGMENTAL
COMMITTEE OF THE ACADEMIC
SENATES. YOU SEE THE CSU AND SEE
CCS HAVE LONG WORKED TOGETHER TO
PROVIDE ACCESS AND OPPORTUNITY
FOR STUDENTS SEEKING TO TRANSFER
A KEY EXAMPLE OF SUCH AS THE
INTER SEGMENTAL GENERAL
EDUCATION TRANSFER PATHWAY
CURRICULUM. I GET THAT THE THREE
SEGMENTS HAVE HAD IN PLACE SINCE
1988. ASSEMBLY BUILT 19 9 28
BECAME LAW IN 2021 AND SOUGHT TO
PRODUCE A NEW COMMON LOWER
DIVISION GENERAL EDUCATION.
PATHWAY FOR C C C. STUDENTS
TRANSFERRING TO UC AND CSU. THIS
NEW PATHWAY KNOWN AS CALLE, GET
SEE. THE LEGISLATION ALSO
ESTABLISHED IMPLEMENTATION. THE
IMPLEMENTATION COMMITTEE THAT
HAS OVERLAPPING RESPONSIBILITIES
WITH WHAT I OVERSEAS. THIS NEW
LAW PRIORITIZES ALIGNMENT OF
TRANSFER REQUIREMENTS WITH THE
STRUCTURE OF ACTS, WHICH
ORIGINATED AS DEGREE PROGRAMS
DESIGNED FOR ACADEMIC
PREPARATION AND TRANSFER TO THE
CS. YOU ALTHOUGH THERE ARE MANY
SIMILARITIES BETWEEN UC AND CSU
UNDERGRADUATE PROGRAMS,
IMPORTANT DIFFERENCES DO EXIST.
THESE DIFFERENCES REFLECT THE
RICHNESS OF EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES AVAILABLE TO
TRANSFER STUDENTS AND SHOULD NOT
BE IGNORED, AND THIS IS PARTLY
CAPTURED IN ASSEMBLY BILL OUT.
1291 SIGNED INTO LAW JUST LAST
YEAR, WHICH WAS A UNIQUE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN èC AND
STATE LEADERS TO LAUNCH A NEW AD
PILOT PROGRAM AT LA IN WHICH
PREFACED MENTIONED EARLIER.
WE'VE SEEN SUCCESS OVER THE
DECADES RANGING FROM èC
SPECIFIC EFFORTS TOO MUCH
BROADER COOPERATIVE EFFORTS
INVOLVING ALL THE VARIOUS BODIES
REPRESENTED IN THIS ROOM.
BECAUSE THE STATE'S PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
ARE CRITICAL AVENUES OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL STUDENTS TO
MEET THEIR EDUCATIONAL GOALS. IT
IS IMPERATIVE THAT YOU SEE,
COLLABORATE AND COORDINATE WITH
THE C S. U C. C C SYSTEMS TO
ADDRESS HOW THE TRANSFER PROCESS
COULD BE FURTHER ENHANCED. WE
AIM TO DO THIS THROUGH
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT CYCLES
AND INTEREST SEGMENTAL POLICY
MAKING AMONG THE FACULTY
SENATE'S AND WE WELCOME SUPPORT
FROM THE LEGISLATURE AND STATE
LEADERS TO ENSURE ADEQUATE
RESOURCES TO HELP US TACKLE THE
CHALLENGES AHEAD. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR STRANGER. THANK
YOU TO EACH OF THE PANELS. LET
ME START THE QUESTIONS. LET ME
ASK THE SAME QUESTION. I'VE
ASKED OF OTHER PANELISTS. DO YOU
ALL AGREE THAT A CENTRAL
COORDINATING BODY WOULD BE
USEFUL AND IS NECESSARY? AND IF
SO, WHAT ROLE SHOULD ACADEMIC
SENATES PLAY WITHIN IT? I HAVE A
THOUGHT OR TWO. IF YOU GO WELL,
SO YOU KNOW, I UM, DUPLICATION
HAS BEEN ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT'S BEEN BROUGHT UP A NUMBER
OF TIMES. AND I THINK THAT 11
THING THAT A COORDINATING GROUP
MIGHT BE ABLE TO ADDRESS WOULD
BE A DUPLICATION OR THE PROBLEMS
OF DUPLICATION COORDINATION
ACROSS THE ACROSS THE SEGMENT,
SO I THINK THAT MIGHT BE USEFUL
FUNCTION FOR SUCH A GROUP. UM I
DO WORRY IN THE IN THE TRANSFER
AREA IN WHICH I HAVE
CONCENTRATED MY COMMENTS THAT
THAT EFFORTS TO KIND OF
COORDINATE FROM ABOVE MIGHT HAVE
UNINTENDED, UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES, AND WE'VE ACTUALLY
SEEN SOME OF THOSE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES ON ALREADY AND, UM
SO TRYING TO ALIGN A TTS WITH
PARENTS FOR PATHWAYS IF IT'S IF
IT'S DONE, UM AH. TO FORCEFULLY
STUDENTS ARE GOING TO LOSE OUT
AND THAT WOULD BE A DANGER OF
THAT KIND OF COORDINATION FROM
THE TOP. IN WHAT WAY WITH
STUDENTS LOSE OUT. WELL I MEAN,
THIS WAS ONE OF THIS WAS
MENTIONED RIGHT? SO ALIGNMENT
MIGHT MEAN. UH. RAISING THE
BUTTON? YES. BUT WHAT SHE'S NOT
GOING TO PASS THE BATON. VERY
GOOD. WHAT WELL DONE. SO IT'S
ALIGNMENT OR FEASIBLE, SO I
MENTIONED THE ECONOMICS TRANSFER
MODEL CURRICULUM AND èC
TRANSFER PATHWAYS TO ALIGN THOSE
TWO DEGREES, SO THAT STUDENTS
REGARDLESS OF THE DEGREE THEY
GOT, THEY WOULD BE QUALIFIED OR
PREPARED FOR TRANSFER TO BOTH
THE CSU AND UC SYSTEM. THEY
WOULD HAVE TO UP THE CALCULUS
REQUIREMENTS FOR THOSE STUDENTS
THAT ARE INTERESTED IN
TRANSFERRING TO CSU. CSU DOESN'T
HAVE THE SAME CALCULUS
REQUIREMENTS THAT YOU SEE DOES
AND SO THAT COULD CREATE AN
UNINTENDED BARRIER FOR STUDENTS
THAT ARE ALREADY EARNING THESE
ECONOMIC DEGREES OF VERY
VALUABLE DEGREE FOR STUDENTS.
THEY'RE EARNING THESE DEGREES.
THEY'RE TRANSFERRING TO CSU
GETTING A DEGREE IN ECONOMICS,
GETTING OUT INTO THE WORKFORCE
AND LANDING FABULOUS JOBS. YEP
THOSE PATHWAYS WERE ALIGNED AND
STUDENTS HAD TO TAKE THE
ADDITIONAL COURSES FOR CALCULUS
THAT COULD PUT A BARRIER WHERE
STUDENTS MIGHT NOT EARN THOSE
DEGREES ANYMORE THAT ARE
CURRENTLY VERY VALUABLE TO
STUDENTS. AND SO, BUT THERE ARE
OTHER PATHWAYS THAT ALIGN
BEAUTIFULLY AND WE'RE IN THE
PROCESS OF WORKING ON SOME OF
THOSE 22 I MENTIONED ALREADY
ALIGNED BEAUTIFULLY. SO IF WE
HAD A COORDINATING BODY LIKE DR
LO MENTIONED, UM YOU KNOW, WITH
THE 8928 COMMITTEE. I AM THE
SOLE FACULTY VOICE FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES ON
THERE. AND LIKE SHE MENTIONED,
OF COURSE, I LIKE HAVING MY
OPINION SHARED. BUT THERE ARE
MANY MORE FACULTY. THERE ARE
WHAT 56 57,000 COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY IN THIS IN OUR SYSTEM
FULL TIME, PART TIME. AND WE
NEED MORE VOICES. WE NEED THOSE
EXPERTS IN THE ROOM TO KEEP US
FROM FROM COMING UP WITH
UNINTENTIONAL UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES IN THE WORK WE'RE
DOING TO SERVE STUDENTS SO THAT
THEY HAVE VALUABLE PROGRAMS
MOVING THROUGH THE SYSTEM. MR
FAULT. AND I WOULD JUST ECHO
WHAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID
THAT IF YOU HAVE A UNIFIED
PATHWAY THAT THERE IS AN
ADVANTAGE IN THAT, AND THAT YOU
HAVE, YOU KNOW THERE IS ONE
THING, BUT IT NECESSARILY WILL
LEVEL AT THE HIGHEST SET OF
STANDARDS, WHICH THEN YOU KNOW,
POTENTIALLY CREATES ADDITIONAL
BARRIERS TO TRANSFER THAT WE
DIDN'T INTEND AND ALSO TO WITH
THE COORDINATING BODY, YOU KNOW.
I WOULD. I WOULD ECHO THAT WE
THE DUPLICATION CONCERNS WHICH
WE'VE HAD BETWEEN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND THE CSU SO FAR, BUT
MAY HAPPEN BETWEEN THE èC AND
THE WOODS YET, YOU KNOW THAT
SORT OF YET TO HAPPEN, BUT YOU
KNOW, IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE DEFINITELY HAD
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT. THAT, YOU
KNOW, THINKING ABOUT HOW THAT
WOULD BE CONSTITUTED IS SORT OF
THE QUESTION LIKE HOW A BODY
WOULD BE CONSTITUTED, SORT OF
WHO WOULD BE ON THAT. I THINK
OUR SENSES IT WOULD BE A NEUTRAL
BODY, BUT I THINK NEUTRALITY IS
OFTEN DIFFICULT TO ACTUALLY, YOU
KNOW, ESTABLISHED AND PRACTICE
AND SO AND SO I'LL SAY WITH THE
MOST RECENT LEGISLATION, WHICH I
KNOW FOR A LOT OF OUR TIMES,
THIS CHAIR TOOK UP A LOT OF THE
SPACE AND MAYBE MAYBE MADE US
EVEN MORE CLOSELY BONDED. THEN
WE WOULD HAVE BEEN OTHERWISE AND
WORKING ON A B 928. BUT THERE'S
SORT OF TWO THINGS ON THAT. THAT
I DON'T THINK IT'S NECESSARY IF
YOU HAVEN'T BEEN DEEPLY IN THE
WEEDS THAT WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE
BEEN, UM THERE'S SORT OF TWO
PARTS OF THAT. THAT AREN'T
OBVIOUS. THERE'S SEGMENTAL
COMMITTEE OF ACADEMIC SENATORS.
I CURRENTLY CHAIR WHICH MY
COLLEAGUE JENNY CHAIR LAST YEAR
THAT CREATED THE SINGULAR
TRANSFER PATHWAY. CAL GET SEEMS
SO THAT'S THE THING THAT'S THE
THING THAT WAS, YOU KNOW,
FACULTY DRIVEN THAT WE'VE DONE
THAT'S OUT THERE THAT EXISTS,
AND THEN THERE'S A COORDINATING
BODY, WHICH I ALSO HAVE THE
AWESOME RESPONSIBILITY OF
REPRESENTING ALL OF THE FACULTY
OF THE CSCO ON THAT BODY AS WELL
, BUT THAT IS SORT OF, YOU KNOW,
THERE'S A REPORT THAT WAS SENT
TO THE LEGISLATURE AT THE END OF
DECEMBER AND SORT OF THAT C
OUTPUT SO FAR FROM THE EXISTENCE
OF THAT BODY, AND I THINK
ANOTHER REPORT IS INTENDED TO GO
AT THE END OF THIS YEAR, SO SORT
OF TANGIBLE RESULTS THAT ARE
WILL BE BENEFITING STUDENTS AND
ARE BEING IMPLEMENTED VERSUS UM
YOU KNOW, SORT OF THINKING ABOUT
REPORTS OR THINKING ABOUT POLICY
THAT MAY OR MAY NOT ULTIMATELY
HAPPEN OR BE A GOOD IDEA. LET ME
REFRAME IT. JUST GET. I KNOW THE
AUDIENCE COULD ALSO SEE YOUR
FACES. WHEN I ASKED THE QUESTION
IT WAS. I COULD DESCRIBE
SKEPTICAL SO GOOD IDEA. BAD IDEA
. YOU FOLKS HAVE A VERY
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE AND
REPRESENTING VERY DIFFERENT
CONSTITUENCIES AND THE OTHER
FOLKS WHO HAVE SPOKEN TODAY UM
YOU KNOW HOW URGENT IS THE NEED
FOR A COORDINATING BODY? I THINK
WE NEED TO FULLY RESOURCE. IS
THIS WORKING? YEAH WE REALLY
NEED TO FULLY RESOURCE THE INNER
SEGMENTAL COORDINATION WITH
FACULTY IN ALIGNING OR
CLARIFYING THE TRANSFER PATHWAYS
, NOT JUST THE TRANSFER PATHWAYS
. BUT THE COURSE IS HOW WILL THE
COURSES TRANSFER? BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW IT'S A COLLEGE TO COLLEGE OR
A COLLEGE TO SYSTEM. AH! AND
IT'S VERY COMPLICATED. AND SO IF
WE HAD THE FACULTY AND UM
SENATOR OCHOA BUG WAS HAD
STARTED TALKING ABOUT THIS IF WE
HAVE THE FACULTY WORKING IN
THESE AREAS WE CAN HAVE YOU KNOW
, THE ECONOMICS FACULTY IN A
GROUP COMING UP WITH DECISIONS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS AND HOW THEY
CAN MOVE FORWARD. WE COULD HAVE
MATHEMATICS FACULTY DOING THAT.
BUT WE NEED RESOURCES SO THAT WE
HAVE PEOPLE TO DO THE
COORDINATION TO WRITE THE
DOCUMENTS. TO SEND EVERYTHING
THROUGH THROUGH THE PROPOSAL AND
APPROVAL PROCESS. AND WE NEED
THE FACULTY EXPERTS IN THERE WHO
REALLY UNDERSTAND THE PROGRAMS
WHO UNDERSTAND THE COURSES AND
WE NEED THE SUPPORT FROM OUR
ADMINISTRATIVE COLLEAGUES TO
FINALIZE THIS AND MAKE THESE
AGREEMENTS APPRECIATE THAT ANY
OTHER THOUGHTS. I WAS JUST GONNA
I'LL JUST ECHO RESOURCES. I MEAN
, THE WORK THAT YOU'VE SEEN THE
WORK THAT OF CAL GET C OF, I
GUESS I MEAN, IT'S BEEN DONE
WITH ZERO RESOURCES AND WE YOU
KNOW IS A HERCULEAN EFFORT IN IT
TOOK A LOT OF GOODWILL AND A LOT
OF EFFORT. IN LEAST WE, YOU
KNOW, I DON'T KNOW THAT IT'S YOU
KNOW, IF THAT WERE TO BE THE
MODEL GOING FORWARD, I DON'T
KNOW HOW SUCCESSFUL IT WOULD BE.
YOU KNOW, IT WOULD BE, IT WOULD
BE AN UNSUSTAINABLE EFFORT. I'LL
SAY THAT AND SO WE HAVE
PROCESSES IN EFFECT, AND I'LL
SAY I KISS HAS BEEN AROUND SINCE
I BELIEVE IT'S 1980 BECAUSE IT'S
EXISTED. SINCE THEN WE HAVE THE
TRANSFER ALIGNMENT PROJECT THAT
THAT THAT JENNY REFERENCE THAT
THERE ARE STRUCTURES THAT EXIST
THAT ARE WILDLY UNDER RESOURCED
IN THAT, YOU KNOW, A BIG PART OF
THE REASON WHY THERE HASN'T BEEN
SCALE THAT IF THERE WERE PROPER
RESOURCES PUT TO IT. THAT, YOU
KNOW. STRUCTURES IN PLACE, YOU
KNOW, WOULD BE MORE PRODUCTIVE
IN THE WAY THAT I THINK WE'D ALL
LIKE TO MOVE TO VERSUS THINKING
ABOUT. YOU KNOW, A COORDINATING
COMMITTEE THAT WOULD THEN BE
ANOTHER SET OF RESOURCE DEMANDS
IT WOULD YOU KNOW, I HESITATE TO
SAY THE DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS,
BUT THAT'S REALLY THE YOU KNOW
WHAT IT WOULD ACTUALLY LOOK LIKE
WHAT DETERMINE WHETHER IT WOULD
BE USEFUL AND SUCCESSFUL. IT'S
HARD FOR ME TO ADD TO THAT I
ENDED MY SCRIPTED COMMENTS WITH
RESOURCES SO OBVIOUSLY BELIEVE
THAT THE RESOURCES PART IS
IMPORTANT. I THINK WHAT WE'RE
ALL EMPHASIZING IS THAT SOME OF
THIS IS IT REALLY A BOTTOM UP
PROCESS RATHER THAN USEFULLY TOP
DOWN PROCESS AND AS AN EXAMPLE I
RECENTLY CØNG. ABOUT CO PENNED
WITH THE PROVOST, A LETTER THAT
THE èC SIDE WILL GO OUT TO
DEPARTMENT SHARES ACROSS THE
ENTIRE SYSTEMS IN LARGE NUMBER
OF CHAIRS TO HAVE THEM IDENTIFY
A FACULTY MEMBER WHO IS
KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT HOW THEY'RE
CORRECT. MAJOR CURRICULUM WORKS
SO THEY CAN THEN BE PLUGGED INTO
OUR COORDINATION EFFORTS AROUND
TRANSFERS THAT WE HAVE YOU GET A
SET OF KNOWLEDGEABLE
DISCIPLINARY EXPERTS. THAT WILL
ALL BE, YOU KNOW, BASICALLY
VOLUNTEER WORK, BUT IT'S HOW THE
WORK OUGHT TO GET DONE AS WELL.
RIGHT. REALLY FROM FROM THE
GROUND UP, SO I GUESS WHAT I'M
HEARING IS COORDINATING BUDDY
MIGHT PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES, BUT IT ALSO MIGHT
CREATE SOME CHALLENGES, RIGHT
FRICTION FOR THE FOLKS WHO ARE
ALREADY DOING THIS INTERESTING
MENTAL WORK. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS? SENATOR JOE BUCK. SO
IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE I THINK
WHAT WE'RE HEARING IS FROM OUR
PREVIOUS PANELS IS THAT WE DO
NEED TO HAVE OUR SYSTEMS WORKING
TOGETHER IN ORDER TO PREPARE
STUDENTS WITH REGARDS TO THE
TRANSFERABILITY OF MAJORS
THROUGHOUT IN THE DIFFICULTIES
AND CHALLENGES THAT LIES WITHIN
THOSE SPECIAL, ESPECIALLY WHEN
THERE ARE SERVICES BETWEEN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. THE CSU'S IN
THE UCS AS FAR AS THE EMPHASIS
AND FOCUS ON THE TYPE OF
EDUCATION THAT THEY'RE PROVIDING
AT DIFFERENT LEVELS. BUT WHAT
I'M HEARING IN THIS PARTICULAR
PANEL IS THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE
SYSTEMS THAT COULD ACTUALLY
COORDINATED DO ALL OF THAT IF
THEY WERE FULLY FUNDED TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT, AND IT HAD THE
RESOURCES OF THE FUNDING TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT. SO ON THE
PREVIOUS PANELS, WE HAVE A NEED,
UM, IN THIS PANEL. I HEAR THAT
WE HAVE THE SYSTEMS ALREADY IN
PLACE, BUT THEY JUST NEED TO BE
FULLY FUNDED TO BE ABLE TO DO
THE WORK THAT IS ALREADY BEING
DONE WITH THAT PREVIOUS INTENT
IS THAT IS THAT WHAT I'M HEARING
IS THAT IS THAT CORRECT? PRETTY
MUCH SOON. PRETTY MUCH. I MEAN,
IF THEY'RE FULLY RESOURCED, THEN
WE CAN GET THE PEOPLE THAT NEED
TO BE THERE TO COORDINATE AND
GET THIS WORK DONE INSTEAD OF
JUST PIECEMEAL NG IT HERE AND
THERE. IT'S LIKE, OH, THIS NEEDS
TO BE DONE. WE'LL FIND SOMEBODY
TO HURRY UP AND GET IT DONE, BUT
HAVE THE WHOLE PLAN SET IN
MOTION GOING DIFFERENT PROJECTS
ALL AT THE SAME TIME? I
ABSOLUTELY UNDERSTAND THAT. YEP,
I AGREE. I GET THAT. AND THEN
THE OTHER QUESTION THAT I WANTED
TO ADDRESS WAS BASED ON THE
CHAIRMAN'S AND CHAIRMAN NEWMAN'S
QUESTION. AS FAR AS THE URGENCY
GOES, AND BASED ON MY
CONVERSATIONS THAT I'VE HAD, UM
WITH THE DIFFERENT HEADS OF
DEPARTMENTS AND DIRECTORS FOR
OUR DIFFERENT SYSTEMS IS THAT
THE URGENCY IS ACTUALLY PRETTY
URGENT. AND THE REASON BEING IS
THAT CURRENTLY, UM ALTHOUGH
WE'RE GRADUATING BEING VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN OUR DIFFERENT
SYSTEMS IN GRADUATING PEOPLE
WERE STILL NEEDING NOT MEETING
THE ENTIRE NEED OF THE WORKFORCE
FOR A STATE AND FOR THE NATION
AS A WHOLE BECAUSE THERE'S A
DISCREPANCY BETWEEN THE MAJORS
THAT WE'RE PROVIDING AS A WHOLE
CURRENTLY AND WHAT THE WORKFORCE
AND WHERE WE'RE GOING IN THE
FUTURE, SO THE URGENCY IS THERE.
BECAUSE TECHNOLOGY SCIENCE, THE
WORKFORCE IS DEVELOPING
EXPONENTIALLY, AND SO WE NEED
THE BODY AND THE FORCE AND THE
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO SAY
EXACTLY WHAT IT IS THAT WE
CURRENTLY NEED, WHICH WE HAVE AN
IDEA BASED, BUT WE'RE HEADING IN
THE FUTURE. SO IN MY OPINION,
BASED ON WHAT I'VE HEARD FROM
THE LEADERSHIP AND THE WORKFORCE
DEPARTMENT, BOTH PRIVATE AND
PUBLIC. UM THERE IS AN URGENCY
ON THAT END, SO THAT'S JUST MY
PERSONAL OPINION BASED ON THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT I'VE HAD AND
SEEN, UM AND BASED ON WHAT WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW IS ACTUALLY VERY
ENCOURAGING AS FAR AS OUR
POTENTIAL TO BE ABLE TO MEET
THAT. UM THOSE CHALLENGES THAT
WE HAVE. SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY. I REALLY APPRECIATE
IT EARPHONE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE CHAIR. NEWMAN. THANK YOU
TO YOUR PANELISTS. I THINK WE'VE
HEARD A LOT OF COMMENTS AND
INSIGHTS ABOUT GREATER
COORDINATION AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF THE
FACULTY, REALLY MAKING SURE THAT
WE HAVE THE RESOURCES NECESSARY
TO CLARIFY TRANSFER PATHWAYS TO
REDUCE DUPLICATION. ANOTHER
EFFORTS. I THINK. THE WORK THAT
WE CAN DO TO CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
THE FACULTY COLLABORATION AND
HELP DEVELOPMENT. IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF JOINT ACADEMIC
PROGRAMS TO LAW STUDENTS
TRANSFER SEAMLESSLY AS THE
CRITICAL WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING
HERE. AND MAKE SURE THAT MEANING
THEIR CALLS AND OBJECTIVES. UM
SO I THINK, AS I'VE HEARD ALSO,
I THINK THERE'S SOME
OPPORTUNITIES BUT CHALLENGES
THAT THE SENATE BUT THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE TO REALLY HAVE
GREATER COLLABORATION WITH A
COORDINATING BODY THAT WOULD
HELP REALLY ON THESE TRANSFER
PATHWAYS. WE KNOW THAT WITH THE
PRIOR PRESENTATIONS IN DIFFERENT
REPORTS, SOMETIMES SOON AS
TRANSFER WITH ADDITIONAL 13
EXTRA CREDIT FROM THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO YOUR HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEMS. SO I THINK
WITH THIS AND OR REALLY ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS HE WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE AROUND THIS, BUT I
THINK WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE GREATER COLLABORATION
AMONGST THE FACULTY. THANK YOU.
WELL WE DO HAVE COMMON COURSE
NUMBERING COMING UP THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT A LINING THE COURSES
SO THAT SO THAT THERE'S UH LESS
UNNECESSARY REPETITION WHEN
STUDENTS TRANSFER FROM COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TO A FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTION AND WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AS WELL AH,
WE HAVE MOMENTUM NOW TO GET THIS
WORK DONE. AND I THINK THE TIME
IS NOW TO SUPPORT THIS WORK.
WE'RE MOVING. THANK YOU. ANYBODY
ELSE? THANK YOU. WHAT I'M
HEARING IS YES TO MORE
RESOURCES. TOTAL SKEPTICISM AS
TO THE NEED TO CREATE RECREATE
SEAT BACK AND THAT IS ACTUALLY I
THINK VERY USEFUL BECAUSE YOU
FOLKS MORE THAN ANYBODY IN YOUR
SYSTEMS HAVE THE BEST SENSE OF
DAY TO DAY LIFE IN EACH OF THE
SEGMENTS SAID I DO APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK YOU, EACH
OF YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY. AND
WITH THAT, THANK YOU TO THE
PANEL. THANK YOU TO ALL THE
PANELISTS. LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WANTING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT AS PART OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS.
PLEASE RESHOOT. HI. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. I'M NOT SURE IF THE MIC IS
ON OR YOU'RE ABLE TO HEAR ME.
YES MY NAME IS ELIZABETH BOYD
AND I AM A FACULTY MEMBER AT CAL
STATE. CHICO I'M ALSO THE VICE
CHAIR OF THE ACADEMIC SENATE OF
THE CSU. AND I WANTED TO THANK
YOU FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING
FIRST OFF. AND ALSO JUST TO
COMMENT ON A COUPLE OF THE
POINTS THAT WERE MADE EARLIER BY
BOTH OUR ADMINISTRATIVE PARTNERS
AND OUR SEGMENT PARTNERS. UM,
FIRST OFF THE RESOURCES. OF
COURSE, I'M SURE YOU ALL HEAR
THIS OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN, BUT THOSE SYSTEMS THAT WE
DO ALREADY HAVE IN PLACE FOR
COLLABORATION DO DESPERATELY
NEED THE RESOURCES TO DO THE JOB
. WELL UH, SECOND TO, UM, THE
UNDOING UNINTENDED POTENTIAL
CONSEQUENCES. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT THE CSU IS MOST CONCERNED
ABOUT IS THE SUCCESS OF OUR
STUDENTS. THE RETENTION OF
STUDENTS ONCE THEY COME IN AS
TRANSFERS OR AS 1ST 1ST 1ST YEAR
STUDENTS COMING INTO THE CSU.
MANY OF OUR STUDENTS. AS YOU
KNOW OUR FIRST GENERATION
THEY'RE COMING FROM ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED BACKGROUNDS, AND
WE SPECIFICALLY HAVE CATERED A
PORTION OF OUR GENERAL EDUCATION
TO HELPING THOSE STUDENTS
SUCCEED. UM THIS IS OUR AREA E,
LIFELONG LEARNING COURSE IN OUR
GENERAL EDUCATION BREADTH. AND
THESE COURSES ARE SPECIFICALLY
SET UP TO ENHANCE FINANCIAL
LITERACY TO HELP STUDENTS IN
THEIR FINANCIAL AID AND OTHER
LIFELONG SKILLS THAT THEY MAY
NEED IN THEIR CAREERS GOING
FORWARD AND WE UNINTENTIONALLY
ENDED UP THROUGH THE A B 928
WORK LOSING THOSE OFF OF OUR
UNIFORM TRANSFER. SO I WANTED TO
JUST MENTION THAT BECAUSE ONE OF
THE THINGS IS IF YOU DO GO
FORWARD WITH A COORDINATING
BODY, IT WOULD BE INCREDIBLY
HELPFUL IF WE COULD BE PULLED TO
THE TABLE ALONGSIDE AS PARTNERS
IN THE IN THE AUTHORSHIP OF ANY
SUCH LEGISLATION SO THAT WE
COULD HELP NAVIGATE AROUND THOSE
, AND I JUST WANTED TO OFFER
THAT WERE WILLING AND ABLE TO BE
AT THE TABLE AND VOLUNTEER
SERVICES TO DO THAT. SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU, MR
BOYD. SHOOT DOWN ANYBODY ELSE IN
THE ROOM LIKE TO FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. WELCOME. THANK YOU. I'M
ADAM SWINSON. I'M ALSO A FACULTY
MEMBER WASN'T GOING TO SPEAK.
BUT FORTUNATELY, MY COLLEAGUE
JUST SAID ALL THE THINGS I WAS
GOING TO SAY, UM, TO THE
SENATORS POINT EARLIER. YES WE
HAVE A LOT OF THE SYSTEMS WE
NEED. WE JUST NEED THE RESOURCES
AND YOU KNOW THOSE. IT LIES A
LOT WITH THE FACULTY. WE DO. A
LOT OF THIS WORK ALREADY. OUR
FRIENDS IN THE SYSTEM OFFICES TO
INCREDIBLE AND IMPORTANT WORK
AND A COORDINATING COMMITTEE
COULD HELP. I SUPPOSE THAT THE
SORT OF GENERAL PLANNING LEVEL
BUT I THINK WHAT WE SEE OVER AND
OVER IS A LOT OF UN INTENSIVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. AND
WHAT TERROR VICE CHAIR BOY JUST
MENTIONED IS ONE OF THEM THAT
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THE
NEGOTIATIONS AROUND THE CALGARY
PACKAGE PLAYED OUT, GIVEN THE
DIFFERENT SYSTEMS, SORT OF, UH
SHALL WE SAY AUTHORITIES? WE
ENDED UP NOT HAVING THE STUDENT
SUCCESS PACKAGES ARE COURSES THE
AREA I E IN THE COW GET C
PACKAGE. SO THAT MEANS OUR
TRANSFERS ARE AT LEAST GOING TO
LOSE IT. AND IT'S LOOKING LIKELY
THAT THE CSU IS GOING TO REMOVE
THOSE CLASSES ALTOGETHER. AND
THAT'S AN UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE
THAT YOU KNOW, I DON'T THINK
WELL, I ASSUME IT'S AN
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE, BUT IT'S
PROBLEMATIC AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE WORKING WITH OUR
FRIENDS IN THE SYSTEM OFFICE TO
TRY TO NAVIGATE. UM AND THERE IS
ANOTHER THING TO SAY, OH, I'M
YOU KNOW, FROM THE HUMANITIES,
AND I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WHEN YOU KNOW WE ARE THE
ROLE OF HIGHER EDUCATION IS TO
PREPARE THE WORKFORCE OF
CALIFORNIA. BUT IT'S ALSO THERE
TO YOU KNOW, EDUCATED CITIZENRY
AND WORKFORCE NEEDS CHANGE. AND
AS WE'VE SEEN LATELY, THEY'VE
CHANGED RAPIDLY. I MEAN, AI IS
GOING TO DESTROY A LOT OF LIKE
LOW LEVEL PROGRAMMING JOBS THAT
YOU KNOW STUDENTS IN COMPUTER
SCIENCE. WE'RE GETTING INTO THE
DO THAT CAN ALL BE DONE WITH,
YOU KNOW, GET HUBS COPILOT NOW,
SO THERE'S GOING TO BE MASSIVE
SHIFTS. AND SO WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT WHAT YOU KNOW, HOW TO
PREPARE STUDENTS FOR THE
WORKFORCE. WE DO NEED TO KEEP AN
EYE ON THE SORT OF MORE HOLISTIC
EDUCATION. IN ADDITION TO
PREPARING, YOU KNOW, FOR
TARGETED WORKFORCE AREAS BECAUSE
STUDENTS YOU KNOW GRADUATES ARE
GOING TO MOVE AROUND IN THEIR
LIVES, AND I JUST HOPE THE
COMMITTEE WILL KEEP THAT IN
MIND. SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND SORRY. IT'S JUST A
LITTLE RAMBLING, AND IT WASN'T
REALLY AT ALL. THANK YOU, MR
SWANSON. AND I DO APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENT WITH RESPECT TO THE
HUMANITIES AS A HUMANITIES AS AN
UNDERACHIEVING FORMER HISTORY
MAJOR, BUT POINT WELL POINT WELL
TAKEN DOWN AND WE OFTEN LOSE
SIGHT OF THAT. WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT WORKFORCE ALIGNMENT,
ANYBODY ELSE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO OFFER PUBLIC
COMMENTS SEEING NONE. I WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY WHO PARTICIPATED
IN TODAY'S HEARING. IF YOU ARE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY, PLEASED TO
MAKE YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE IN
THE ASSEMBLY, HIGHER EDUCATION
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITES, LET ME
GIVE OUR MY COACH HERE CHANCE TO
THOSE. THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAIR
NEWMAN AND THANK YOU TO ALL OUR
PANELISTS WHO ALL OUR FELLOW
COLLEAGUES AND EVERYONE WAS
PARTICIPATING TODAY, AS WELL AS
HEARING. WE KNOW THERE'S ALSO
BEEN A LOT OF COMMENTS ABOUT
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION AND WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S PLAN FOR CREW,
TECHNICAL EDUCATION, EMPHASIZING
PARTNERSHIPS AND COLLABORATIONS
AS WELL AND THEN REALLY, WITH
ALL THE SEGMENTS HERE TODAY,
TALKING ABOUT COLLABORATION AND
HOW WE'RE ONLY ONE OF TWO STATES
IN OUR NATION THAT DOES NOT HAVE
A COORDINATING COMMISSION. I
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE
FEEDBACK HERE TODAY AND OTHER
COMMENTS THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
FUTURE ENGAGEMENT AS WELL. AND
WITH THAT, THANK YOU SO MUCH
AGAIN TO EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S HEARING
AND MADE TODAY'S HEARING
POSSIBLE CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU, MR
CHAIR. AGAIN TO ANYBODY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO ADD TO THE RECORD.
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US TO INCLUDE
YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
RECORDS WITH THAT, THANK YOU
AGAIN TO EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION TASTE
HEARING, PARTICULARLY STAFF, AND
WE HAVE NOW CONCLUDED THE AGENDA
FOR TODAY'S HEARING THE JOINT
INFORMATION HEARING ON THE STATE
OF PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION,
COORDINATION AND COLLABORATION
IS HEREBY ADJOURNED.